A GOOD AFTERNOON.
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
WE WILL GET UNDERWAY.
.
LET US PLEASE.
MADAM SECRETARY CAN WE PLEASE
ESTABLISH THE ROLE.
THURMOND HERE FLORA HERE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER RATHER KALRA.
MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
FORMA STUFF.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
IF WE COULD.
GET THAT DOOR CLOSER LIKE TO
MAKE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS FIRST
OF ALL ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO EGGMAN IS
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
A. B. TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN.
WILL BE THIS BOUNCED UPON BY
CONSENT.
ITEM NINE A. B. THIRTY THIRTY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAVALLERO WILL
NOT BE HEARD BY THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY. THE BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED.
AND IN THOSE AMENDMENTS THE
LABOR PROVISIONS OF THAT BILL
HAD BEEN REMOVED SO THAT BILLS
NO LONGER UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND THEN A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE.
I WILL BE HEARD TODAY FOR
TESTIMONY ONLY.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBERS GARCIA.
GABRIELLE AND MATT THIS WILL BE
HEARD BUT IT WILL BE TESTIMONY
ONLY THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE
TAKING A VOTE THE AUTHOR. THE
AUTHORS
HAVE MADE THE DETERMINATION TO.
FLOOR OTHER OPTIONS ARE AMONG
OTHER THINGS.
WHAT THE BILL SEEKS TO DO I CAN
BE DONE WITHOUT LEGISLATION? UP
BUT AT A RESPECT FOR THOSE
WHO'VE COME DISTANCE TODAY TO
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION.
AND WE WILL HEAR FROM THOSE WHO
WISH TO BE HEARD. ARE SO A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL BE
HEARD TESTIMONY.
ONLY DISCUSSION ONLY.
THAT WOULD HAVING SAID THAT WE
WILL BEGIN WITH OUR CALENDAR.
I RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN IS HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN WE
WELCOME YOU.
YEAH.
OKAY. I GOOD AFTERNOON.
EVERYBODY HAVE SHOWED UP.
.
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE IN STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THE TIME AND COMMITMENT IS
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THIS BILL O'DONNELL LOT AROUND
AND PROTECTED WITH A PROTECTION
OF EMPLOYEES.
WHICH IS FANTASTIC AND BRIGHT.
BUT SOMETIMES OR RULES THAT DO
INVESTIGATIONS ARE OUTSIDE OF
THE EMPLOYEE BASE SOME OF THESE
ROLES MIGHT BE PATIENT RIGHTS
ADVOCATES. ADVOCATES FOR FOSTER
CHILDREN POLICE.
AUDITOR'S ALL OF THESE ROLES
THEY PROTECT BOTTLE POPULATIONS
BUT THEY THEMSELVES DON'T HAVE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTION.
SO THAT IS WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS TO THE EXTENT WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS.
TO THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE NON
EMPLOYEES CONTRACTED EMPLOYEES
WHO ARE WORKING TO PROTECT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE AND DO
INVESTIGATIONS AND PROVIDES A
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS TO
THEM AS WELL AND I HAVE
WITNESSES WITH ME HERE. IN
SUPPORT.
PLEASE CAN WE KEEP IT A TWO
MINUTES PER WITNESS THINKING.
THANK YOU THE CHAIR AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN. MY NAME IS SAMUEL JAN
AND I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES.
.
WE ARE THE PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION FOR COUNTY PATIENTS
RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND WE ARE CO
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTEEN.
STATE LAW REQUIRES THAT EVERY
COUNTY HAVE A DESIGNATED
PATIENTS RIGHTS OFFICE.
TO.
RECEIVING INVESTIGATE
COMPLAINTS OF ALLEGED PATIENTS
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND MONITOR
LOCKED PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH PATIENTS
RIGHTS LAWS.
OUR WORK IS CRITICAL TO
IMPROVING CONDITIONS IN QUALITY
OF CARE WITHIN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM.
HOWEVER OUR PROFESSION HAS BEEN
PLAGUED WITH INSTANCES OF
RETALIATION RESULTING IN FEAR
AMONGST ADVOCATES
THAT THEY MAY LOSE THEIR
POSITION FOR FULLY CONDUCTING
THEIR STATUTORY DUTIES.
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY PERCENT OF
PATIENTS RIGHTS ADVOCATES ARE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR
EMPLOYEES OF A CONTRACTED
ORGANIZATION.
UNLIKE COUNTY EMPLOYEES THESE
CONTRACTED ADVOCATES DO NOT HAVE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS.
OUR DUTIES MAY REQUIRE US TO
INFORM STATE LICENSING ABOUT
SERIOUS PATIENTS RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS AT A COUNTY FACILITY
WHICH ARE COUNTY MAY FROWN UPON.
ADVOCATES HAVE HAD THEIR
CONTRACT NOT RENEWED IN THE
CONTEXT OF FORWARDING A PATIENT
COMPLAINT TO LICENSING.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN WOULD
EXTEND ALREADY EXISTING
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS FOR
EMPLOYEES TO CONTRACTORS IN A
WATCHDOG ROLE. THESE WOULD APPLY
TO OTHER CONTRACTED
ORGANIZATIONS RECEIVING
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS
INCLUDING THOSE WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES FOSTER CHILDREN ARE
ELDERLY AND INDEPENDENT POLICE
AUDITOR PROGRAMS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO ENSURE
THE PROFESSIONS PROTECTING OUR
MOST VULNERABLE ARE ABLE TO
CONDUCT THEIR JOB WITHOUT FEAR
FOR IT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WITNESS.
I THINK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
CHAIRPERSON AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN. I MY
NAME IS JUSTIN BUS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLANNING
COUNCIL. I AM THE STAFF MEMBER
FOR THE PATIENT RIGHTS COMMITTEE
I WHICH IS MANDATED IN WELFARE
INSTITUTIONS CODE AND IS TASKED
WITH ADVISING ON POLICIES AND
PRACTICES THAT AFFECT PATIENT
RIGHTS IN THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM.
LAST YEAR THE PATIENT RIGHTS
COMMITTEE CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF
COUNTY PATIENT RIGHTS ADVOCATES
WITH OVER FIFTY PERCENT RESPONSE
RATE.
I COMPLETED MOST OF THAT
ANALYSIS OF THE SURVEY DATA.
WE FOUND THAT NEARLY ONE FIFTH
OF INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
EMPLOYEES OF CONTRACTED
ORGANIZATIONS.
REPORTED THAT CONCERN OVER
LOSING THEIR CONTRACT AFFECTS
HOW STRONGLY THEY ADVOCATE
AGAINST PRACTICES AND POLICIES
THAT THEY BELIEVE VIOLATE THEIR
CLIENT'S RIGHTS.
WE ARE VERY STRONGLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS.
ONE SURVEY RESPONDENTS STATED.
THERE IS NO AUTONOMY OR
PROTECTION FROM ADMINISTRATORS
THAT MAY SEE YOU AS AN ADVERSARY
OR A THORN IN THEIR SIDE.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR CAN
CHOOSE TO DIVERT OR SILENCE THE
EFFORTS OF AN ADVOCATE AT
ANYTIME.
ALL OF US ARE SUBJECT TO UNCHECK
REPERCUSSIONS IF WE RUFFLE THE
WRONG FEATHERS.
RECENTLY THERE WERE TWO PENSION
RIGHTS ADVOCATES WHOSE CONTRACTS
WERE NOT RENEWED IN A NORTHERN
COUNTY.
THIS WAS SUB GOOD SUBSEQUENT TO
A TWO MONTH THE COMMUNICATIONS
BLACKOUT FROM THE LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR.
AFTER AN ADVOCATE REPORTED A
SERIOUS PATIENT RIGHTS
COMPLAINTS.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN WILL
PROVIDE. A LEVEL OF PROTECTION
TO PATIENT RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
OTHER PROFESSIONS IN SIMILAR
WHAT STOCK RULES.
SO THAT THEY WILL NOT HAVE TO
FEAR EMPLOYMENT.
SITE WILL NOT HAVE TO FEAR
EMPLOYMENT RETALIATION FOR
SIMPLY PERFORMING THE REQUIRED
JOB DUTIES.
OF THE COUNCIL SEEKS YOUR
SUPPORT IN THIS IMPORTANT BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
INGRAM ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE A SUPPORT.
C. N. NONE.
A ONE OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
BILL AS A FIRST AND SECOND
REQUEST FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAY WHEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THE CASE HAS BEEN CITY WE CANNOT
SUPPORT.
WELL IF WE DON'T PROTECT THOSE
JOB IS TO PROTECT THEM.%
THREE I'VE.
PERFECT APPRECIATE IT. THAT A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE. BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THURMOND. AYE THURMOND AYE.
FLORA.
FLORA I.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
CONSULT WHICH I JONES SAWYER
KALRA MCCARTY MELENDEZ LENDERS
AYE. BY BILL AND STOP.
GRADUALLY SOME BILLS OUT
THINKING.
SO A MENTALLO PRESENTING AB
THIRTY EIGHTEEN.
MR LOW WHATEVER IT AND THAT YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY EIGHTEEN
INCREASES COMPLIANCE WITH THIS
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
RULED BY IMPROVING PUBLIC
SAFETY.
I WITH THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
WITH ME IS SPEAKING AND SUPPORT
IS CAESAR DS BEHALF OF THE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL.
THANK YOU AYE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS HAS IDEAS ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
WELL I THINK YOUR STAFF AND OF
COURSE OUR AUTHOR WHO WAS
CARRYING A BILL VERY IMPORTANT
BILL. TO INCREASE COMPLIANCE
WITH A SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS FOR
ALTERNATE DELIVERY PROJECTS.
BY PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AS YOU KNOW THIS LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED SEVERAL BILLS TO ARE
AT THE SKILLED INJURING
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS.
WITH.
A. B. THIRTY EIGHTEEN SIX TO DO
WITHOUT BETTER COMPLIANCE WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE CONTRACTOR
COMMUNITY AND PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
IMPROVE THE PROCESS OF THAT ERA
BY COMPLYING THE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE RULES ARE. BUT THAT WE'RE
TARGETING MORE APPRENTICES TO GO
TO THESE PROGRAMSTHAT THEY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA HAS A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE READILY
AVAILABLE TO ACHIEVE THE
PROJECTS WE ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE'S SUPPORT.
THEY WILL ALSO SUPPORT.
SEEN ON ANY OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VICE CHAIR
ACTUALLY SCOTT GOVERNOR PERHAPS
THE CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL NOW WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE PROPONENTS WE AGREE THAT THE
WORK FORCE SHOULD BE SKILLED AND
TRAINED.
WE WANT TO CERTAINLY CLEAN UP
SOME OF THE ITEMS IN THE BILL
THAT WE FIND PROBLEMATIC THEY'VE
BEEN RECEPTIVE WE LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING THOSE CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU.
THEY DO ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
BY OPPOSITION I'M SORRY. YOU
MISTER CHAIR CHAIRMEN PARA
RICHARD MARX AND ON BEHALF THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION THE PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA. SAN DIEGO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS.
FOR IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
WE SUPPORT THE IDEA OF THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
BUT WE REALLY THINK IT IT'S BEEN
A RUSE. SINCE ITS INCEPTION TO
ENCOURAGE THE USE OF PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS WHICH IS WHY
YOU SEE SPRINKLED THROUGHOUT THE
CODE SECTIONS THAT MANDATE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS OR THAT
MANDATE THE SKILLED TRADES
WORKFORCE. THAT THERE ARE
EXCEPTIONS
IF YOU HAVE A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT YOU'RE NOT SUBJECT TO
THE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
A THAT ARE REQUIRED OF EVERY
OTHER CONTRACTOR.
THAT'S THE BILL THAT CREATES THE
KNEW STATUTORY PENALTY FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH THE
SKILLED TRADES WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENT.
CONTRACTORS WORKING UNDER THE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT NEVER
HAVE TO MAKE THE REPORT AND THUS
ARE NEVER SUBJECT TO THE
PENALTIES.
IF THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
TRULY WANT A BILL THAT
ENCOURAGES THE USE OF SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE IT WOULD
APPLY IRRESPECTIVE TO WHETHER
THERE WAS AN EXISTENCE OF A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT OR NOT.
WE'VE ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO
ACCEPT.
AN AMENDMENT THAT STATES THAT
IRRESPECTIVE OF ANY OTHER
PROVISION IN STATE LAW.
A THAT THE PENALTIES THAT ARE
ASSOCIATED INCLUDING THE
DEPARTMENT.
APPLY IRRESPECTIVE TO THE
EXISTENCE OF A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT UNTIL THAT LANGUAGE IS
ADOPTED WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CAN STONE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE SAME
CONCERNS FOR THE.
EXEMPTION IF WE'RE GONNA PYITHU
ONE WE SHOULD APPLY TO ALL THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FOR IT'S IMPORTANT I
WANT TO KNOW THAT OF COURSE WHEN
THERE IS PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
WE ARE GUARANTEED A SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE SO THAT IS THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING THAT.
THANK YOU FOR INSPIRED AND.
LIVED THE BILL.
I THINK THE BILL HAS A FIRST IN
THE SECOND.
IS WHY I'M SORRY MISS MOMENT.
THANK YOU.
SO.
THE PLA'S.
DON'T HAVE TO ABIDE BY THESE
SAME RULES FROM WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT.
IS THERE ANYWHERE IN STATUTE
WHERE IT SAYS PLA'S ARE ALWAYS
GUARANTEED TO HAVE A TRAINED AND
SKILLED WORK WORK FORCE.
SURE. YOU WANT.
THREE QUESTION. OF.
THE STATUES ACTUALLY REQUIRE THE
PLA'S THAT CONTAIN THE SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE PROVISIONS
AS WELL. THE ONLY LIMITATION AS
REGARDS TO APPEAL A IS THAT THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE
AS IF SOMEONE ALREADY MENTIONED
APPEAL A HAS ALL THE REALLY THE
BILL TEN SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS. THAT IS
THAT THE UNION PROGRAMS ALWAYS
PUT THEIR MEMBERS THROUGH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS THE LAST
TYPICALLY THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
NOT OF THAT THE JOURNEY OUT AND
BECOME THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
BY THE DEFINITION OF THE
STATUTE.
WHAT IS NOT HAVING TO DO HERE IS
A REPORTING REQUIREMENT TO THE
PUBLIC A YOU SEE THAT'S THE ONLY
KIND OF THE STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS?
WHY? I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THERE'S A CAR ABOUT THEIR.
THROUGH THE CHAIR UP BECAUSE
IT'S BUILT INTO THE ACTUAL
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT ON THE
WORK FORCE WOULD APPEAL A IS IS
A WORKFORCE AGREEMENT.
AND THE WORK FORCE AGREEMENTS
ALREADY STIPULATED THAT THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED BECAUSE
YOU'RE ACTUALLY HIGH PEOPLE
WATER HIRING HALLS.
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NON UNION
WORKERS IN THE SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS THAT
ACTUALLY DO NOT MEET. THE ACTUAL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS TO BE
INCLUDED IN THAT. THE ESCULENTA
RAIN ONLY GOES UP TO SIXTY
PERCENT SOME OF THE FORTY
PERCENT.
ACTUALLY COULD BE A PERSON
THAT'S EITHER AN APPRENTICE OR A
PERSON THAT HAS A NUMBER OF
YEARS TO HAVE GRADUATED IN THE
INDUSTRY.
STILL CONSIDERED A SKILLED
TRADES PERSON BUT NOT
NECESSARILY MEETING THE
PERCENTAGES OF THE SKELETON
WORKFORCE PROVISIONS FOR THE
STATURE.
.
I GUESS THE ONLY OTHER QUESTION
I WOULD HAVE MR LOW IS. THAT
THERE IS ALREADY A PROVISION IN
THE LAW THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE.
CESSATION CESSATION OF PAYMENT
SHOULD THEY NOT COMPLY WITH THIS
BARREN. THAT.
TRAINED LABOR FORCE
SO AND THAT'S A PRETTY BIG HIT
TO NOT GET YOU PAYMENT FOR YOUR
WORK SO WHY ARE WE ADDING ON
SUCH AS SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL
BURDEN ONTO. ONTO WHAT ALREADY
EXISTS
YES THE VILLAGE THEM INTENSE IS
WITH RESPECT TO THE LEVEL OF
COMPLIANCE AND THAT'S THE
IMPETUS OF THE BILL. AND
ENSURING THAT WE ADDRESS THAT AT
THE HANDS AND SO THAT IS WHAT
THE LEGISLATION ATTEMPTS TO TRY
TO DO AND ADDRESSING AND THE
LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE AND SO
THEY'VE BEEN SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
FOR THE LEVEL OF COMPLIANCE.
.
WHAT WHAT CONCERNS?
SURE SO.
I MEAN GOING ON WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID BASICALLY
THE LEVEL COMPLIANCE AND UNDER
WHAT YOUR QUESTION WAS. THAT
WHEN A CONTRACTORS IN COMPLYING
AND THEY WERE PAYMENT IS
WITHHELD THERE'S A QUESTION OF
WHAT THE PROCESS IS TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THAT CONTRACTOR HOLE.
IT COULD BE A SUB CONTRACTORS
NON COMPLIANT AND THEN FOR FILL
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE SKILLED
AND TRAINED. IN THAT SITUATION A
FAIR PROCESS THROUGH A PENALTY
WHAT ACTUALLY BET ME BETTER THAN
ACTUALLY WITHHOLDING THE
PAYMENTS FROM THAT GENERAL
CONTRACTOR. OR THE SUBCONTRACTOR
AND THEN IT'S AN EITHER OR YOU
EITHER DON'T CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE%
PAYMENT OR YOU CAN FIND URINARY
YOU'RE INNOCENT ATTEMPT TO
CREATE A MORE FAIR PROCESS.
BECAUSE THE WITHHOLDING OF
PAYMENT. WHO KEEPS THE PAYMENT
SHOULD THE GENERAL CONTRACTOR
KEEP THE PAYMENT SHOULD THE
PUBLIC AGENCY KEEP THE PAYMENT
AND IS IT FAIR FOR NONCOMPLIANCE
FOR THERE TO BE A WITHHOLDING OF
THE ENTIRE PAYMENT? AND SO WITH
THIS BILL SEEKS TO DO IS TO
ACTUALLY GET A MORE FAIR PROCESS
BY PUTTING IN A PENALTY INSTEAD
OF A WITH HOLDING ENTIRELY. OF
THE CONTRACTORS WORK.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
OKAY WAS LOW WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
EXTRACT YES RIGHT. THANK YOU.
YEAH. APPRECIATE THE BILL COMING
FORWARD AND THAT.
IT HAS AN AYE RECOMMENDATION
FROM THE CHAIR.
I DO APOLOGIZE I'M ACTUALLY
EMULATE OFFER THE BILL THERE'S A
CUSTOM CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU
AND I ACTUALLY I WANT TO HAVE
ABOUT THIS AS IT RELATES TO SOME
OF OUR DISTRICT THINGS THAT I
WANT TO.
DISCUSS WITH YOU BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO. IMPOSSIBLY SUPPORT
IT ON THE FLOOR.
BUT APPRECIATE YOU BRING THE
BILL FORWARD THANK YOU.
YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
MCCARTY. KALRA AYE MCCARTY
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES KNOW THAT
THERE WAS ON CALL.
BILLS UNCLE THANK YOU YOU.
MS BAKER PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY TWO FROM PERMISSIBLE
MISTER VOEPEL.
THANK YOU.
AB MEMBERS I APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS AB TWO FOUR
EIGHT TWO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN VOEPEL WHO'S ILL
TODAY I'M SORRY TO SAY WELL I
KNOW WE ALL HOPE THAT HE IS WELL
SOON. OF THIS IS LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD EMPOWER AN EMPLOYEE
TO REQUEST AN ALTERNATIVE WORK
SCHEDULE PROVIDING FOR UP TO
FOUR TEN HOUR WORK DAYS WITHIN
THE SAME FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK.
THAT CALIFORNIA HAS A STANDARD
LAW. AND THIS IS BASICALLY TO
PRESERVE PROVIDE THE SAME
FLEXIBILITY FOR A FLEXIBLE WORK
ARRANGEMENTS AYE WITHIN OUR
FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK LAWS AND
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL SHOULD HAVE.
OF THAT MANY OF WHO ARE PART OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING OR EXEMPT
EMPLOYEES HAVE IT IS ABSOLUTELY.
WHERE WE SHOULD BE GOING IN
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW AS YOU KNOW
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW TWO THIRDS
OF EMPLOYEES WITHIN A WORK UNIT
HAVE TO AGREE TO IT I LACKED A
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULE OF UP TO
FOUR TEN HOUR DAYS? WITHIN THE
FORTY HOUR WORK WEEK AND.
THIS IS WE ARE ONE OF THE LAST
THREE STATES IN THE NATION THAT
DOES REQUIRE THIS TYPE OF
PROCESS IN ORDER FOR INDIVIDUAL
EMPLOYEES TO DO THIS. HAVING A
FLEXIBILITY WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL
CAN REACH OUT TO THEIR EMPLOYER
AND ASK
HIM OR HERSELF FOR A MORE
FLEXIBLE WORK ARRANGEMENT IS
WHAT CALIFORNIANS DESERVE IT'S
WHERE OUR ECONOMY IS GOING MORE
FLEXIBILITY. AND I AM PARTICULAR
THINK IT HELPS KNOW THAT IT
HELPS WORKING FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY WOMEN WHO ARE
RETURNING TO THE WORKPLACE AFTER
HAVING CHILDREN THE NUMBER ONE
WAY WE CAN HELP THEM. CONTINUE
ON THEIR CAREER TRAJECTORY AND
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE SAME
COMPETITIVE PAY AND COMPETITIVE
SKILLS AND PROGRESS IN THEIR
CAREER IS IF THEY HAVE MORE
FLEXIBLE SCHEDULES. I AM I KNOW
THIS FIRST HAND BECAUSE WHEN I
HAD ARE TWINS A INSTEAD OF
HAVING A RIGID SCHEDULE I REALLY
WANTED TO SEE IF I CAN HAVE
LONGER DAYS SO I'D HAVE MORE
DAYS WITH MY FAMILY. AND THAT
ALLOWED ME TO BE ABLE TO BE HOME
MORE.
FOR SUSTAINED PERIODS OF TIMES
AS MY CHILDREN WERE YOUNGER IT
MADE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE ON
WHETHER OR NOT I CONTINUE TO DO
MY WORK AND CONTINUE TO MY
CAREER PATH WE SHOULD BE
PRESIDING. PROVIDING THE SAME TO
OTHER CALIFORNIANS IN ADDITION
UP IN JUST VISITING WITH
CONSTITUENTS OF THERE'S THERE'S
OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO SAID TO ME
IF I COULD HAVE THAT ONE DAY A
WEEK LET'S SAY IT'S A FRIDAY
WORK MONDAY THROUGH THURSDAY. OF
FOUR TEN HOUR DAYS THAT FRIDAY
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
REACH MORE BALANCE IN MY LIFE TO
ALL THE ADULT TEAM THINGS WE
NEED TO DO WHY CAN'T CALIFORNIA
MAKE IT EASIER FOR US.
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WAY OUR ECONOMY NEEDS TO GO AND.
I THINK WE NEED TO PROVIDE THAT
BENEFIT TO CALIFORNIANS AND
FINALLY COMING FROM THE BAY AREA
WHERE WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
TRAFFIC IMPACTS THE MORE WE CAN
HAVE MORE FLEXIBLE WORK
SCHEDULES AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE
ON THE ROADS AND IN TRANSIT. AT
DIFFERENT TIMES A DAY THAT ONLY
HAS AN ADVANTAGE FOR ALLOWING
PEOPLE.
TAD EASIER COMMUTES TO GET TO
WORK AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PARTNERS WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
FIVE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TRICIA CILIC THANK YOU FOR
HEARING IT AND I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE. I'M AN HR PROFESSIONAL
ARTISTS AND YOU HEALTH WARNA.
AND I'M ALSO MEMBERS SOCIETY
HUMAN RESOURCE MANAGEMENT SHERM.
WHO HAS OVER TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND A HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE COUNTRIES ALL OVER
THE GLOBE? MORE IMPORTANTLY I'M
STATE DIRECTOR LIKE FOR CAL SURE
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA BODY FOR
THE H. R. PROFESSIONALS OVER
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND INSTEAD OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT I GOT ALL THOSE
STATS OUT LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT
ME AND WHY I'M HERE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I THINK.
IN INCOME BEING AN HR
PROFESSIONAL I'M AN EMPLOYEE FOR
THE EMPLOYER AND I THINK PEOPLE
FORGET THAT ABOUT HR PEOPLE. IT
IS SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE HEAR
EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ONAND
YOU SPOKE ABOUT BALANCED LIFE
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO GO HOME TO
TAKE CARE OF THE CHILDREN WHAT
ABOUT THE PARENTS WE HAVE MANY
EMPLOYEES THAT WOULD LIKE A
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULE SO WE CAN
GO HOME AND TAKE. CARE OF THEIR
PARENTS THAT ARE AGING OR ARE
ILL. AND YOU KNOW I HAVE A
GRANDDAUGHTER THAT'S IN BALLET
AND HOW DO I GO IN TO THAT
BALANCE A YOU KNOW WHAT I'LL BE
BACK IN A COUPLE HOURS.
RIGHT NOW WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
THE FOUR FOUR DAY FORTY HOUR
WORK WEEK PASSED.
IT'S HORRENDOUS WORK IT'S A LOT
OF WORK YOU HAVE TO GET A LOT OF
VOTES GOT ABOUT THINGS GOING
WORD LEADING TOWARDS A MORE
BALANCED WORK LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE NEED THAT LET'S GET SOME OF
THESE CARS OFF THE ROAD LET'S
LET HAVE PEOPLE HAVE FLEXIBILITY
WITH THEIR LACK TO DO SOME OF
THINGS THAT AE IMPORTANT THEM
WHICH IS THEIR FAMILY.
AND WE'RE NOT A LINE THAT
BECAUSE OF HOW LAWS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MARKER THAT
SOME AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR EIGHTY TWO FOR MANY OF THE
REASONS THAT I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAKER MENTIONED. AND AS WELL AS
REPRESENTATIVE FROM SHARM ARE.
AND WHAT A COUPLE THINGS TO KNOW
IS THAT WE ARE ONE OF ONLY THREE
STATES ARE REQUIRED TO DAILY
OVERTIME AFTER EIGHT HOURS
WORKED HOWEVER THE OTHER TWO
STATES ALLOW SIMPLE WEAVER AS
LONG AS THE EMPLOYEE AND THE
EMPLOYER AGREE. THAT IT'S A
SIMPLE WAIVER THAT THE TWO
INDIVIDUALS CONSIGN THEREFORE
THEY CAN ELECT TO HAVE A FOR TEN
WORK SCHEDULE RATHER THAN WHAT
HAPPENS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE DOES
HAVE TO BE. ELECTED BY TWO
THIRDS VOTE ADDITIONALLY THERE
HAS TO BE A FOURTEEN DAY NOTICE
REQUIREMENT AFTERWARDS THERE HAS
TO BE A MEETING SET UP BEFORE
THAT AND HAS TO BE DONE BY. EACH
DEPARTMENT WHICH MEANS THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL PERSON CANNOT ELECT
TO HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE WORKWEEK
SCHEDULE UNLESS THEY'RE THE ONLY
PERSON IN THAT DEPARTMENT AND
THEREFORE YOU WOULD HAVE TO
ACCEPT THE LOBBY ALL OF YOUR CO
WORKERS. IN THAT DEPARTMENT IF
YOU WANTED SAY TO HAVE
WEDNESDAY'S OFF IN ORDER TO PICK
YOUR CHILD UP EVERY DAY FROM A
MINIMUM DAY WHICH IS OFTEN.
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA WITH SCHOOL SYSTEMS
SO THIS WOULD ALLOW THAT
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
EMPLOYEES AND THERE'S A QUOTE
THAT I'VE BEEN HURT THAT I'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN HEARING A LOT FROM
OPPOSITION IN OTHER. BILLS AND
THAT THE WORKFORCE IS CHANGING
BUT THE WORKPLACE IS NOT I THINK
THAT THAT IS REALLY APPLICABLE
HERE WE ARE NOT ALLOWING
FLEXIBILITY IS FOR OUR
EMPLOYEES.
EMPLOYEES CONSULATE COME TO
EMPLOYERS AND ASK FOR MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND THEY'RE HAVING
TO TELL THEM NO BECAUSE AS SOON
AS THEY EXPLAIN TO THEM WHAT THE
PROCESS IS THE EMPLOYEE DOESN'T
WANNA GO THROUGH WITH IT.
THERE'S ONLY TWO POINT THREE
PERCENT OF CALIFORNIANS RIGHT
NOW UTILIZING AN ALTERNATIVE
WORKWEEK SCHEDULE AND THAT
REALLY DOESN'T CHANGE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY AND AGAIN WE
ENCOURAGE AN AIBO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
WE ARE JUST LIKE.
THEY GOT A MINUTE. BE REALLY
QUICK IF I COULD JUST DIRECT YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS TO THE
TEXT OF THE BILL IN SECTION
FOUR.
SUBDIVISION A SAYS THE EMPLOYEE
MUST REQUEST THE SCHEDULE IN
WRITING.
THERE MUST BE A STATEMENT THAT
SHOWS THAT THERE'S AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE WORK IN THE
RATE OF PAY.
A REQUIREMENT THAT TO BE
VOLUNTARY.
THAT THE EMPLOYER IS PROHIBITED
FROM INDUCING A REQUEST OR
THREATENING AN EMPLOYEE. AND
THAT EITHER PARTY CAN
DISCONTINUE THE SCHEDULE AT ANY
TIME AND OF COURSE THERE'S A
CARVE OUT FOR BOTH CBA'S AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SO THERE ARE
NUMEROUS BUILT IN PROTECTIONS
FOR THE EMPLOYEE. IN THIS
PARTICULAR VERSION OF THE BILL
AND I WOULD SIMPLY ASK THE
OPPOSITION WHETHER OR NOT THE
EGREGIOUS EXAMPLES THAT ARE
USUALLY CITED ARE OCCURRING IN
THE OTHER FORTY SEVEN STATES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
SEAN LUIS THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING OVER
TWENTY THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO WOULD LOVE TO PROVIDE
THIS FLEXIBILITY OPTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE. OPPOSITION PLEASE.
MR CHEN MEMBERS AYE KITTEN VEGA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS IS A BILL THAT.
HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP EVERY YEAR
THAT I'VE BEEN HERE WHICH IS
THIRTEEN YEARS NOW.
AND A BILL THAT WE HAVE ALWAYS
OPPOSED.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE THING THAT ALLOWS
PARENTS TO COME HOME TO THEIR
KIDS
AT THE END OF THE DAY IS THE
EIGHT HOUR WORK DAY. THAT IS
WHAT ENSURES THAT THE EMPLOYER
HAS A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO LET
YOU LEAVE.
WHEN WE ASK THAT WORKERS. AND BE
PUT IN A POSITION WHERE THEY
CAN.
WAVE THESE CORE RIGHTS
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT MAKE
THAT A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE.
ONE IS THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF
WORKERS ARE OUT WELL CAN BE
TERMINATED FOR ANY REASON.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS BILL HAS
LANGUAGE IT SAYS THE EMPLOYER
CANNOT AND.
PRESSURE YOU TO DO THIS OR OR I
RETALIATES AGAINST YOU IF YOU
DON'T DO IT BUT IN THE NORMAL
WORKPLACE. THOSE KINDS OF
MESSAGES ARE SENT TO WORKERS ALL
THE TIME IF YOU'RE A TEAM PLAYER
MOST OF US HERE WE WAIVE THE
RIGHT TO DAILY OVERTIME ITS.
FLEXIBILITY THIS IS A GREAT
THING MOST WORKERS DO WHAT THEIR
EMPLOYERS ASK THEM TO DO SUGGEST
THAT THEY SHOULD DO WHAT OTHER
WORKERS SAY HELPS YOU GET AHEAD.
ON OUT THE JOBBER HOPES TO KEEP
THE JOB.
SO WE THINK THAT ALLOW IT
CREATING A SCENARIO WHERE
WORKERS CAN WAVE HE'S VERY QUEER
RIGHTS IS DANGEROUS NOT ONLY
BECAUSE WORKERS HAVE SO FEW
PROTECTIONS. BUT BECAUSE ON THE
FLIP SIDE THERE IS THE THE
POTENTIAL FOR HUGE FINANCIAL
SAVINGS FOR THE EMPLOYER SO WHEN
YOU HAVE THAT IMBALANCE YOU HAVE
HUGE. ARE INCENTIVES FOR THE
EMPLOYER TO TRY TO CUT. UM'S THE
COSTS
BY GETTING WORKERS TO WAVE DAILY
OVERTIME AND YOU HAVE WORKERS
WHO FEAR LOSING THEIR JOBS SO
THOSE ARE CONCERNS AROUND THE
KIND OF VOLUNTARINESS WE DON'T
THINK. MOST THINGS CAN BE DONE
VOLUNTARILY IN THAT SETTING.
BEYOND THAT HERE'S THE OTHER
PIECE THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FIRST OF ALL NOTHING
IN THIS BILL AND NOTHING IN ANY
OF THE BILLS THAT HAS EVER BEEN
INTRODUCED. HAS EVER GIVEN
WORKERS THE CHOICE TO GET
FLEXIBILITY YOU CAN ASK BUT IT'S
THE EMPLOYER'S DECISION WHETHER
OR NOT THEY GRANT THAT. SO
OFTENTIMES THESE BILLS ARE
TALKED ABOUT AS GIVING SOME KIND
OF FLEXIBILITY THAT THEY DON'T
ACTUALLY GIVE IT IS THE
EMPLOYER'S CHOICE.
RIGHT NOW UNDER EXISTING LAW
THERE ARE NUMEROUS WAYS TO HAVE
FLEXIBILITY. THERE IS AN
ALTERNATIVE WORKWEEK COLLECTION
MORE THAN FORTY THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS HAVE.
FOLLOWED THE RULES AND ADOPTED
THESE ALTERNATE WORK WEEK
ELECTIONS
WE HAVE WORKED WITH EMPLOYERS
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR TO
MAKE THAT PROCESS EASIER.
ACTUALLY THE THE ALTERNATIVE
WORKWEEK ELECTION NOW AT THIS
POINT YOU DON'T HAVE TO PRESSURE
OTHER WORKERS TO ALLOW YOU TO
GET WEDNESDAY'S OFF THE EMPLOYER
CAN ALLOW A MENU OF OPTIONS. IN
THE ELECTION THEY CAN SAY
WORKERS CAN OPT FOR FIVE FIVE
EIGHTHS THEY CAN OPT FOR FOR
TENS BIG OFFER THAT MENU AND
THEY CAN CHOOSE. HOW MANY
WORKERS ARE ON EACH SCHEDULE SO
EVERY PIECE OF IT IS CONTROLLED
BY THE EMPLOYER AND THEY CAN
INJECT FLEXIBILITY? INTO EVERY
PIECE.
CURRENTLAW ALSO ALLOWS MAKE UP
TIME IF MY KID GETS OFF EARLY ON
WEDNESDAY. IKE RIGHT NOW UNDER
CURRENT LAW LEAVE EARLY ON
WEDNESDAY WORKING ADDITIONAL OUR
THURSDAY AND DO NOT ACCRUE
OVERTIME.
FOR THOSE REASONS WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE'S OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS
LONGSHOREMEN EIGHTEEN YEAR UNITE
HERE I OF P. T. E. LOCAL TWENTY
ONE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIAN OPPOSITION THEY GET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING CARB ALTERNATIVE
STRATEGY GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DOMESTIC WORKERS
COALITION ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION VERY
CURIOUS YA ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS.
BUT WHEN US.
I'M JUST WONDERING MISS BAKER
IF YOUR WITNESS WOULD SUIT YOUR
MAJOR PROFESSIONAL IN YOUR HERE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IF OU
COULD PERHAPS I COMMENT ON SOME
OF THE CLAIMS OF THE OPPOSITION
MADE.
SURE SO. EASY ELECTION HAVE ANY
OF US EVER VOTE ONE OF THOSE ARE
SEEN ONE OF THOSE THAT'S IT'S
JUST NOT EASY. AND WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH THE WORKPLACE
YOU'RE TRYING TO BALANCE WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE AND AGAIN. I'M
AN EMPLOYEE AS WELL SO I'M
LOOKING OUT FOR ALL OF US
INCLUDING MYSELF.
TRYING TO DO AN ELECTION IN
GETTING THINGS DONE WITH SO MUCH
AS I NEED TO DO THIS ON FRIDAY
IS NOT THAT EASY OR I NEED TO DO
THIS FOR THE NEXT SIX WEEKS
BECAUSE. MY MOM HAS EARLY SIGNS
OF ALZHEIMER'S.
HOW DO YOU BALANCE THAT I'M
SORRY WE NEED TO DO ELECTION WE
NEED TO WAIT THIRTY DAYS IN
FORTY DAYS AFTER THAT WE WILL
THE AND THEN? AND THEY'RE GOING
TO SAY WELL MY MOM TALKING TO
MAKE THAT LAW SO IT'S NOT THAT
EASY IT'S ABOUT GIVING THE
FLEXIBILITY AT THE TIME THAT IS
NEEDED FOR THE EMPLOYEE.
INCLUDING MYSELF.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHEN.
I I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
OBVIOUSLY I I FEEL LIKE.
EMPLOYERS HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN A
OF FOR THOSE.
.
I'M SURE THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF BENEVOLENT. EMPLOYERS THEY
CAN CURRENTLY OF BE FLEXIBLE
WITH HOURLY WORKERS BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS PEOPLE WHO ARE IN HOURLY
JOBS NOT SALARIED. AND THEY CAN
GIVE THEM OVER TIME.
.
FOR WORKING TEN HOURS IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY WORK AND THEY CAN GIVE
THEM TIME OFF TO GO TO THEIR
FAMILY THE TRUTH IS THAT'S NOT
EASY TO SECURE FROM AN EMPLOYER
PERIOD. THE EMPLOYER COULD BE
NEUTRAL ON THE VERY HARD AS YOU
SAID HAVE YOU EVER SEEN IT ED
EASY ELECTION WE SHOULD TRY
UNIONIZATION ELECTION BUT YOU
KNOW AS AN EMPLOYER HAS BEEN
EVELYN WHO WANTS TO WORK WITH.
THEIR THEIR EMPLOYEES WHO CARE
SO MUCH ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES
COULD BE NEUTRAL IN A
UNIONIZING.
ELECTION IT IF THEY SO CHOSE IN
FACT THEY COULD DO CARD
TECHNICALITY I'M SO THERE ARE A
LOT OF WAYS I THINK IF YOU HAVE.
THE EASE EMPLOYERS IN THESE
MANAGERS WHO WANT TO DO BEST BY
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND LET'S NOT
FORGET WHO ARE TALKING ABOUT WE
TALK ABOUT HOURLY WORKERS THE
MOM WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHO.
WAS AN ATTORNEY AT A LAW FIRM
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HOURLY
WORKERS WHO I NEED PROTECTIONS
WHO I AM ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE
WHEN ANY OF THESE CONVERSATIONS
HAPPEN WITH OUR BOSSES. AND SO I
APPLAUD ALL OF THOSE EMPLOYERS
WHO HAVE WORKED WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO INSURE WHETHER IT'S
BY THE ELECTION WHETHER IT'S BY
ALLOWING FOR UNIONIZATION
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE OR WHETHER
IT'S BY ACTUALLY PROVIDING OVER
TIME WHEN YOU GO BEYOND THE
DAYS.
AT EIGHT HOURS TO DO THAT I'M
PROUD TO BE ONE OF THE FEW
STATES IT'S STILL HONOR THE
EIGHT HOUR DAY AND I'M SORRY MEN
HAVE TO BE VOTING NO TODAY.
COLOR THINKING.
THANK YOU WAS SURE.
AND YOU KNOW I. THAT EIGHT HOUR.
FORTY HOUR A WEEK.
THE WORK WEEK AND EIGHT HOUR
WORK DAY. IS ON THE WAS FOUGHT
FOR.
VIGOROUSLY PEOPLE DIED.
BECAUSE THE WORK CONDITIONS
THERE ARE PUT UNDER.
AND SO YOU KNOW THE THE LABOR
MOVEMENT THAT BOB FOR THE
WEEKEND TO A IT WAS A STRUGGLE
THAT I THINK THAT OFTENTIMES.
WE TAKE FOR GRANTED BECAUSE WE
AND HOW TO DO THE STRUGGLE TO
GET THERE IT'S BEEN A MATTER OF
FACT. THERE'S A REASON WHY IT'S
A MATTER OF FACT IT IS SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GO HOME TO THEIR
CHILDREN.
AFTER WORKING FOR EIGHT HOURS
AND IT TOOK KEPT LONGER THAN
THEY GET PAID FOR THAT.
THE REALITY IS THAT THERE IS AN
IMBALANCE AND THE POWER BETWEEN
EMPLOYER AND THAT WILL EMPLOYEE.
AND A TO SUGGEST OTHERWISE IS
JUST NOT BEEN AS IT'S JUST NOT
REALITY. AND FOR ANY SITUATION
SOMEWHAT HAS MEDICAL EMERGENCIES
WE'LL HAVE YOU OUT IS ABSOLUTELY
SUMMER SICKLY BICU GIVE HOW
MUCH VACATION HOURS INDICATION
DAYS YOU GIVE A YEAR.
SO MANY OF THOSE EMPLOY
EMPLOYERS DON'T GET HARDLY ANY
IF AT ALL.
I AND YOU CAN SAY IT'S VOLUNTARY
BUT THEN OF THE DAY IF YOU ARE
THREE EMPLOYEES ARE GOING TO GO
TO THE FORTY HOUR. FOUR DAY WORK
WEEK AND YOU'RE THE ONE THAT
DOESN'T. AND YOU'RE OUT WELL HOW
MUCH LONGER YOU GONNA BE THERE.
I'M NOT VERY LONG AND I WOULD
ALSO SUGGEST THAT THOSE THAT
WORK.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT IT NOW
ESPECIALLY IN RECENT YEARS IN
THIS REALLY BOTHERS ME. AS
ALTHOUGH OF LOW WAGE WORKERS OUR
THAT ARE REQUIRED THE EITHER
TEKELI OPTIONAL BUT THEY WORK TO
THE HOLIDAYS AND THEY WORK ON
BLACK FRIDAY THEY WORK ON THE
THANKSGIVING DAY MAY BE
COMPENSATED FOR IT. BUT THE END
OF THE DAY THAT SPEAKS TO THE
IMBALANCE IN THE POWER. THAT THE
WORKER HAS WITH THE EMPLOYER AND
I REALLY HOPE THAT EMPLOYERS AT
THEIR TRULY SINCERE. AND CARE
ABOUT FLEXIBILITY FOR THEIR
WORKERS WOULD CONSIDER GETTING
MORE SICK DAYS MORE VACATION
DAYS AND THAT IF THEY DID HAVE A
LOVED ONE THAT WAS SICK.
AND HAD THE LEAD TO TEND TO
THEM THAT THEY WOULDN'T
TERMINATE THEM BECAUSE OF THEIR
ABSENCES AT WORK BECAUSE THEY'RE
DOING IT FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
THEIR FAMILY IN THE COMMUNITY.
JUST FOR A QUICK COMMENT AND
THIS IS NOT ELIMINATE THE EIGHT
HOUR WORK DAY AND OVERTIME
REQUIREMENTS IT SIMPLY PROVIDES
AN EXCEPTION ON AN
INDIVIDUALIZED BASIS FOR AN
EMPLOYEE THAT WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT.
FLEXIBILITY AND IT DOES NOT
ELIMINATE ON AN OVERALL BASIS
THE EIGHT HOUR WORKDAY THINK
YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTION WAS
COMMITTEE.
SPEAKER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE YES
PLEASE THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THEY HAVE THE COMMENTARY AND
THAT THAT COMMENTS IN THIS.
I'D DO UNDERSCORE DOES NOT
ELIMINATE THE A EIGHT HOUR WORK
DAY OR FACT SICK LEAVE OR ANY OF
THE OTHER STATUTES THAT ARE IN
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH ARE.
WHICH ARE MANY TO PROTECT THAT
WILL EMPLOYEES FROM WRONGFUL
TERMINATION FROM WORKPLACE
DISCRIMINATION WE HAVE VERY.
EMPLOYEE FAVORABLE LAWS IN THAT
REGARD.
WE'VE HEARD AT SOME
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE VERY MUCH
AT A LEVEL OF WHAT I DON'T THINK
IS AT ISSUE IN THIS BILL I'M
REALLY AM THINKING OF THAT.
THAT MOM IT'S GOING BACK TO
WORK.
AFTER HAVING KIDS WHO NOW IS
GOING BACK TO EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION WHERE SHE ALREADY
FEELS A LITTLE BIT LIKE SHE'S
GOING TO BE BURDENING HER
COLLEAGUES.
BECAUSE SHE'S GOING TO NEED MORE
TIME OFTEN NEEDS THIS WORKPLACE
SO NOW SHE'S GOT TO GO TO THEM.
AND SHE HAS TO LOBBY THEM.
AND I DON'T DIDN'T JUST
EXPERIENCES AS AN ATTORNEY WHO
DID NOT GO BACK AS AN EXEMPT
EMPLOYEE AFTER I HAD KIDS.
I KNOW MY GOOD COLLEAGUE ISN'T
IN THE ROOM TO HEAR THAT BUT
THAT WAS NOT THE CASE IN WHICH I
WENT BACK TO WORK AND HAVE THIS
FLEXIBLE SCHEDULE. IT WAS DURING
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
TIME WHEN THE LAWYERS ARE BEING
SHED FROM LAW FIRMS AND I'D BE
LUCKY TO BE ABLE TO GET A JOB AT
A LAW FIRM. BUT I'M THINKING OF
THAT MOM HE'S GOING BACK TO THE
EMPLOYEE THE VERY THE VERY
EMPLOYEES I REPRESENTED AS AN
ATTORNEY FOR EMPLOYERS WHO
WANTED TO TAKE CARE OF THEM.
SHE'S GONNA BE GOING ALSO HER
COLLEAGUES TO TRY TO CONVINCE
THEM AYE I NEED THIS.
SO THAT I CAN TAKE CARE OF MY
FAMILY I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU
HAVE THE SAME THING BUT CAN WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER FOR THIS AND
GO THROUGH THE SCHEDULE AGAIN
AND AGAIN. AND A WHOLE ELECTION
PROCESS WHICH TO QUOTE THE
OPPOSITION SAID AT EVERY PIECE
OF IT IS CONTROLLED BY THE
EMPLOYER.
THIS BILL PUTS THE POWER WITHIN
THE HANDS OF THE EMPLOYEE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG TIME IN
CALIFORNIA LAW. THAT MOM ALREADY
IS GOING TO FEEL LIKE SHE'S GOT
THE BURDEN ON HER AND SHE'S SHE
IS. IMPOSING UPON HER COLLEAGUES
AND ONCE AGAIN NOW SHE'S GOING
TO ASK THEM TO GO THROUGH THIS
PROCESS AND THERE'S MORE THAN
JUST A THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
OF BENEVOLENT EMPLOYEES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THERE
ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
BENEVOLENT EMPLOYEES EX
EMPLOYERS EXCUSE ME WHO'D WHO
WANT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A MUCH
MORE AGILE RESPONSE. TO THAT
EMPLOYEE WHO IS ASKING FOR THIS
FLEXIBILITY AND.
.
I THINK IT IS FOR GETTING THE
THAT THAT WHAT I'M FIGHTING FOR
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEES
IS THE SAME BENEFITS THAT MANY
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
AND EXEMPT EMPLOYEES HAVE IT'S
THE VERY HOURLY EMPLOYEES. WHO
NEEDS THIS FLEXIBILITY AND THE
AGILITY OF HER EMPLOYER TO BE
ABLE TO MEET THE NEEDS WITHOUT
HAVING TO ALREADY GOING TO A
WORKPLACE AND TRY TO NEGOTIATE
WITH COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL PERSONALIZED
SCHEDULE?
AND THAT IS THE WAY OF A MODERN
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
WHAT ARE CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
AND FOR EVERYONE WHO TALKS ABOUT
PAY EQUITY FOR WOMEN WHICH I
HAVE SUPPORTED HISTORIC
LEGISLATION FOR PAY EQUITY. WHEN
THE NUMBER ONE THINGS YOU CAN DO
IS MAKE SURE EVERY SINGLE WOMAN
WHETHER THEY'RE PART OF A UNION
OR NOT. WHETHER THEY'RE EXEMPT
OR NOT OR AN HOURLY EMPLOYEE HAS
THE ABILITY TO GO BACK TO WORK
MORE EASILY TAKE CARE OF HER
FAMILY AND CONTINUE ON HER
CAREER CALIFORNIA MAKES THAT
HARDER THIS BILL MAKES IT EASIER
EASIER I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THE US BAKER.
HOW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL?
I'M SORRY THIS I DO HAVE TO
MAKE.
THE HAS A POST ON THE CHAIR AND
I WOULD HAVE WE SUPPORTIG IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN.
FLORA FLORA AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KNOW KALRA UNKNOWN MCCARTY
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S I.
THE BILL'S UNCLE THINK YOU THINK
YOU.
AND ON BEHALF OF MR OF OF VOEPEL
THINK AS WELL.
MISS CARILLO PRESENTING AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT.
READY WHEN YOU ARE
.
IT DOESN'T MEAN AND ONE WITNESS
TO COME IN.
WE GOT ALL DAY.
PACKED OUTSIDE.
IT'S
.
SO. SCREW WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
PERSON PRESENTING IN THIS
COMMITTEE.
DIFFERENT TYPE OF ROOM IT'S THE
BEST COMMITTEE.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY EIGHT.
A BILL THAT WOULD STRAIN OUR
EFFORTS AND AND DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT ALL STATE
CONSTRUCTION TRADE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THE CONTROL THE CONSTRUCTION
FIELD OFFERS GOOD PAY RETIREMENT
PLAN HEALTHCARE BENEFITS HOWEVER
IT'S THE FIELD AND BENEFITS THAT
MOSTLY DOMINATED BY MEN.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA WOMEN.
MAKE UP ONLY ABOUT TWO POINT
FOUR PERCENT A BUILDING TRADES
APPRENTICE.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ARE THE DE
AYE ARE. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SIX APPRENTICESHIPS.
BUT ONLY ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE OF THEM
WERE LED BY WOMEN.
THIS BILL WILL FACILITATE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECRUIT AND
RETAIN MORE WOMEN OF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AS WELL
AS OFFER THEM A WELL PAYING JOB.
THIS BILL BROADENS THE AUTHORITY
OF THE DIR TO OVERSEEING
NONDISCRIMINATION EFFORTS AND
ENSURE GREATER PROTECTION FOR
WOMEN AGAINST HARASSMENT.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY A WILL
ALLOW APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO
INTERVENE TO STOP HARASSMENT OR
EVEN DISCONTINUE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH EMPLOYERS WHO DO NOT COMPLY
WITH THESE NEW POLICIES.
AS A RESULT THIS BILL WILL
ENCOURAGE MORE WOMEN TO PURSUE
CAREERS IN CONSTRUCTION BY
HELPING THEM FEEL SAFE AND
PROTECTED. WHILE DOING THEIR
JOB.
IN SOLIDARITY WITH SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TODAY IS DONE ON DAY.
IT'S A DAY THAT ACTUALLY
ACKNOWLEDGES RAPE.
AND SEXUAL ASSAULTS AGAINST
WOMEN.
WELL WEARING JEANS. MOST OF US
ARE.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
FOSTERS GREATER REPRESENTATION
BY WOMEN OF WOMEN BY
FACILITATING INCREASED GENDER
DIVERSITY AMONG THE CONSTRUCTION
PROFESSIONALISM AND JOB SITES.
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IZZY'S
IDEA IF THE LEGISLATIVE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR. WHO'S IN THE
BACK.
AND DEBORAH CHAPLAIN DIRECTOR OF
SPECIAL PROGRAMS OF STATE OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL.
AND SELENA DERAIL OF CARPENTERS
LOCAL ONE FIVE TWO WITH HER OWN
PERSONAL TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE KEEP
AWARENESS IS A TWO MINUTES A
PIECE WOULD APPRECIATE IT. THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MY NAME IS
DEBORAH CHAPLAIN AND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL.
AND FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS I
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH WOMEN
IN THE TRADES AROUND THE STATE
ORGANIZING OUR OF ANNUAL
NATIONAL CUP OUR ANNUAL
STATEWIDE AND THEY BECAME
NATIONAL CONFERENCES.
WE KNOW THAT EVEN AFTER YEARS
OF REALLY HARD WORK BY TRADE
SUMMIT ORGANIZATIONS. AND
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO
RECRUIT MORE WOMEN THE NUMBER IS
STILL VERY LOW AS THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SAID ONLY A TWO TO THREE
PERCENT ARE WOMEN.
WORKING WITH THE TOOLS.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
DISCRIMINATION AND CONSTRUCTION
ARE UNFORTUNATELY STILL REAL.
PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
EIGHT WILL GO FAR LETTING WOMEN
KNOW THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
BE TRADED TREATED FAIRLY. AND
WITH DIGNITY ON THE CONSTRUCTION
WORK SIDE THIS WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY SUPPORT OUR
EFFORTS TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN
WOMEN IN THE TRADES SO THAT WE
CAN FINALLY BRING UP THAT
PERCENTAGE. AND REACH A CRITICAL
MASS.
THIS BILL DOES TWO REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS THE FIRST
IS THAT PRECIOUS APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS MUST PROVIDE TRAINING
TO ALL OF THEIR PARTICIPANTS IN
INSTRUCTORS ON PREVENTING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND DISCRIMINATION.
THIS TRAINING IS ALREADY BEEN
CALLED FOR IN A.
TWENTY NINE CFR THIRTY OF THE
FEDERAL APPRENTICESHIP
GUIDELINES THAT WERE IMPLEMENTED
LAST YEAR THIS BILL MANDATES AT
THIS TRAINING INC IT BECOMES
PART OF CALIFORNIA AS WELL.
GIVEN THE WHIMS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS TRAINING WILL BE
PART OF THE CURRICULUM IN CASE
THE FEDS BACK OFF.
SECONDLY AB TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT ADDS AN
IMPORTANT FUNCTION IF AN
APPRENTICE INFORMS HER PROGRAM
ABOUT HAVING TO DEAL WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR DISCRIMINATION ON
THE JOB SITE. THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM IS EMPOWERED TO ACT IN
HER DEFENSE AND MAY REFUSE TO
SEND APPRENTICES TO THAT
PARTICULAR JOB SITE UNTIL THE
PROBLEM IS DEALT WITH.
WE'VE DONE SURVEYS WE KNOW THAT
WOMEN VIEW THEIR APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS AS A SAFE PLACE WHERE
WOMEN CAN BE COMFORTABLE AND
RESPECTED. NOT SO MUCH OUT AT
THE WORK SITE.
WITH THIS BILL WOMAN WILL KNOW
THAT THE REACH OF THEIR
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM IS
EXTENDED TO KEEP THEM SAFE OUT
ON THE JOB SITE AS WELL.
SO.
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO FOR SPONSORING THIS BILL
AND WE URGE YOU TO PASS AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT. AND
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR THIS
BILL WITH TRADES WOMAN INK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
X. WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SELENA DERAIL I AM A UNION
CARPENTER OUT OF. OF MANTECA
LOCAL ONE FIFTY TWO.
I PERSONALLY HAVE EXPERIENCED
HARASSMENT AND.
DISCRIMINATION ON A WORK SITE
BUT I'M ACTUALLY HERE TODAY TO
TELL THE STORY OF HOW THE HICKS.
LIKE ME AUDI HICKS WAS IN A A
CARPENTER APPRENTICES
SHE WAS OUT OF VOTE LOCAL.
FRESNO OFFICE.
I WAS IN OVER FOUR YEARS SHE
WAS IN FOR JUST ABOUT NINE
MONTHS.
AUDI IT'S BEEN SOMETIME IN
PRISON.
AND SHE FINALLY FELTTHAT SHE
WAS GETTING HER LIFE TOGETHER.
AND SHE HAD A GOOD UNION JOB SHE
WAS ABLE TO.
SHE WAS SHE WAS GOING TO RAISE
HER SCIENCE I WITH THIS A GREAT
PREVAILING WAGE JOB.
AND SHE WAS ON HER WAY. SHE WAS
GOING TO IN A BRITISH
APPRENTICESHIP SCHOOL. AND
WORKING FOR A SCAFFOLDING
COMPANY.
ON THAT JOB THERE WAS A YOUNG
MAN.
AT THE JOB SITE WHO'S
CONSTANTLY.
GIVING HER A HARD TIME.
HE WAS KNOWN AS. A GUARD DOG.
THERE WAS A RUMOR THAT THE OUR
DOG WAS MAD AT AUDI.
HE WAS MAD THAT SHE WAS MAKING
MORE MONEY. ALSO THAT SHE WAS A
BLACK WOMAN.
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHY BUT.
AT THE END OF HER WORK DAY ON
VALENTINE'S DAY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
THEY GOT INTO AN ALTERCATION AND
ARGUMENT.
AND HE.
HE ASSAULTED HER WHICH RESULTED
IN HER DEATH.
ON THE JOB SITE.
WHILE SHE HAD.
.
WHILE SHE HAD COMPLAINED TO HER
EMPLOYER ABOUT HIM.
HER APPRENTICESHIP DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THAT THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
HAD AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE
FIFTY EIGHT BEEN IN PLACE.
AUDI WOULD HAVE HAD THE TRAINING
TO KNOW THAT SHE DID NOT HAVE TO
BE TREATED LIKE THAT FROM A CO
WORKER.
ALSO THAT SHE HAD AN ALLY IN HER
APPRENTICESHIP. PROGRAM
COORDINATOR IN THAT SHE HAD THE
RIGHT.
I CALL ON ON.
THE PREMISE SHIP.
TO REMOVE TO REMOVE HER.
AND TO KEEP HER SAFE AND ANYONE
ELSE FOR THAT MATTER SAY FOR
THAT JOB.
IN THE NAME OF AUDI HICKS IN ALL
THE PREMISE
THE PREMISES OF FEATURE I ADDS
THAT YOU PASS AB TWENTY THREE
FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING SPEAK
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ITS ALWAYS
GREAT TO SEE CONSTITUENTS
TOUCHING HIMSELF WELCOME THANK
YOU BY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME'S MIKE WES AND ON BEHALF
OF THE WOMEN AND MEN OF DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES. AND ESPECIALLY ON
BEHALF OF MADISON HALL WHO ON MY
RECOMMENDATION IS THE FIRST A
DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNCIL IN ONE OF
THREE NATIONWIDE HOUSE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
YOU VERY MUCH.
VERY GOOD YEARS YOU ARE ABOVE
THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIA
MAVERICK AND I AM A. APPRENTICE
CARPENTER FIFTH PERIOD.
A LOCAL SEVEN ONE THREE HEBRON.
WHAT THIS?
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
KITTEN BIG FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PARENTS.
THANK YOU.
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU.
THEY ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I THINK HE SUPPORTED OR EVEN HAS
LAWLER SHE SUPPORTED AS WELL.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR. COMMENTS ON THE
COMMITTEE.
THE FIRST AND SECOND.
HI MYSTERY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I THINK SALINAS TESTIMONY.
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR CASE IS.
.
WHY WE NEED THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THINK?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS ENJOYS
THE SUPPORT RECCO FROM THE CHAIR
AS WELL AS ON THE VICE CHAIR SO.
MATTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN.
FLORA A FLOOR I GONZALEZ
FLETCHER GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA. KALRA IM MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MULLIN IS AYE BUTTONS
ON.
THE BILL IS OUT GRADUATION THANK
YOU.
THINK.
THANK YOU.
FOR.
AND THAT'S WHAT THE RIGHT.
YEAH.
I WANNA MAKE SURE WAS LOOKING.
SO OFTEN WASHES HANDS.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
.
SURE MEMBERS TODAY ON DENIM DAY
THE LEGISLATURE COMES TOGETHER
TO RAISE AWARENESS ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT INTO STAND WITH
SURVIVORS WE WEAR JEANS AND
SOLIDARITY SHOW THAT WHAT YOU
AWARENESS NOT INVITATION FOR
HARASSMENT THAT SAX SEXUAL
ASSAULT. AT ITS CORE IS AN ABUSE
OF POWER.
JANITORIAL WORKERS ARE AMONGST
THE MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS IN
OUR SOCIETY THIS INCREASINGLY
FEMALE WORKFORCE OFTEN WORKS
ALONE AND AT NIGHT.
THIS ISOLATION FROM CO WORKERS
IN THE PUBLIC REDUCES THE
LIKELIHOOD OF HAVING SOMEONE
INTERVENE OR SERVE AS A WITNESS
TO THE RAMP IT. OCCURRENCES OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SALT AND
THAT HAPPEN IN THE WORKPLACE.
IN MANY CASES THESE WORKERS ARE
IMMIGRANT WOMEN OF COLOR WHO DOT
ALWAYS SPEAK ENGLISH FLUENTLY
FURTHER IMPEDING THEIR ABILITY
TO COMMUNICATE THEIR
MISTREATMENT. THESE CONDITIONS
ON TOP OF LOW WAGES LEAVE THEM
EXPOSED TO EXTREME ABUSES ON THE
JOB. WORKERS OFTEN DO NOT KNOW
WHERE TO REPORT ABUSES WHEN THEY
DO HAPPEN AND MANY SUPERVISORS
NOT TRAINED PROPERLY ON HOW TO
RESPOND LEAVING THESE WORKERS
WITH NOWHERE TO TURN. AB TWENTY
SEVENTY NINE WORKS TO CHANGE A
CULTURE OF HARASSMENT FEAR IN
THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY WHICH IS
FAR TOO LONG HAS TURNED APPLY A
BLIND EYE TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULT.
THIS LEGISLATION EMPOWERS
JANITORIAL SERVICE WORKERS BY
UTILIZING EXISTING PEER
COUNSELORS ARE PERMIT TAUGHT US.
TO PROVIDE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
TRAINING TO FELLOW JANITORIAL
WORKERS ON HOW TO PREVENT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING. AND IT'S ON
THE WORKPLACE.
PEER TO PEER COUNSELING THAT HAS
SHOWN TO BE EFFECTIVE TEACHING
TOOL ALLOWING WORKERS TO MORE
CLOSELY RELATE.
WITH THEIR PEER COUNSELOR AS
OPPOSED TO AN OUTSIDE SOURCE OR
AGENCY WHILE ALSO CHIPPING AWAY
AT THE ISOLATION THAT HIS ALLOW
THESE PERPETUAL ABUSES IN THE
WORKPLACE. THIS IS.
A FOLLOW UP TO OUR FIRST WHAT I
CONSIDER FIRST ME TO BUILD. THAT
THAT CAME THROUGH THIS
LEGISLATURE WHEN OUR JANITORS
CAME FORTH AND SAID THEY NEEDED
PROTECTION FROM BEING RAPED ON
THE NIGHT SHIFT BASICALLY. I'M
WE PASSED THAT BILL IN IN THAT
BILL WE HAVE.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THESE
WORKERS ARE GIVEN.
INFORMATION ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS
ABOUT SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT TAKES THE
NEXT STEP IN SAYS WE KNOW THAT
THEY'LL BE IN A BETTER SPOT IF
THEY ARE TAUGHT.
FROM FROM SURVIVORS FROM PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN TRAINED TO TO
COMMUNICATE.
WITH THESE WORKERS AND NOT JUST
SIMPLY FROM AN ATTORNEY OR SOME
SLIDE SHOW THAT ALL OF US.
SEEM TO. WATCH BUT HAVE.
A LESSER EFFECT MAYBE ON ON A
THE OUTCOMES SO.
I HAVE SOME WITNESS HERE STE
HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING THIS TIME
TO TESTIFY. MY NAME IS SANDRA
HENRIQUEZ SOME EMBASSY  WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF AB
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE.
I SEE MANY SIMILARITIES BETWEEN
THE WORK OF THE JANITORIAL
PROMOTE THOUGHT US.
AND THE RAPE CRISIS MOMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. IN THE EARLY
NINETEEN SEVENTIES SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT DECIDED THAT THEY
NEEDED TO TAKE THEIR HEALING.
AND WELL BEING INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS AND THEY SAID ENOUGH.
THEY MOBILIZED ORGANIZED AND
TRAINED THEMSELVES.
FORTY SIX YEARS LATER THE RAPE
CRISIS SAFETY AND IT IS A
PROFESSIONAL EYES MOVEMENT.
WHICH HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL.
STRENGTHENING SYSTEMS
INSTITUTIONS AND HELPING
SURVIVORS TO HEAL.
RIGHT CRISIS ADVOCATES HAVE A
LONG HISTORY OF PEER TRAINING
AND APPEAR RESPONSE.
THEY'VE BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF STANDARDS AND THE
DELIVERY OF TRAINING FOR SERVICE
PROVIDERS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REPRESENTATIVES. AND A VARIETY
OF INSTITUTIONS.
THIS PEER TRAINING MODEL HAS
BEEN TRIED AND TESTED FOR OVER
FORTY YEARS AND HAS SERVED AS
THE CORNERSTONE OF THE STATE'S
RAPE AND SEXUAL ABUSE SAFETY
NET.
RIGHT CRISIS STATUS STRATEGIES
ARE STEEPED IN THE PEER TRAINING
PHILOSOPHY AND MODEL WHICH.
SHARES MANY OF THE KEY TENANTS
OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY SEVENTY
NINE.
PEER TRAINING RECOGNIZES THAT
THOSE AFFECTED BY SEXUAL
VIOLENCE ARE EXPERTS IN THEIR
OWN LIVES AND AS SUCH ARE THE
BEST SUITED TO DEVELOP VICTIM
CENTERED STRATEGIES.
PIERRE TRAINING FACILITATES THE
DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION
BECAUSE TRAINERS ARE OFFICE ARE
OFTEN SEEN AS BEING
APPROACHABLE.
AND ARE RECOGNIZED FOR HAVING
WALKED IN THE OF THEIR OWN
SHOES.
THE THE OTHER PERSON'S SHOES.
PEER EDUCATION HAS BEEN SHOWN TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE THAN OTHER
TYPES OF ADULT LET EDUCATION. IN
TERMS OF CHANGING BEHAVIORS
ATTITUDES AND NORMS.
IN MY THIRTY PLUS YEARS WORKING
IN THIS FIELD I HAVE LEARNED
THAT SEXUAL ASSAULT SURVIVORS
ARE PASSIONATE AND TENACIOUS.
AND IT IS BECAUSE OF THEIR
COMMITMENT THAT WE ARE IN THIS
MOMENT OF ELEVATED VISIBILITY
SURROUND THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
THE ISSUE OF RAPE AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE.
IN THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS I HAVE
WITNESSED THIS GROUP OF WOMEN
FROM THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY.
SINGLE HANDEDLY DEMAND CHANGE IN
THEIR INDUSTRY.
THEY ARE NOT ONLY CAPABLE THEY
ARE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
INDIVIDUALS TO TRANSFORM THE
CULTURE WITHIN THAT INDUSTRY.
THEY ARE THE PIER TRAINERS THAT
ARE NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRAINING ADDRESSES REAL ISSUES.
AS THEY PLAY OUT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THEY ARE THE MOST IMPACTED BY
THE CURRENT CLIMATE AND
THEREFORE MOST INVESTED
INCLUDING A CREATING A WORKPLACE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH THOSE. WHO
SEXUALLY HARASS OR HARM WOMEN
ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE?
IN WHICH JANITORIAL WORKERS KNOW
THEIR RIGHTS AND KNOW HOW TO
ACCESS REMEDIES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
PIERRE TRAINERS ARE BEST SUITED
TO HELP CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH WOMEN FEEL SAFE. GOING TO
WORK ON THE NIGHT SHIFT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS.
I WHEN ASSEMBLY NUMBER IS BUT I
THINK I WANNA.
LEVINE A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS VERONICA AWARENESS SO DANNY
DOT E. THAMMASAT ATTRIBUTED
THEIR BASIC. ITEMIZE THOUGH A
CLASSES THEY SETTLEMENT THAT BUT
ANOTHER LOS ANGELES I AM A
JANITOR I AM ALSO RECEIVING A
TPS AND I AM ALSO CERTIFY TO
GIVE.
CLASSES ON A MENTAL HEALTH IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
I SAID US ANYA'S ESTAMOS TACKY
BILLION THE PUT ON A LINK KILEY
FOR NOT HAVING THIS NEVER
THOUGHT THAT THEY ARE TO.
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO WE'RE HERE
FIGHTING OFF FOR A BI NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT.
LAKE UP BUT THEY HEY THAT'S I
WOULD ALISON HELLO DISTINCT WEB
BY THE NOSE HAS THAT GARCIA WAS
AS EXCITING AND WHETHER THEY
HAVE A HOME. ALLAY THAT PROTECTS
AND GIVES.
WILL HELP TO THOSE WORKERS WHO
WANNA. OUT POWER REPORTS AGAINST
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
AT THE WORKPLACE. ICKY SAYS IBM
EQUIPMENT MAP WHAT ABOUT AT
ANOTHER.
ON SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH THERE WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. BOEING
UNDERTAKEN AND THEY I SALLIED
AND GONE THROUGH ICON THAT MOST
OF THE STUDIES IT WAS A
EXTREMELY BIG FIGHT ON FOR US TO
COME OUT AND. TELL OUR STORIES.
I DON'T BUT A CNC OUT AYE SOME
SILENCE AND TODAY WE ARE HERE
AS EMPOWERED WOMEN.
IN NOT WILLING TO STAY SILENT
ANYMORE.
EVIL HAT IS COMPLEMENT THE
THAT'S GONNA SEE THAT
EGOTISTICAL BUT YET THAT I HOPE.
AND AS WOMEN.
COMMITTED TO OUR WORK AND ALSO
TO OUR FELLOW. COWORKERS.
I WANNA LET HIS FELLOW ENOUGH
PERSON THAT WAS NO PROJECT
DON'T.
BAIT BANG THIS THING MAYBE AND
DAVE THINKS A LOT AND NOW WE ARE
HERE SPONSORING. A NEW PROJECT
WHICH AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE.
ELECTED IN A BUT I MEAN THAT
JANET THAT'S OTV AND.
THE.
EMPOWER MEN OF A CERTAIN.
WOMEN SURVIVORS JANITORIAL WHIMS
WRITERS.
AT THAT PRICE THEN THOSE HAS IT
WAS US IN A
LETTER THAT I. HOW TO FILE?
COMPLAINTS. ABOUT WORKERS
HARASSMENT
THEN I MOST OF WHAT THE WEAPONS
THE FELLAS BUT AT THE MEDICAL
PER ME SO THEY SEND THEM TO ME
AND. WE HAVE THREE BASIC
PRINCIPLES ON HOW WE WANT TO DO
THIS TRAINING. IN MIDDLEBURG
ESTAMOS HEAD OF THIS US AND
LATIN ALSO PUT THEM THAT IS GOOD
TEMAS TEMAS BOSSES AND THAT AND
THEN ON SATURDAY. THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST BECAUSE WE ARE GRATEFUL
THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO RAISE OUR
VOICES AND HAVE BEEN HEARD OF
FROM WESTERN OUR STORES.
THEY WOUND UP AGAINST AMAZ
COMPLEMENT THE THAT'S OF THE
PHONE THE IT AS THE LA. GOING AS
A MOTHERHOOD IS THAT IN THE
CITY.
AND SECOND OF ALL BECAUSE WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ALSO EMPOWERING
OTHER WOMEN IN THE INDUSTRY.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION.
IF THERE SAID ALL PURPOSE I'M
ALSO REALLY GOT US AND THEY SET
UP THEM BAD LUCK WITH BUDDHA
THEY MEET THOSE OR NOT WITH WHAT
I'M A TEASE THAT. BUT AGAIN I
SAYS IN MY THAT THE US IN THE
YES.
AND BECAUSE DIRT OF ALL BECAUSE
WE ARE COMMITTED TO CHANGING
CULTURE AND CHANGING THE CULTURE
OF MACHISMO IN THE WORKPLACES%
WHERE YOU KNOW THESE THINGS ARE.
NOT REPORT.
OUT BUT CAN ALSO TELESERYE AGAIN
THIS IS NOT A CRITICISM
ANALYSTS.
BE QUIET US IN NOT.
THE SURVIVORS AND NOT OUR HUMAN
RESOURCES DEPARTMENTS.
BUT IN THE SOUTHERN US LOGAN
AMASIS AT CLINICS YOUNG INTO A
SET OF HAZARDOUS BUT UP WOULD
YOU GOT AS OAKLAND CIENCIA.
BECAUSE WE ARE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
CONNECTION WITH EVERY SINGLE
WORKER AND TO REALLY REACH THEIR
CONSCIOUSNESS BUCKET GONNA SAMUS
ELAINE THOUGH STEM HER KENNEDY
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE INDUSTRY
BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
BUT GUESS FAMILIES AND THROW
THEIR SUBTLE AT AT THAT OF A
WHOLE EQUAL ASSEMBLY NECK WAS
DUDEK AXES THEY ELI'S BRAHMA
SIXTIES THAT'S.
BECAUSE WE ARE IN THAT.
WORK INDUSTRY AND WE KNOW.
HOW YOU KNOW EVEN SEXIST JOKES
CAN CAN AFFECT OUR WORKPLACE
I SAID ONE AND I REALIZE THAT I
HAVE SO LESSEN OF THE IN THE
THESIS IT BALEARIC ACCORD EMMA
SAYS HELLO TO THEM NOT TO A
MOTHER RATHER THAN ABOUT? AND WE
KNOW THAT FEAR AND AND.
.
THAT WE SUFFER YOU KNOW HAD WITH
WORKING ALONE AT NIGHT. AND IN
LEAVING WORK VERY LATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY APPRECIATED VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I THINK IT WAS SHARED MEMBERS
TROSZYN ROUND OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS HERE
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH ALL
THE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
URGING AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RENE BAYARDO SL YOU
CALIFORNIA RESPONSE THE BILL AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
PAT AND I NAME IS CARMEN SAN
THOUGH I'M SUPPORT THAT BILL A.
B. TO ANY SEVENTY NINE.
WHEN NUMBER MY HAVE ASKED HAS
BEEN GOOD TO FINALLY SEE UP WE
ALUMNI BANG BANG AVE THAT MAKE
THEM THAT WAY.
WELL THAT THE REMAINING THESE
MONEY OUT THEMES AYE COMING FROM
LA I'M SUPPORT THEY A. B. A. B..
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK VERY MUCH MY FAMILY HE
ABNORMAL BODY SO THEY DIDN'T UP
OR YOU'RE LIFE OBVIATING DAYS
THAT THEN THEY NINE.
MANY I WON SALAS PALOMO TAUGHT
US WHATEVER EVN THAT YEAH OR
YOU'RE NOT AYE THIS IT BANK THIS
AT THAT POINT WHEN THEY GET OUT.
BREAK A AS YOU ARE THE
CALIFORNIANS WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
CAITLYN VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION OTHMAN SUPPORT.
MATT BROWN WITH THE TEAMSTERS
EIGHTY YEAR MACHINISTS I'LL W.
AND SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MIKE AT THROUGH HE
YOU KNOW AND I AM SUPPORT.
A. B..
TWENTY SEVENTY NINE.
BUT IF OUT OF THE SCHOOL BUT I'M
GONNA MISS THAT IS BOUND CLOSELY
AGAIN THE GLORIA FOR YOU LET A
LOT IT IS ADVANCE IT THEN THEY
KNOW.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MARILYN RUBIO IN
THEM.
SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY SEVEN AND I.
WELL I MEAN I'M GONNA LEAVE HIM
UP THE MESS YOU UP OR YOU KNOW
AVE. MAKE THIS A THAT THEY
NEVER.
ON I WANNA STAND DIDN'T NUMBER
LET THE CSO THOUGHT YOU UPLOAD
YOUR HAVE IT MADE THIS AT THAT
THE NOISE.
WELL I MEAN NUMBER AS JANET
SUMMIT ON THE U. OUT FOR YOU OF
A BANK THIS AT THEM THEN I.
I AM RETURNED THE KISS. I
SUPPORT AB TWENTY. SEVEN I.
JOSH WILL GOKU WITH THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES AND SUPPORT.
BUT IN A COMPASS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN SUPPORT OF AB.
THE NUMBERS MIGHT AND AT THE
OPENING OF THE LOS ANGELES
SUPPORT THE LOVING DISCIPLINE
THEM PRESS.
TINA RODRIGUEZ MADERA COUNTY AND
I SUPPORT AB TWO SEVEN ZERO
NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MARKETS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND WE ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS OF
THE BILL AT THE FIRST THE COUPLE
THINGS THAT I WANT TO COVER ARE
THE. CONCERNS WITH THE AFFILIATE
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN THE DEPTH
OF NATURE OF THE HARASSMENT
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS UNDER
CURRENT LAW EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED I'M A JANITORIAL
SERVICE INDUSTRY EMPLOYERS ARE
REQUIRED TO REGISTER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS. AT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO ADDITIONALLY
PROVIDE THE NAME OF ANY
SUBCONTRACTOR OR FRANCHISE
SERVICING CONTRACT AFFILIATED
WITH THE BRANCH LOCATION THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES OF
THAT AFFILIATE OUT OF EACH
LISTED BRANCH OFFICE AN ADDRESS
OF EACH WORK LOCATION THAT
BRANCH OFFICE HOWEVER AFFILIATE
ISN'T DEFINED WHAT. EXACTLY DOES
AFFILIATE MEAN POLICY AND
EMPLOYER IS SUPPOSED TO KNOW HOW
MANY EMPLOYEES IN PHILLY HOUSE
WHAT HAPPENS IF THERE'S TURNOVER
AT THE AFFILIATE HOW OFTEN THEY
HAVE TO UPDATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS. IS THOSE
KIND OF CONCERNS THAT WOULD
EXPOSE EMPLOYERS TO ADDITIONAL.
CAN YOU JUST FLOWED OUT DOWNLOAD
OUR EVENNESS SORRY.
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AT THE
SECOND PART IS THE DUPLICATIVE
NATURE OF THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING AT THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT DOES PROVIDE
TRAINING WE UNDERSTAND THAT AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRE THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO CAN DO
PROPOSED TRAINING HOWEVER UNDER
FEE HA A TRAINER IS ALLOWED TO
BE AN ATTORNEY A PROFESSOR OR
INSTRUCTOR OF HUMAN RESOURCES
PROFESSIONAL OR HUMAN PREVENTION
CONSULT HER BASSINET PREVENTION
CONSULTANT. UNDER THIS BILL.
A PEER TRAINER WOULD NEED TO BE
HIRED IN ADDITION TO THOSE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING TRAINERS AND
THE BILL STATES THAT THE PEER
TRAINERS M. MUST BE PAID A. WAGE
OF TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR
THAT WOULD BE A STATUTORILY
REQUIRED WAGE OF TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND ADDITIONALLY
THEY WILL BE PROVIDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINING THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING ACT TRAINING THAT'S DONE
BY. ANOTHER TRAINER AND SO THE.
DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF THIS
REQUIREMENT IS A CONCERN
ESPECIALLY WITH IT THAT IT'S
STATUTORILY REQUIRED THANK YOU
SO MUCH SORRY ABOUT THE SPEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION.
TRICKER CAN I JUST HAD A
CHRISTMAS HAILING CAN I HAVE
JUST ONE ADDITIONAL POINT WE'VE
HAD MANY DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
REGARDING DFT H. VERSES THE
LABOR CODE.
HEAD LIKE A LAST WEEK IN THE
LABOR COMMITTEE AND.
OR IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
PERHAPS IT WAS I CAN'T EVEN
REMEMBER WHICH ONE IT WAS.
ANYMORE.
BUT A NARROWER VERSION OF THIS
WAS A I'M SORRY.
A NARROW BILL AB FIVE SIXTY NINE
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ FLETCHER WAS VETOED
LAST YEAR BY THE GOVERNOR. AND
WHAT THE GOVERNOR SAID IS I
BELIEVE THESE TYPES OF CLAIMS
SHOULD REMAIN WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
AND SO WE SHOULD. WE THINK THAT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING AT
ALL SHOULD REMAIN WITH INDIA FEE
H. RATHER THAN MOVE OVER TO THE
LABOR CODE THANK YOU.
AND SHAUN THOSE THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ALSO POST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
CENA AND BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ITS COLOR. THINK MISS SHARE.
I FIRST OF ALL I WAS WAS COUPLE
YEARS AGO I KNOW WHEN. ASSEMBLY
GOOD GONZALEZ FLETCHER AND
OTHERS WE LED THE CHARGE HERE.
AND I WAS UP IN SOUNDS IN THE
CITY COUNCIL AND THE REALITY IS
THAT.
THE MOVEMENT BEFORE THE NEED TO
HAVE MEANT WHAT WE'RE REALLY
THESE JANITORS THESE WOMEN VERY
BRAVE WOMAN THAT STOOD UP AND
SPOKE OUT. AYE EVEN WHEN PEOPLE
WEREN'T LISTENING.
I'M GLAD THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
TO SEE NOW BUT. BUT I JUST WANT
TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR THAT.
IT WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
COURAGEOUS AT THE TIME.
UP WHEN THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE
TALKING ABOUT THE STUFF.
TO PUT.
AT YOUR JOB ON THE LINE AND
MANY DID.
EDITOR BICU BONTA HERBAL AND
COURAGEOUS AND TALKING ABOUT
PERSONAL EXPERIENCES.
I AND I YOU KNOW NOT ONLY. I HAD
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE AND
OPPORTUNITY TO HOST OF THESE ON
ONE OCCASION SCREENINGS OF RAPE
ON THE NIGHT SHIFT AND. THOSE
VERY POWERFUL VERY MOVING AND
CLEARLY LEAD TO REAL ACTION BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND NOW GONNA
POST THE INITIATION OF THE NEED
TO MOVEMENT. I THINK IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN EVER THAT WE
CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO THE
VOICES.
THOSE WHO ARE VICTIMS OF ASSAULT
I KNOW ITS.
UNLIKELY A COINCIDENCE THAT
THIS BILL IS HERE BEFORE US
TODAY ON DENIM DAY.
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN
THE SYMBOLIC ASPECT OF THAT IS
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO THAT
SUBSTANTIVE. AYE AYES SINCERELY
DO NOT BELIEVE. THAT.
IT'S.
OVERLY BURDENSOME TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL PEER COUNSELOR TO THE
TRAINING THAT'S NOT DUPLICATIVE
AT ALL I THINK THAT IF THERE'S A
SENSE.
FROM ANYONE ELSE THAT IS
DUPLICATIVE I DON'T THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT APPEARED COUNCIL
REFORMATORY AT.
PREMATURE DOES.
AND A SENSE OF CONNECTEDNESS
THAT IS OBSOLETE NESTLE SPECIAL
MORE TALKING ABOUT SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
.
AND TO SUGGEST THAT SOMEHOW ON
EMPLOYER DOESN'T KNOW HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES IT HAS. OR THAT WHEN
THEY'RE THEY'RE PUTTING TOGETHER
CONTRAST HUNDRED OF THOUSANDS OR
EVEN MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN CONTRACTING OUT SERVICES FOR
JANITORIAL SERVICES THAT THEY
CAN ADD ONE SIMPLE LINE A BY THE
WAY CAN YOU PROVIDE US
INFORMATION HOW MAY EMPLOYEES
HAVE AND WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED.
YOU KNOW IT'S INTERESTING THAT
THE SUGGEST THAT SOME OF THESE
ARE HAPLESS EMPLOYERS THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
BUT THEIR WORK FORCES JUST THE
IT TOTALLY FALLS FLAT. I THINK
THIS IS A KIND OF. THIS IS THE
KIND OF ISSUE WHERE IT WOULD
REALLY.
.
AYE I THINK BEHOOVE EMPLOYERS
TO GET ON BOARD AND SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN EASILY DO
TO SUPPORT.
THE WORKERS THAT ARE SUFFERING
THAT ARE SUFFERING TODAY HAVE
BEEN SUFFERING FOR MANY MANY
YEARS AND IT'S FRANKLY
DISAPPOINTING. THAT.
ON AN ISSUE LIKE THIS.
THOUGH THE FACT THEY HAVE TO
PAY TWENTY FIVE BUCKS AN HOUR
HOPE FOR ACCOUNTS ARE TO COME IN
WITH THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE DATA.
IS IS CONSIDERED AN OBSTACLE
RATHER THAN.
DAMN BEING PROACTIVE IN
PROTECTING THE VICTIMS THAT
WORK.
IN THERE COMPANIES THAT WORK ON
SITE.
THAT CLEAN THEIR FACILITIES ARE
I WOULD HOPE THAT YOU KNOW I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
DISCRIMINATORY ISSUES HERE
SOMETIME JUST LABOR BUSINESS
WITHOUT YOU. THIS IS THE DECENCY
ISSUED THIS IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
ISSUE. THIS IS AN ISSUE WHERE WE
NEED TO STAND UP FOR ALL VICTIMS
PRICKLY THOSE COURAGEOUS WOMEN.
THAT HAVE STEPPED UP.
ATTACK TO TELL THEIR STORIES
WHICH IS WHICH ARE SO POWERFUL.
AND SO.
IT'S MY HONOR DOES THAT MAKE.
OF A MOTION.
MOTIVATED TO MOVE THE BILL AND
ASSET I CAN BE JOIN IN ANY
CAPACITY POSSIBLE WAS A CO
AUTHOR. I IN SUPPORT AND OF
COURSE I WAS OUT THERE TODAY A
THE. I THINK IT IS IN OUR TIME
IS UP IT'S IT TIMES UP ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH AND WE OUGHT TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN IN OUR GOAL TO
PROTECT.
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE DOING
SERVICE ON OUR BEHALF.
QUESTION OR COMMENT ON THE BILL.
REMEMBER MELENDEZ THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
SO  I DID WATCH
RIGHT ON THE NIGHT SHIFT THE
SENATE TO ME I WAS A YEAR AGO I
THINK MAYBE MORE HERE'S ABOUT
TWO YEARS AGO YEAH.
AND I WAS SHOCKED BY WHAT I SAW
I'M SO I SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO MY PROBLEM IS YOUR
STATUTORILY MANDATING A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF PAY FOR A JOB AND I.
REALLY WISH THAT WASN'T IN THIS
BILL.
BECAUSE I I JUST THINK WHETHER
IT'S A VOLUNTEER OR WHETHER THEY
GET PAID TWENTY FIVE OR HUNDRED
DOLLARS AN HOUR WON'T. WON'T
CHANGE THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING THE TRAINING AND I'M
KIND OF THE GUIDANCE ALONG THE
WAY.
SO I.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THAT REASON I
CAN'T SUPPORT I WISH I COULD
BUY.
BUT I'M PROUD OF YOU FOR
BRINGING IN FORT INDIAN ORCHARD
DOWN.
THEY WHAT ELSE WISHING TO
COMMENT OR ASK A QUESTION.
I'VE SEEN NINE I WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I DO IN ON THAT I KNOW
IT'S IT'S DIFFERENT AND A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE BUT I DO AND THE
REASONING FOR THAT IS. THESE
AREN'T.
WOMEN UNFORTUNATELY WHO CAN
VOLUNTEER THESE ARE WOMEN WHO
ARE ACTUAL JANITORS WHO HAVE
BEEN.
MOST THE TIME THEMSELVES
ALREADY HAVE HAVE EXPERIENCE A
SITUATION.
WHO HAVE FACED SEXUAL ASSAULT
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE I'M
TO THE OPPOSITION YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THEY KEEP BRINGING UP A
DIFFERENT BILL ABOUT WHY NOT PUT
THINGS IN THE LABOR CODE AND I'D
SAY THERE'S A LOT OF CHANGES
FROM LAST YEAR? AS NUMBER ONE
THIS IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
BILL THAT WAS ALREADY PLACED A
IT COMPANIONS OF ALL THOSE PLACE
IN LABOR CODE. BUT SECONDLY.
IT'S CLEAR THAT WHAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IN EVERY OTHER
STATE THIS NATION HAS BEEN DOING
IN REGARDS TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND SALT DID NOT WORK. IN WHEN
IT COMES TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT
THE HAVE ALTHOUGH THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WORK THAT HASN'T
BEEN ENOUGH SO WHAT WE'RE
PRESENTING BILLS THAT DON'T DO
IN FACT AT THINGS INTO THE LABOR
CODE WHICH GIVES A PATH TO THE
WORKER TO GO TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. WHICH MAY BE MORE
COMFORTABLE SPOT THAN ACTUALLY
FILING A LAWSUIT THROUGH FEE
HAD.
I I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT THAT
SEEMS UM. LIKE HEY WE ARE THE
DISC WE WE ARE READY ALL AGREED
WHERE WHERE THIS BELONGS WILL WE
HAVE WE HAVE AN AGREED.
UP IF WE HAVEN'T LEARNED THAT
THE LAST FEW YEARS ESPECIALLY IN
THE LAST YEAR I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE'VE LEARNED WE HAVE GOT TO
START LOOKING AT THIS PROBLEM
THROUGH A DIFFERENT LENS AND
THAT'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT THESE
BILL THAT'S WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
THESE WOMEN. BECAUSE AFTER THEY
EMPOWER THEMSELVES AND CAME AND
TOLD WHAT I STILL TO FIND THE
MOST DEVASTATING STORY I'VE EVER
HEARD IN THIS BUILDING ABOUT NOT
BEING HARASSED NOT BEING.
SUBJECTED TO SOME LEWD COMMENTS
OR SOMETHING BUT ACTUALLY BEING
RATE
AT NIGHT BY THEIR SUPERVISOR IN
BEING THREATENED WITH
DEPORTATION BEING THREATENED
WITH LOSING.
THEIR THEIR LIVELIHOOD BEING
THREATEN THE TELLING THEIR
HUSBANDS EITHER THAT THE STORIES
AND AND THE WAY THAT THESE WOMEN
EMPOWER THEMSELVES THROUGHOUT
THAT WHOLE PROCESS IT MAKES ME
THANKFUL OF COURSE TO FOR. NANCY
MCFADDEN WAS THERE LISTENING TO
THEIR STORIES AND WHO TOLD HIM
THE BILL HAD BEEN SIGNED THAT
THEY WENT OUT AND. GOT A GROUP
TOGETHER TO COME UP WITH THE
IDEA OF OF OF HOW SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CHANGE SHOULD BE
DONE.
NOT JUST ACCEPTING WHAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN DOING WHICH ISN'T
WORKING IT'S CLEARLY NOT WORKING
AND SO FOR THEM TO GO OUT AND
SEE OTHER MODELS AND TO SEE WHAT
WORKS IT THAT'S CULTURALLY
COMPETENT THAT MAKES SENSE IT
MAKES SENSE FOR THE WORKERS AND
NOT JUST ATTORNEY WHO IS
PRESENTING. THE FACTS OF LIFE AS
IT IS IN STATUTE SO INSPIRING SO
I THINK THESE WOMEN FOR FOR
ALLOWING ME ONCE AGAIN TO CARRY
THIS BILL FOR BEING PART OF THE
OUT PASSED A. MOVEMENT AND AND.
.
FOR FOR ALL OF YOU FOR GIVING IT
ITS DUE CONSIDERATION AND AND
* TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
I'M WATCHING THE FILM I AND I
KNOW I REMEMBER WHEN HE WHEN I
WATCHED IT NICE THAT I GOT THAT
LIST YOU GOTTA SEE THIS IS.
WHERE FINE IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT OR ITS
COMPANION?
FOLLOW UP AYE AYE I URGE PEOPLE
TO DO THAT BUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE
WORK HERE.
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TOGETHER
TO WATCH.
RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT AND
HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
I WITH ADVOCATES FROM UP AND
DOWN THE STATE AND ONE OF THE
FILMMAKERS IS.
LIVES IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THIS IS VERY IMPORTANT AND
POWERFUL DIFFICULT FILM TO WATCH
BUT IMPORTANT FILM THE WATCH.
TO EXPOSE THE TRUTH AND TODAY
IS ANOTHER STEP FORWARD IN
EXPOSING THE TRUTH IN MAKING
CHANGE THIS BILL HAS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION.
AND I ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO SUPPORT IT A PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMAN AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THOSE FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES KNOW THAT LISTENS.
THAT BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS.
SORRY I GOT HERE LATE.
I HAD A STORY TO.
FIRED A JANITOR.
WAS RAPING WOMEN. LA.
AFTER THE AMERICAN RATE COULD
LET YOU KNOW HOW.
SOME STORIES OKAY WE ARE GOING
TO.
HERE DISCUSSION ON A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
.
A WOULD DOING AND IMMEDIATELY
FOLLOWING THAT WE WILL HEAR FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL BE
HEARD FOR DISCUSSION PURPOSES
ONLY THE COMMITTEE WILL NOT BE
VOTING. ON THIS MATTER.
.
THE AUTHORS.
I WILL BE EXPLORING WAYS TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AND.
THIS CHAIR IN THIS COMMITTEE.
WILL BE SUPPORTING THEM AND WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO TO SUPPORT.
I IMMIGRANT WORKERS AND THE
INDUSTRIES THAT EMPLOYED THEM.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF TODAY
EVERYONE WILL BE HURT WILL HAVE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE ISSUE.
WE'LL HEAR FROM THOSE WHO
SUPPORT THE BILL WILL HEAR FROM
THOSE WHO OPPOSE THE BILL BUT
MORE IMPORTANT BUT WE'RE ASKING
EVERYONE TO DO IS SALANDER
CREATIVITY. ON IDEAS TO SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT WORKERS.
AND THE INDUSTRY'S THE GROWERS
THAT THAT EMPLOY THEM.
WITH THAT.
PLEASEGIVE YOUR ATTENTION A TO
SOME MEMBERS AYE GARCIA INCOMING
DATA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING YOU FOR
FACILITATING NAM. AND COMMITTING
TO CONTINUE A DISCUSSION ON A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE. KNOWING
NATIONALLY BUT I THINK.
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
IT RELATES TO NOT JUST THE
ECONOMY.
SECURITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
BUT FOOD SECURITIES AND YOU
KNOW HALL RANGE OF ISSUES THAT.
ARE CONNECTED TO THIS THIS
PROBLEM.
A DATA OVER THE LAST THREE TO
FOUR YEARS. IS THAT THERE ARE
LESS IMMIGRANTS ENTERING THE U.
S. AND SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA
ANNUALLY AND DURING THE KEY
TIMES IN AGRICULTURE AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES.
THIS REDUCTION AND IMMIGRANTS
ENTERING THE U. S. IN CALIFORNIA
HAS RESULTED IN A SMALLER
WORKFORCE AVAILABLE TO WORK IN
THE STATE AGRICULTURE AND
SERVICE INDUSTRIES.
MORE SPECIFICALLY THIS REDUCTION
IN THE READY AND WILLING
WORKFORCE IN THE AGRICULTURE AND
SERVICE INDUSTRIES HAS RESULTED
IN LABOR SHORTAGES FOR THESE TWO
KEY INDUSTRIES IN OUR STATE'S
ECONOMY.
OR THE SAME TIME PERIOD WE HAVE
SEEN INCREASES IN THE WAGES PAID
TO FARMWORKERS FOR CERTAIN CROPS
AND REGIONS IN THE STATE. WE'VE
ALSO SEEN AG EMPLOYERS IMPROVING
WORKING CONDITIONS AND AN
EMERGENCE OF HEALTH AND OTHER
BENEFITS THAT COME ALONG WITH
IT.
DESPITE THESE EFFORTS WE HAVE
NOT SEEN ONE STUDY NATIONWIDE
NOR DATA FROM ANY STATE THAT A
SUBSTANTIAL AG AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES AND HAS FOUND THAT U.
S. BORN WORKERS. ARE MOVING TO
STATES WITH WORKER SHORTAGES IN
THESE TWO INDUSTRIES.
THE U. S. BORN WORKERS SIMPLY IS
NOT ATTRACTED TO WORKING IN THE
AG OR SERVICE INDUSTRIES DESPITE
THE INCREASE IN WAGES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN.
REPORTED IN NEWSPAPERS
THROUGHOUT THE NATION.
I HAVE HEARD FROM GROWERS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY THROUGHOUT THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND SALINAS
VALLEY THAT THE LACK OF LABOR
HAS CAUSED THEM TO LEAVE CROPS
ON THE VINES. ON TREES AND IN
THE FIELD ENSUING IN SUBSTANTIAL
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS A
BIPARTISAN BILL DESIGNED TO
ADDRESS TO LABOR SHORTAGES IN
THE AGRICULTURE AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES.
IT WOULD CREATE A WORKING GROUP
THAT WOULD COME UP WITH THE BEST
WAYS TO IMPLEMENT AND OPERATE. A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT WORKER
PROGRAM AND WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROVAL WOULD SUBMIT THE REPORT
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE SOME TIME TO
ADDRESS THE MISCONCEPTIONS OF
THE BILL.
FIRST OFF
THE BILL WILL NOT CREATE A GUEST
WORKER PROGRAM IT WOULD CREATE A
RESIDENT WORKER PROGRAM FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN LIVING. AND
WORKING HERE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
YEARS.
FURTHERMORE.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE US
CONSTITUTION MAKE STATES
DEPENDENT ON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
BECAUSE OF THAT WE'VE REACHED
OUT TO THE MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA
DELEGATION WHO AGREED THAT THE
ISSUE NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION. THE REAL BIG
CONVERSATION HAPPENING IN
CONGRESS.
IS HAVING TO DEAL WITH BAKA AND
THE WALL.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
GET THE ISSUE OF THE LABOR
SHORTAGES ON THEIR RADAR BECAUSE
OF THE SEVERE ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES THEY HAVE HAD AND
THAT SEEMS TO BE WORSENING.
THAT BEING SAID IT'S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND THE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE KEY AND TRIMMING ROLE IN HOW
THIS PROGRAM WILL BE OPERATED.
WHILE THE PROVISIONS WOULD NEED
TO BE NEGOTIATED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
OUR BILL WILL BE GOING TO DHS
ONLY AFTER WE HAVE CRAFTED IT.
IN THE WAY THAT WE BELIEVE WOULD
BE THE MOST BENEFICIAL FOR
STATE.
IF WE DO NOT LIKE WHAT DHS COMES
BACK WITH.
THE GOVERNOR HAS THE COMPLETE
AUTHORITY TO REJECT THE VERSION
DHS PROPOSES.
LASTLY
THIS BILL DOES NOT UNDERMINE ANY
EFFORTS CONGRESS HAS MADE
REGARDING IMMIGRATION POLICY FOR
FARMWORKERS.
THERE IS A PROVISION IN OUR BILL
THAT SAYS ANY FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
PROGRAM WOULD PREEMPT A STATE.
PROGRAM.
WELL I DON'T AGREE WITH THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION'S STANCE
ON IMMIGRATION POLICY WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES.
ARE TOO VITAL TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY TO DO NOTHING.
THE EDTA ESTIMATE THAT THERE ARE
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND FARM
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE NATIONAL AGRICULTURE SURVEY
ESTIMATES THAT OVER SIXTY
PERCENT OF FARMWORKERS ARE ON
AUTHORIZED.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
UNAUTHORIZED WORKERS ARE
DEPORTED.
BY SETTING THE GROUNDWORK FOR A
STATE RUN RESIDENT WORKER
PROGRAM.
THAT IS WHY THAT THE AKAKA'S IT
DOESN'T THIS BILL IS THE
LEGISLATURE PRIORITY.
THOUSANDS OF MEN AND WOMEN HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE ECONOMIC
STRENGTH OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
OUR STATE ECONOMIC STANDING
WITHOUT HAVING HAD THE ACTIVE
INVITED CONTRIBUTIONS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
DESPITE THE WELL INTENTIONED AND
SUSTAINED EFFORTS BY MANY AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL AND FROM
CALIFORNIA.
ARE IMMIGRANT WORKFORCE HAS GONE
THROUGH SOME VERY DIFFICULT
TIMES.
WE HAD MORE DEPORTATIONS IN THE
PREVIOUS NINE YEARS THAT WE HAVE
HAD AT ANY OTHER TIME SINCE
THEY'D HAVE BEEN KEPT ON THIS
PROCESS.
DESPITE THE INTENTIONS OF THE
CLEARING CITIES COUNTIES AND
STATE SANCTUARIES FOR IMMIGRANTS
MANY FAMILIES CONTINUE TO BE
SEPARATED.
THROUGH APPREHENSIONS AND
DEPORTATIONS BY FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES.
AND DESPITE THE EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE PERMANENT STATUS AND OR
CITIZENSHIP. THROUGH LEGISLATION
TO BLOCK THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE WE
ARE. VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE BEEN
THE COURTS DECIDE THAT THIS
PROGRAM WILL NOT GO BY THE
WAYSIDE.
HOWEVER THERE THERE'S NOTHING
THAT IS ON THE TABLE IN CONGRESS
OR BEFORE THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM
THAT WOULD EXTEND PROTECTIONS
AND JUST TREATMENT.
FOR UNAUTHORIZED IMMIGRANTS WHO
HAVE CONTRIBUTED MIGHTILY TO THE
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS HE
SERIOUS FARE AND PRACTICAL PATH.
PORT THAT IS DESIGNED NOT TO
EXCLUDE THE POPULATION OF
PARENTS AND WORKING ADULTS
RELATED AND NOT RELATED TO
DOCTOR RECIPIENTS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK HARD. IN
AGRICULTURE AND SERVICE
INDUSTRIES FOR STATE.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER GARCIA
SIMILAR COMING OUT OF.
THINK THEY'RE VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
FIRST LET ME THANK THE CHAIR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY JUST BE HERE
TODAY REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE
IN MY DISTRICT ARE INCLUDES BOTH
THE SALINAS IN THE PARK HER
VALLEY.
AS WELL AS SOMEBODY TO COUNTY
AND IT'S THE THIRD LARGEST
NUMBER OF FARM WORKERS IN THE
STATE AN ESTIMATED EIGHTY TWO
THOUSAND. WHICH IS AN UNDERCOUNT
THE CROPS RIGOR WE GROW OUR SOME
OF THE MOST PRODUCTIVE AND LABOR
INTENSIVE AND WE ARE ALSO ALWAYS
IN NEED OF LABOR IN THERE. THAT
THIS SITUATION REALLY HAS BEEN
EXACERBATED BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE IMMIGRATION POLICIES BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
MONTEREY COUNTY AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS CROP REPORT FOUND
THAT AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS
GENERATED FOUR POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
IMPACT IT'S FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT.
THE TOP TEN MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
CROPS IN MY REGION ARE LABOR
INTENSIVE THEY WERE REQUIRE
WORKERS THAT ARE EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE AND HIGHLY SKILLED.
THE LABOR SHORTAGE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS HAS GOTTEN STEADILY WORSE
AND HIS NAME IS NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED OUR ECONOMY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY THIRTY
PLUS YEARS IN A ROW CALIFORNIA
FARMERS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
LEAVE PRODUCE IN THE FIELD. THIS
MEANS THAT THEY'VE GONE TO THE
TROUBLE OF PLANTING.
AT AT BENNING.
GROWING PUTTING EVERYTHING ALL
OF THE.
.
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES INTO IT
AND THEN LEAVE IT IN THE FALL
BECAUSE OF A LABOR SHORTAGE.
THIS PUTS FARMERS AT RISK
ECONOMICALLY WASTING FOOD AND
RURAL. ECONOMIES AT RISK AS WELL
IN AND QUITE FRANKLY ON IT IT
IS.
.
DIFFICULT BECAUSE WITHOUT
WORKERS IN THAT IN THE ECONOMY
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY STARTS TO
SUFFER AS WELL.
ADDITIONALLY IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
ARE TERRIFIED THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT IMMIGRATION RATES AND
DEPORTATIONS.
I RECENTLY WENT TO A TOWN HALL
MEETING ON IMMIGRATION AND WAS
APPROACHED BY LITTLE GIRL. WHO
TELL ME IN TEARS AS SHE WAS
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS OLD THAT SHE
WAS TERRIFIED TO GO TO SCHOOL?
AND.
SHE WAS AFRAID THAT IF YOU WENT
TO SCHOOL.
SHE WOULD COME HOME AND FIND HER
PARENTS. GONE I'VE BEEN TOLD BY
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS THAT.
WHEN THERE IS A LOCAL RATE IN
THE COMMUNITY AND SOMEONE IS
DEPORTED THAT THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THAT SHOW FOR SCHOOL
DROP SIGNIFICANTLY. AND THAT
PARENTS DON'T SHOW UP FOR WORK
BECAUSE FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
THERE'S FEAR. THAT THE ICE
AGENTS ARE IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND PEOPLE WON'T GO OUT AND DO
THEIR DAY TO DAY ACTIVITIES THIS
IS HAVING A TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON
OUR SCHOOLS AND IT'S HAVING A
TREMENDOUS IMPACT ON OUR WORK
WORKFORCE AS WELL. IT'S CREATED
IN OUT UNHEALTHY ATMOSPHERE OF
ENGLISH FEAR AND SUSPICION THAT
HURTS FAMILIES EMOTIONALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY AND FRANKLY THERE'S
THIS SENSE IN THE COMMUNITY BUT
NO ONE'S DOING ANYTHING ABOUT IT
AND THAT'S REALLY THE REASON.
WHY?
WHEN I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH MY. MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM THE COACHELLA VALLEY ABOUT
IMMIGRATION AND THE IMPORTANCE
OF A STANDING UP FOR OUR
FAMILIES THIS BE THIS BILL
BECAME. NOT SO IMPORTANT TO ME
BECAUSE I NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
BACK AND TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOT JUST FOR
THE DOCTOR STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR
THE WORKERS AND HAVE BEEN
WORKING. ON A LOCALLY AND IN MY
REGION OUT MOST OF THE WORK
FORCE HAS BEEN WORKING. FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS IN THERE IN
THE IN THE PROFESSION AND THE
AVERAGE AGE IS OVER THE AGE OF
FIFTY FIVE AND SO. ON MANY OF
THEM ARE ON HAVE FAMILIES AND
HAVE MANY DEPENDENTS THAT
REQUIRE THAT REALLY. LOOK TO
THEM OFFER. ON EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
AND FOR.
ECONOMIC SUPPORT AND MANY OF
THEM ARE FREE TO GO TO WORK.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE IS A
VERY PRACTICAL REASONABLE AND
JUST APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
SERIOUS LABORS.
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE IN MORE MORE
IMPORTANTLY. TO DEAL WITH THE.
REALLY THAT THEY THEY
HUMANITARIAN AND THE.
THE SOCIAL ISSUE WHICH IS DO WE
STAND BEHIND OUR IMMIGRANTS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT TO CONTRIBUTING
TO OUR LOCAL ECONOMY.
THE FARM WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE NOT AUTHORIZED TO WORK
HAVE BEEN DOING SO AS I SAID ON
AVERAGE FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS IT IS TIME FOR CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE ACTION. THAT THING FOR
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
DID YOU JUST BE HERE TODAY AND
PERCENT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SOME IN THE RECOVERY
YOU HAVE SOME WITNESSES.
THE FIRST WITNESS A.
MY NAME'S ON ARNOLD AUTHORITIES
AND I. AM A CONSULTANT TO CLINIC
HAS INVITED SALINAS WHO.
IS A COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER IN
MONTEREY COUNTY WHO IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PLIGHT. OF
THE PATIENTS THAT THEY SEE AND
THE CONSEQUENCES
OF WHAT THE DEPORTATIONS ON THE
SEPARATIONS ARE HAVING IN FACT
IN JANUARY A MAJOR STUDY BY UCSF
IN BERKELEY.
WAS PUBLISHED.
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY WOMEN FARMWORKERS OF
THAT WAR AT.
CLINIC HAS INVTED SALINAS THAT
CONFIRMED THAT THEIR FEAR
DEPORTATION.
WAS CAUSING A SIGNIFICANT.
AT RISK OF FOUR HEART ATTACKS
AND SO THIS WAS CHRONICLED IN
THIS RESEARCH IS ACTUALLY
PUBLISHED IN IN ONE OF THE.
MEDICAL JOURNALS.
SO.
I WANTED TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
THAT I UNDERSTOOD.
SERVER SEVERAL MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE.
VISAS FOR THESE WORKERS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
WHO AVERAGE OVER TWELVE YEARS OF
HAVING LIVED IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAVING WORKED IN THE FIELDS.
THERE ARE NO VISAS FOR THIS
POPULATION.
IT IS NOT JUST A FEDERAL
PROBLEM.
AND THAT WAS A CONCERN THAT I
BELIEVE MISS MELENDEZ.
RAISED AT SOME TIME.
THIS IS A PROBLEM OF THE
ECONOMY.
THERE ARE MAJOR ANALYSIS THAT
HAVE BEEN DONE OF THE LABOR
SHORTAGES IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
AND TO DO AWAY WITH WORKERS WHO
HAVE BEEN WORKING AND
CONTRIBUTING SIGNIFICANTLY. TO
THE NECK ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF
THIS STATE. AYE IS AN ABSOLUTE
SHAME.
THIS BILL DOES NOT.
SUPERSEDE FEDERAL LAW. WE DID
THIS BILL AND TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN I WENT BACK TO
WASHINGTON I MET ALONG WITH
MISTER MIND RIGHT BETTIS WAS THE
MEMBER FROM COACHELLA AT THE
TIME. WE MET WITH THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR PLANNING AND
EVALUATION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY THEY LIKE THIS
BILL THEY THOUGHT THIS BILL MADE
SENSE. AND OF THE BILL HAD
PASSED IN THAT EYELASH.
SESSION OF THE LEGISLATURE THEY
WOULD HAVE CONSIDERED.
THE PACKAGE THAT WE WOULD HAVE
DELIVER TO.
THIS BILL IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
THIS BILL CALLS FOR DOING
SOMETHING THAT IS NOT BEING DONE
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL OR
CONSIDERED. I HAVE A STUDY HERE
FOR THE MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
FROM THE.
SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE.
WHEN JUST TRYING TO RESPOND TO
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED.
AND IN THIS STUDY THEY SIMPLY
INDICATE THAT THE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE LABOR SHORTAGES THAT.
OUR EXISTING AND IS THE NUMBER
ONE ISSUE FOR ALL OF AGRICULTURE
IN THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
ACCORDING TO MR SONNY PERDUE.
THE ONLY ISSUE THEY DESCRIBE
THAT WILL SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IS
THE AGE TO A PROGRAM.
ON BEHALF OF GROWERS THAT I
CAN'T SPEAK ON BEHALF OF BUT
KNOWING THEM AND HEARING THEM
AND HAVING MET WITH HIM ON THIS
ISSUE. NONE OF THEM REALLY LIKE
THE AGE TO A PROGRAM.
IN FACT VERY FEW PEOPLE LIKE THE
H. TWO A PROGRAM FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS AND ALL OF THE MAJOR AG
GROUPS HAVE INDICATED VERY
CLEARLY THAT THEY OPPOSE THE
GOODS THAT BILL WHICH WAS IS D.
H. TO SEE PROGRAM. WHICH IS
SIMPLY AN EXPEDITED VERSION OF
H. TO A WHICH IS NOT RESPONSIVE
TO THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE.
SO LET'S LOOK AT THE OTHER
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED
THAT WE WOULD BE NEGOTIATING
WITH THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THE GROUPS INCLUDING THE UFW AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATING.
IN CONGRESS
HAVE BEEN NEGOTIATING NOT WOULD
SIMPLY THE MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE.
THEY'VE BEEN NEGOTIATING WITH
THE MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
THE MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE ARE
CARRIED FORWARD THIS
PRESIDENT'S.
IMMIGRATION AGENDA.
SO IN ESSENCE THEY ARE
NEGOTIATING WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THIS BILL S.
MISTER.
GARCIA HAS VERY WELL POINTED OUT
IS WE WILL DEVELOP THE PLAN THAT
WE BELIEVE MAKES THE MOST SENSE
FOR THE GROWERS DE INDUSTRY. AND
THE WORKERS.
IF THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY COMES BACK WITH THE
VERSION.
THAT WE BELIEVE IS NOT IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THOSE THREE
PRIMARY CONCERNS.
THEN THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
HAS. COMPLETE AUTHORITY UNDER
THIS LAW TO SAY NO.
THAT IS NOT THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
YOU HAVE WHEN YOU LOOK AT
FEDERAL LAW.
THAT IS NOT THE OPPORTUNITY YOU
HAVE TO TO MAKE A DEAL ANDHAKA
AND THE WALL.
THE DEAL IS THAT BOUGHT THAT
BILL PASSES AND WHATEVER THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT LAW OR
THERE IS THE LAW.
THIS BILL GIVES US A CHANCE TO
DO SOMETHING VERY UNIQUE.
IT'S ABLE TO PUT A THE ISSUE OF
LABOR SHORTAGES IN THE CONTEXT
IT SHOULD BE VIEWED WHICH IS.
AND ECONOMIC PROBLEM.
AND ECONOMIC PROBLEM THAT YOU S.
WORKERS WILL NOT RESOLVE IN THE
YEARS TO COME. SO WE HOPE THAT
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD REALLY LOOK
AT THE MERITS OF WHAT OF WHAT
WE'VE ATTEMPTED TO DO.
WE THINK THE BILL IS A SOLID
BILL IT'S VERY PRACTICAL IT HAS
SUPPORT FROM REPUBLICANS AND
FROM DEMOCRATS AND IT HAS
SUPPORT FROM GROWERS AND THE
WORKER COMMUNITY.
WE HOPE THAT YOU WILL REALLY
GIVE THOROUGH CONSIDERATION TO
APPROVING THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I THINK YOU DO YOU HAVE OTHER
WITNESSES ONE POSSIBLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
PLEASE PROCEED MY TURN TO TALK
IT IS YOUR TURN TO TALK. CRAFTS
GREAT TO BE HERE.
AND MY PLEA FOR THE MIKE.
ALRIGHT.
MY NAME IS JOE DEL BOTH GAY AND
I'M A FARMER I.
FARMING FIREBALL CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS ON THE WEST SIDE OF
FRESNO COUNTY AND I FARM LITTLE
BEEN AND MERCED COUNTY ALSO.
WE GO MOSTLY.
ORGANIC MELANSON ORGANIC
ASPARAGUS BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
ALMONDS AND A AND A FEW
CHERRIES.
OUR FAMILY HAS BEEN IN. MELONS
FOR A LONG LONG TIME.
GOING BACK PROBABLY MORE THAN
EIGHTY YEARS WHEN MY ANCESTORS
WERE MELON PICKERS.
AND I ALSO GREW UP ON THE FARM.
IN BALANCEAND I GOT TO DO ALL
THAT STUFF TOO I PICK MELONS I.
DROVE TRACTOR IN. AND EARN A
LITTLE MONEY TO PUT MYSELF
THROUGH COLLEGE.
SO IT IT'S BEEN IT'S BEEN A LONG
CAREER AND.
AND FARMING.
.
BUT IT'S A FAMILY FARM THAT
INCLUDES MY WIFE MY WIFE WAS
ALSO.
MIGRANT FARM WORKER SHE WAS AN
IMMIGRANT FROM MEXICO. AND SHE
WORKS ON THE FARM SHE'S ACTUALLY
THE THE PEOPLE PERSON ON THE
FARM AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL TO
HAVE HER BECAUSE SHE UNDERSTANDS
THE FOLKS. AND I LISTEN.
TO THEM ALSO.
SO WE ALSO HAVE DAUGHTERS WORK
ON THE FARM THREE DAUGHTERS AND
A SON IN LAW. SO IT'S VERY MUCH
OF A FAMILY FARM BUT.
BUT WE WE OPERATE.
GOOD BUSINESS ALSO BECAUSE
WE'RE REACHING OUT A LOT OF
CUSTOMERS.
OUR CUSTOMER BASE IS ALL OVER
THE UNITED STATES WE SELL TO
PEOPLE LIKE WHOLE FOODS AND. AND
WE SELL TO THE EAST COAST AND
THE NORTHWEST THAN CANADA SO OUR
PRODUCTS PUBLIC SCHOOL ALL OVER
THE PLACE AND WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF WHAT WE DO.
WE HAVE.
.
WE'VE HAD MERIT MANY FOLKS CHO
ACTUALLY COME OUT TO OUR FOREIGN
TO VISIT US.
YOU MAY KNOW A FEW OF THEM LIKE
GOVERNOR BROWN HAS BEEN THERE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA HAS BEEN TO OUR
FORM. AND AND MANY OTHERS
SENATOR FEINSTEIN AND BOXER.
BECAUSE I AM AN ADVOCATE FOR
AGRICULTURE AND I AM ALWAYS OF
I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO HAVE PEOPLE
COME OUT AND LEARN. ABOUT
AGRICULTURE IN OUR PEOPLE RIGHT
ON THE FORM BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
YOU REALLY LEARN WHAT GOES ON
OUT THERE. AND I WOULD WELCOME
ANY OF YOU TO COME OUT THERE TO
THE FARM AT ANY TIME.
SO WHAT I'M HERE ABOUT TODAY IS
IS ABOUT OUR PEOPLE AND NOW AND
THEN ARE HARSH. CHALLENGES WITH
LABOR.
NOW WE HAVE HAD.
SHORTAGES OF LABOR. OFTEN ON FOR
THE LAST.
TEN YEARS AND IF IT GETS A
LITTLE PROGRESSIVELY WORSE.
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY THE LAST
TIME WE DIDN'T HAVE A LABOR
SHORTAGE WAS PROBABLY.
FOUR FOUR OR SO YEARS AGO WHEN
WE WERE AT THE HEIGHT OF THE
DROUGHT AND WE COULDN'T PLAY AT
ALL OF OUR CROPS.
THAT YEAR WE HAD PROBABLY A
THIRTY FIVE TO FORTY PERCENT OF
OUR FORM FELLOW. SO WE DIDN'T
HAVE JOBS.
THAT WE NORMALLY WOULD HAVE.
AND AND THAT THAT HURTS US
BECAUSE WE ARE SOME OF OUR
PEOPLE DIDN'T DIDN'T HAVE WORK
THAT HERE. BUT TODAY WE HAVE
WATER AND WE HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
PLANTED AND WE WE CAN HOPE TO
HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO PICK THOSE
CROPS.
MELONS ARE VERY PERISHABLE AND
YOU HAVE TO PICK UP THE THE VERY
DAY THAT THEY'RE. THAT THEY'RE
RIPE IF YOU'RE NOT THERE THE
NEXT DAY THEY'RE OVERRIPE AND
AND WE HAVE TO THROW THEM AWAY.
AND AND IT'S A IT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING JOB WE WORK SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK. WE STARTED SIGN UP
AND WE WORK UNTIL WE FINISH THE
FIELD. DOESN'T TAKE IT DOESN'T
MATTER HOW LONG IT TAKES.
NOW IF WE'RE SHORT OF PEOPLE IT
TAKES US LONGER TO COVER THE
FIELD AND SOMETIMES WE DON'T
MAKE IT TO THE END OF THE FIELD
AND WE LOSE SOME OF THE CROP
THAT'S.
AT THE OTHER END.
BUT IT'S BUT IS VERY CHALLENGING
BECAUSE EVERY YEAR WERE WE SEEM
TO BE A LITTLE SHORT OF PEOPLE
AND IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR
WORKERS TO BECAUSE. OUR CREWS
ARE ARE MILLING CREWS ARE TWENTY
PEOPLE BEACH HAVE A DEFINED JOB
AND WHEN THERE'S. SOMETIMES A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE SHORT.
SOMEBODY ELSE HAS TO FILL IN FOR
THEM AND IT IT IT IT DOES CREATE
MORE WORK FOR. ARE UP FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT WE DO HAVE.
SO WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT
WE CAN TO HAVE.
.
A LITTLE BIT MORE SECURE LABOR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER
COMPANIES IN IN OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY AND GET CALIFORNIA.
THAT GROW.
PERISHABLE VEGETABLES AND
FRUITS THAT ALSO HAVE A LOT OF
CHALLENGES.
AND ONE THING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
THAT  I'M ALWAYS PROUD TO
TELL PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD TO COME HERE. IS THAT WE
HAVE THIS THIS WONDERFUL
MEDITERRANEAN CLIMATE THAT WE
CAN GROW ALL THESE FRESH FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES THAT EVERYBODY
WANTS.
YOU GO TO THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THEY BY OUR
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES.
AND SO THE COUNTRY DEPENDS ON
WHAT WE DO HERE AND AND AND WHAT
WE WHAT WE GROW HERE DEPENDS ON
HAND LEVER.
WE ARE NOT ANYTIME SOON GOING TO
MECHANIZE MELON PICKING OR TABLE
GRAPE PICKING. OR. YOU KNOW A
LOT OF THESE OTHER CROPS THAT
HAVE TO BE PICKED CHERRIES LIKE
LIKE WE GROW. CAN DO A BY
MACHINE WE HAVE TO DO IT BY
HAND.
AND HAVE SO WHERE IT WOULD WE
NEED TO HAVE A DEPENDABLE OF
LABOR SO.
SUPPLY SO THAT WE CAN GET THESE
THINGS DONE.
IF WE DON'T OF IT ISN'T JUST THE
FARMS GOING TO HURT IT'S ALSO
THE COUNTRY THAT'S GONNA HURT
BECAUSE WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
PICK.
THOSE HEALTHY FRUITS THAT
EVERYBODY DEPENDS ON THAT BEYOND
CALIFORNIA FOR.
AND SO I WOULD KNOW WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER THIS
BILL.
VERY SERIOUSLY BECAUSE I I
THINK THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD HELP US. AND YOU KNOW
WE'RE TRYING TO.
TRYING TO DO THE BEST WE AN TO
TO CONTINUE TO GROW CROPS.
AND OUR OUR OUR OUR PEOPLE ARE
HARD WORKING PEOPLE AND WE TAKE
CARE OF THEM MY WIFE MAKE SURE
THAT. AND.
AND AND SO THERE ARE THEY'RE
GETTING OLDER HARP OUR WORKFORCE
IS AGING. WE SEE THAT THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE COMING
IN.
ARE FARMWORKERS CHILDREN.
ARE NOT COMING BACK TO THE FARM.
THEY'RE GOING OFF TO COLLEGE AND
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT WE
SUPPORT THEM ON THAT.
WE DO AND.
SO THERE IS A A A GAP THAT'S
BEING LEFT BEHIND BY OUR
FARMWORKERS WHEN SOME OF THEM
RETIRE FROM FROM THEIR JOBS. AND
THERE ISN'T A LOT. OF A GOOD
SUPPLY OF NEW WORKERS TO COME IN
AND TAKE THEIR PLACE.
THANK YOU SIR WE AND AS I
MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET WE'RE
NOT VOTING ON THE BILL TODAY BUT
WE ARE. GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT WORK THAT WILL DO GOING
FORWARD TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT YOU LAID OUT OF THE
BILL LABOR SHORTAGE. AND HOW TO
PROVIDE SECURITY FOR THOSE WHO
ARE DOING THE WORK SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO LIVE UNDER THE THREATS.
OF DEPORTATION OR OTHER
MISTREATMENT OF ANY KIND SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY WHAT
WE WILL BE VOTING TODAY THAT
KNOW THAT WE ARE.
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THE
ISSUES GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I DO WANT TO
HEAR FROM SOME OF THOSE WHO'VE
COME UP FROM I KNOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUBBY OWES DISTRICT AND
OTHERS WHO CAME IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL TODAY BUT I KNOW. THAT
ONE OF THE BILL'S AUTHORS IS IN
THE ROOM WHEN I GIVE HIM AN
OPPORTUNITY IF HE WISHES TO MAKE
SOME BRIEF COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
QUITE A BIT OF TESTIMONY TODAY.
AS FAR AS WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THE WORKERS.
WITH THE SHORTAGE.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE IN THIS BILL
QUITE FRANKLY IS SOMETHING WE
DON'T SEE EVERYDAY EXPRESSING
NOT HERE IN SACRAMENTO?
WE HAVE A BIPARTISAN MEASURE.
THAT IS VERY COMMON SENSE THAT
GIVES PROTECTION.
TO OUR IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE
BY SAYING LET'S KEEP THESE
PEOPLE. AT HOME WAS GIVEN WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
LET'S REMOVE THE FEAR THAT'S
BEEN STIRRED UP ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE.
AND GIVE THEM SOMETHING THAT
MAKES SENSE LET'S GET THEM
VETTED. LET'S GET THEM
DOCUMENTED FOR GOD SAKE.
AND LET THEM KEEP WORKING.
LET'S DEVELOP A GROUP WAVE EDT
TO LOOK AT WHAT BEST PRACTICES
AUTHOR THAT WAY WE DON'T HAVE TO
SIT HERE. AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION OF WHAT DOES THIS
LOOK LIKE GOING FORWARD. QUITE
FRANKLY MISTER CHAIR WE KNOW
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING
FORWARD THIS IS A GROUP THAT
GETS SET UP. WHERE THE GOVERNOR
GETS TO PUT PEOPLE ON THE GROUP
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE IS TO PUT
PEOPLE ON THE GROUP WE WORK
WITH?
THE PROFESSIONALS.
AN EDTA INFUSION ACT WHO KNOW
THESE ISSUES THE PAST.
SEOUL LOOK AT OTHER THINGS AS
THEY COME UP.
AND YOU KNOW A A BIG PART OF
THIS AND I KNOW FOR FOR MY FOLKS
ON THE RIGHT THIS GETS THESE
FOLKS VETTED THROUGH HOMELAND
SECURITY.
THIS WORKS IN CONCERT WITH
CONGRESS AND THE FEDERAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT THE STATE HAS
WITH IMMIGRATION. SO THIS
INSURES THAT WERE NOT KEEPING
CRIMINALS HERE THIS ENSURES THAT
THESE ARE THE HARD WORKING
PEOPLE. THAT WHETHER SOME OF US
LIKE IT OR NOT THIS WORKFORCE.
IS WHAT DRIVES OUR ECONOMY.
IN MANY SECTORS NOT JUST
AGRICULTURE. BUT SEVERAL OTHERS
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN.
AND.
YOU KNOW FOR ME IT'S.
A I I'VE HAD TO WORK WITH MY AG
COMMITTEE I GOT BEAT UP ON THE
RIGHT FOR. BEING ON THIS BILL
AND I SAT THEM DOWN AND I TALK
TO THEM AND I SAID LOOK YOU GUYS
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
THESE PEOPLE ARE HERE.
THEY'RE WORKING THEY'RE TRYING
TO PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM THE
SAME OUR ANCESTORS DID.
WE NEED TO GET THEM VETTED WE
NEED TO GET THEM DOCUMENTED.
AND WE NEED TO GIVE THEM A FAIR
SHAKE AT THIS.
AND IF YOU ASK ANYBODY OUT THERE
AND YOU SAY HEY WHAT DID YOU
THINK.
AND I'LL USE THE WORD ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS SHOULD BE VETTED
THROUGH HOMELAND SECURITY
EVERYBODY WILL TELL YOU YES.
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE A FEW MORE ON
THE LEFT
SO THIS BILL WHAT WHAT WE'VE
DONE HERE WHO PUT A GROUP
TOGETHER THAT IS BALLOTS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY I FIND IT
TRAGIC THAT WERE ONLY DOING
HEARING ENOUGH VOTING AND ALL
THE MY TESTIMONY WITH I THINK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
SOME OF THEM MATHIS AND. FOR THE
RECORD.
AS THAT MAY BE CLEAR THAT.
FIRST OF ALL I KNOW THAT EVERY
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE IS
COMMITTED TO WHAT YOU DESCRIBE
THAT WE WANT TO SUPPORT.
IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES
I THINK THE ISSUE OF
DOCUMENTATION.
HAS NOT BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE
BILL.
I WOULD SAY THAT MANY OF US ON
THIS COMMITTEE ARE INTERESTED IN
CREATING A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP AND DOCUMENTATION.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF CLARITY LET
ME JUST SAY THAT THE BILL DOES
NOT DESCRIBE.
DOCUMENTATION WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEBATE IF YOU
WANT A LIFT THAT UP.
BUT WE ALSO MANY OF US IN THIS
COMMITTEE ARE ALSO INTERESTED IN
CREATING PATHWAYS FOR
CITIZENSHIP
WORK OPPORTUNITIES AND SAFETY
FOR THE WORKERS.
DEALING WITH THE WORK SHORTAGE
WE THINK THAT THERE A WIN FOR
EVERYONE INVOLVED WE WANTED
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE THOSE
WINDS HAPPEN. AND MITIGATE ANY
NEGATIVE EXPERIENCES THAT MY COM
WE WELCOME YOUR HELP GOING
FORWARD IN ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
BE A PART OF THAT COMMERCE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M ONE OF THE
AUTHORS AND I INTEND TO WORK ON
A GONE FOR GOOD FOR TO WORK WITH
YOU.
SOME OF THE RELIGIOUS.
WHY ARE WE NOT VOTING ON THIS
BILL TODAY?
WE'VE.
AT COMPENSATION WOULD CHAIR.
AND STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE
RAISED SOME CONCERNS.
CLARIFICATIONS AS WAS JUST
MENTIONED.
BY TE CHAIRMAN.
WE THINK THAT THERE IS UP SOME
WORK TO BE DONE.
IN ORDER FOR THIS BODY.
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE.
VOTING UP
OR DOWN THE MEASURE
AND SO.
THE CHAIRMAN IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH.
A HANDFUL OF STAKEHOLDERS WHO
HAVE COME OUT IN OPPOSITION.
SURPRISINGLY GROUPS THAT.
TRADITIONALLY WOULD SUPPORT.
THIS CONVERSATION TO HAPPEN.
IN SO I THINK THAT HAS CREATED A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF.
CONCERNS.
AND SO WE'RE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE.
THE CHAIR AND THE.
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED.
SO ORDINARILY WHEN THERE'S
PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL
AMENDMENTS ARE SUGGESTED AND
OFFERED AND.
WE CAN DO THAT THIS TIME.
THERE WERE ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
AND DOES NOTHING CONCRETE.
TURNED OUT.
FROM THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU ASKING
THE QUESTION AND. GIVES ME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO.
BELIEVE HIGHLIHT.
WHAT?
HAPPENED OR DIDN'T HAPPEN AND
ULTIMATELY WHAT.
PATH WERE TAKEN FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THE REALITY IS THAT MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT THIS BILL SEEKS TO
SPEAK TO.
PLAY OUT AT A FEDERAL LEVEL
WHILE THEY AFFECT US HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN CALIFORNIA IS
IMPORTANT TO THIS CONVERSATION.
THERE ARE SOME ASPECTS THAT
CAN'T BE DEALT WITH. AND AS THE
AUTHORS HAVE MENTIONED.
THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE WORK TO BE DONE BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
TO FIGURE OUT A PATH MOVING
FORWARD WHAT'S IRONIC IS THAT.
ARE AMONG OTHERTHINGS
LEGISLATION IS NOT REQUIRED.
BY THIS
HOUSE TO DO WHAT IT IS THAT WE
SEEK TO DO HARM BUT IT IS
CERTAINLY ALWAYS AN OPTION ARE I
FOR ONE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS.
WHO ARE WILLING TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS?
I FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MOVE THESE
CONCEPTS FOR.
AND WHAT THE BILL IS INTENDED
TO DO.
APPRECIATE THE OFFICE FOR THEIR
WILLINGNESS TO DO THAT MUCH
CHAIRED WORD.
A WITNESS WOULD LIKE TO JUST
MAKE A POINT. YES WE COULD BRIEF
WEEKS I'D LIKE TO BRING UP THE
SPEAKERS WHO COME FROM THE
VARIOUS DISTRICTS TO TALK HERE
YET AND A COUPLE OF POINTS
MISTER THURMOND I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THINKS SOMEONE.
IN THIS COMMITTEE SAID EARLIER
ON A BILL THAT WHAT WAS BEING
DONE.
WAS NOT WORKING. AND THAT'S WHY
THE MEMBER HAD A BILL BEFORE
YOU.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU VOTED ON
THAT BUILDING I THINK THAT
COMMENT WAS VERY APPROPRIATE.
WHAT HAS BEEN ATTEMPTED?
FOR THE LAST.
SEVENTEEN YEARS IN CONGRESS BY
GOOD AND WELL INTENTIONED.
ADVOCATES
MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESS SENATE
IN THE HOUSE AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATIONS AND INDUSTRIES
EXCITER. HAS NOT WORKED.
WE HAVE LESS PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
DEPORTATIONS UNDER A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT AND WE HAVE A
PHENOMENAL FEAR FACTOR BY
REPUBLICAN ADMINISTRATION.
SO WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON HAS
NOT WORKED.
NOW I WANT TO MAKE SURE IT WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO YOUR
COMMENTS.
WE ANTICIPATED.
ALL OF THE TYPE OF CONCERNS.
THAT WE HAVE HEARD FROM OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL.
I TESTIFIED OVER A HUNDRED TIMES
ON THE IMMIGRATION BILL IN
CONGRESS THAT CONGRESS PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. OVER A
HUNDRED TIMES ON BOTH THE SENATE
AND ON THE HOUSE SIDE ON EVERY
ASPECT OF THE BILL THAT WAS
PASSED
I WROTE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROGRAM THAT LEGALIZED CLOSE TO
THREE MILLION PEOPLE.
I KNOW THIS ISSUE QUITE WELL
MISTER THURMAN. AND I WOULD SAY
TO YOU AFTER TEN TRIPS TO
WASHINGTON ON THIS ISSUE JUST
LAST YEAR.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED
THE BEST POSSIBLE BILL WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF KNOWING WHAT MR
TRUMP IN HIS ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO WANT. WE WON'T KNOW
THOSE THINGS UNLESS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND ATTEMPT TO SEE IF WE
CAN DO SOMETHING ACHY BUT AGAIN
MY LAST POINT WAS DETERMINE IS
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING IN
THE FIELDS.
DESERVE SOMETHING MORE THAN A
HOLDING PATTERN IT IS NOT FAIR
TO THEM ESPECIALLY AS THEY ARE
WORKING IT ASK YOU TO WRAP THIS
AND. WE WELCOME YOUR EXPERTISE
WE NEEDED AND I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US AS
WE MOVE FORWARD.
.
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT TODAY.
THAT IS A STATEMENT.
ABOUT THE EXPERTISE
AND BUT I THINK YOU YOU DESCRIBE
IT IN A VERY PERFECT WAY.
THERE ARE. POLITICAL FORCES
BETTER OUT OF SIGHT OF THE
CONTROL. OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
THAT NEED TO BE CONSIDERED.
THAT COULD HAVE CONSEQUENCE FOR
PEOPLE THAT WE WERE TRYING TO
HELP.
AND THOSE NEED TO BE CONSIDERED
AND WE WELCOME YOUR EXPERTISE
AND HOW WE ADDRESS THOSE TO
MITIGATE WITH THOSE FORCES MIGHT
BE.
WE'RE GLAD THAT YOU'RE HERE I
LIKE TO HEAR FROM THE SPEAKERS
WHO CAME IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WE HAVE A
MICROPHONE FOR YOU. PLEASE COME
FORWARD WE WELCOME YOU TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY OUGHT TO SPEAK.
UP WE ASK THAT YOU KEEP IT VERY
VERY BRIEF.
TYPICALLY WE ONLY ALLOW YOU SAY
YOUR NAME.
AND YOUR CAPACITY AND YOUR
POSITION WE WILL I YOU A MINUTE
TO TO MAKE WHATEVER POINT YOU
WANT TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
HEAR. WE WELCOME YOU AND AT THE
RIVER REAL QUICK MUCH.
CHAIRED.
MEMBERS AYE I WILL STEP OUT I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE HEARING.
PLEASE REACH OUT MY OFFICE FOR
ANYTHING OR ANY FURTHER
CLARIFICATIONS YOU ABSENT WE
WILL THANK YOU SOME OF MY MATHIS
LOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS MIKE SIMILAR ADEQUATE US I'M
A PHYSICIAN.
IN SALINAS CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OF
CLINIC OF THE SALOON Y. ASIDE
ENOUGH A FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTER THAT TAKES CARE
OF.
A LARGE MIGRANT FARM WORKER
POPULATION IN THE COUNTY.
HA WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE.
WE'RE HOPING THAT.
IN YOUR DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTHORS AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
KNOWLEDGEABLE. ON.
IMMIGRATION.
OUR LAW.
THAT WE LOOK AT.
THIS ISSUE AND A SERIOUS MATTER
BECAUSE AS YOU HEARD OTHER
PEOPLE TALK BEFORE.
IT HAS TREMENDOUS IMPACT.
ON THE ECONOMICS OF CALIFORNIA.
ECONOMICS OF THE NATION.
AND ULTIMATELY THE WORLD.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT IT IN
TERMS OF.
THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THEY CAN
MAKE TO TOMORROW. AND.
EVERY DAY OF THE FUTURE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IS GOING
TO GO AWAY BECAUSE STAKEHOLDERS
OPPOSING IT. LET'S ALL WORK
TOGETHER TO FIND A COMMON
SOLUTION AND A COMMON ANSWER. TO
A BIG PROBLEM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THAT HAS GOT.
WHEN I THOUGHT IF THE FIFTH A
MAJORITY BUT THE MADE THE WHOLE.
BUT I THINK THE LIST I JUST
RELAXING YOGA I LIKE JAPANESE
EASILY EXHIBITS THAT I MISSED IT
DIVA.
THEN.
VINIK AT A SAID.
BUT IN THIS MOMENT BUT MISTER
KAMAL MEMBER THAT I MAY SAY NO.
GOOD AFTERNOON. APPRECIATE BEING
HERE NAME IS EILEEN CHAVEZ SHE
IS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE CLINIC
AS A VITAL SALINAS WHICH IS NOT
HERE IN THAT CAPACITY.
I THINK SHE JUST WANTED TO LET
YOU KNOW THAT WAS VERY ACTIVELY
INVOLVED.
ITS ACT COME UP BUT SO NOT
GIVING ANY CITY THAT THEN YOU
CAN PICK THEM AMPLE.
ASSESSING THE OF MY COMMUNITY.
I YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA COME HIT
THE MUTE AND. EMAIL GATHER THE
AT THE AT THE END IN LITTLE
THISTLES NINOS. BUSINESS PATH IS
AND WHAT GET MOMENT AN OPINION
THAT ACROSS.
MILLER SO PUTTING ME IN THE IT
OR NOT. LEBANESE THEY HAVE. THIS
SEVEN DON'T KNOW MAN THAT
IMPOSES W. WILL WITH YOUR FOR
YOUR MIND THAT THE OPAQUE GLASS
PERSONAS ADAM WOULD YOU SAY THAT
WOULD HAVE HIM COME BE ABLE TO
KEEP.
THEY DIDN'T MAKE A POSITIVE
CHANGE TO ADDRESS.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
YES YES ATLANTIS IMPLACABLY
HAPPY EVP DON'T WHEN BECCA BUT
FROM WHAT I WANT TO SAY THAT
THERE.
IN MY THEY'VE MADE BY MEDIA THEY
BEGIN. THEIR THUMPER HE COOPER
FOR VOTERS TERMINATE QUINN THAT
MOST DOMINANT WHEN THAT IS
SKEPTIC IS THAT.
IN THIS THE BODIES BETTER
BENEFITS HE DECADE WAS THE THIS
IS PUT IT BUT THREE DELEGATES
YET. BERMAN AND WENT BACK
MISTOOK PARA HOPE THAT ACCESS WE
AMABILIS.
WHAT ARE YOU?
HI THERE MY NAME IS SET
MATHEMATICAL LITTLE JUST.
I MEAN I WORK IN A FIELD. AND I
HAVE THEN YOU'RE.
AND THE FIELD WORKER. YEAH YES
THE MIDDLE TARA GAVE A SIMPLE
YET UMBILICAL MODEL THAT YOU
SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE. HOT
POCKETS THEY.
POLICE NOT OF ANY METALLIC ON OF
THE PLACE HE NO AND YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT FIELD.
IF VOICE YOUR BILL GAY.
SO MUCH OF THE AMPLE BE ABLE
SEAMAN THEM AT ALL SEE IF THERE.
MISS BOTH A YOUR OF THE THREAT
COMES UP WE ARE GOING. AND I'M
FAMILIAR ENOUGH AND YOU'LL SEE
WITH.
THE MOST COMMON SIMILKAMEEN BUT
I THINK A.
ON THE AIR.
MIDDLE SPENDS HOURS THERE. NOT
WHETHER MONTHS YOU GOT A LITTLE.
BOTTOM LINE
WE CAME HERE TO WORK.
TREATED ME DONE THAT IN THE IN
MY LIFE.
BOTH WORK HERE WE HAVE A. NINE
MONTH CHILD AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT PERHAPS LADY STATE'S WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE WITH HER.
SOME OF THE SEPARATE.
YES THERE WAS MUCH LESS
POLLUTANTS YOU PC.
I DON'T KNOW THAT AT SOME POINT
YOU. ACCESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON HONORABLE PEOPLE
MY NAME WITHOUT ANYONE
THOUGHTLESS THE I'M A CURRENTLY
THE BOARD MEMBER OF THAT BECAUSE
I THOUGHT REALLY. AND I DO WANT
TO MAKE TWO POINTS ONE IS. THAT
I THOUGHT BOARD MEMBER WE HAVE
SIXTEEN THOUSAND VITH A MONTH.
AND WITH ME THAT YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH NEED WE HAVE FOR THESE KIND
OF SERVICE THAT. WE COULD ARGUE
THE PATH THAT THIS BILL ON THE
THICK IN PART THE THE THE THE
LABOR. AND WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE STAY HERE WE HAVE
UP.
GIGANTIC ACT BETH OF MIGRANT
WORKERS GOING BACK TO MEXICO OR
SOUTH AMERICA WE NEED TO KEEP
THE MIR WE HAVE ALREADY HERE SO
THIS IS A WIN WIN BILL. THAT IT
ONLY ONLY HELP THE ECONOMY
PLAYING CURRENT YOU TO PLEASE
PATH. PATH IS VALE AND WHATEVER
NEEDS TO BE WORKED OUT WITH THE.
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION UP OF
BOB.
SOVIET LET LET LET PHILIP PEOPLE
HELP US WITH THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
WHEN.
ME NUMBER AS VICTORIA SOME BUT
I'M ALSO A THEY ALLOWED US TO
OTHER WHAT THE MY LEFT THE PLAYS
THEY WHAT THEY WANT SHE'S FROM
BOTTOM ALL.
BANG GO NOWHERE ENDS BE IN THE
WEST BUT YOU FIVE NINE YEARS
LIVING HERE.
THEY'VE ALREADY HAVE IS HAVE
BEEN I KNOW. I HAVE A CHILD
SEVEN YEARS.
GET OUT OF THE ULTIMATE IS IT MY
MY.
BUT TO GET TO KNOW PUT OF A
TICKET IS TO UNLIMITED GOD.
GONNA ASK HER EVERYDAY Y. MOM
CAN YOU NOT SAY THAT YOUR LIMIT
IS SUPPORT CAPITAL LOOK WHETHER
STEVE COMIGO I MISSED THAT I
MISS HER WEIGHT LOSS NOTHING
LESS THAN A IF THEY IF
THE BY YOUTH AND THE LAWS OF
THE.
NOT WHAT THEY WANT TO HAVE TO
VOTE ON THIS SCORE LEVY FEEDLY.
OVER THIS THING.
MIDDLE SCHOOLERS BUT IF YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GETTING OVER THE SENATE
BY USE.
WE HAVE TO TELL OUR CHILDREN TO
A DAY WHEN THEY'RE IN SCHOOL WAS
AT THE HOSPITAL I HAVE THING IS
HOW AND GIVEN THAT ON THIS ISSUE
A
SKIP IN THE HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
SEE THE NECESSITY THAT WE HAVE.
S. BOOK.
CLASSES BUT I BLOOD IS TO
EXPERIENCE A.
IN THIS ONE.
HI MY NAME IS AS AND I'VE GOT
THE YOU KNOW THANK GOD THEY SEE
BECAUSE HE HAS THREE CHILDREN.
AND THEN LET THE SISL BEHIND ON
THEIR FEET TEN YEARS WORKING IN
THE FIELD. AYE COMMERCIALIZING
O'DONNELL SELLECK ON WHICH I AND
OTHERS HAVE YET A HIGH BUT OWN
DIDN'T SYMPATHY IN HIS EMAIL THE
SEA LEVEL REVENUES AT ADVOCACY
BECAUSE.
IT WAS A POOR YOUNG IS IS THE
MOST. THIS THAT'S ALL.
IT ALWAYS AFRAID WHEN SHE GOES
OUT THE WORK THAT.
SHE'LL BE SEPARATED FROM HER
CHILDREN ON THE WAY BACK.
SHE IS LOOKING FOR THE SUPPORT
OF THIS COMMITTEE. IT SEEMS THAT
I AND THEN I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
THAT I HAD COME. DO LIKE WORKING
IN THE FIELDS THANK YOU AND MY
PARENTS THEMSELVES MY
MONTH MY MONTH BACK HERE AND SHE
IS FROM THE FIELD AS WELL. AND.
IT'S JUST A GREAT MOVEMENT
WHERE ALL THE PARENTS THOUGHT
COUNTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHEN ESTABLISHED THE NUMBER OF
MONEY A POORLY DONE. SO THAT I
HAVE ANOTHER BAMBOO WHEN MY NAME
IS BY THE UP ITS RUN AND I AM A
FIELD WORKER.
THIS IS A DUMB OF MORE JUST
WHILE YOU'RE THERE BUT OTHER
HELP VERY MUCH BUT I THOUGHT I
MOST CERTAINLY THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THEM MOST SALINAS
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I'M
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE.
IN SUPPORT OF ALL THESE FAMILIES
WERE LIVING IN FEAR SO TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ALICE
TO HELP YOU WITH CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL AND SUPPORT OF
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE WE
APPRECIATE YOU LISTENING TO ALL
THE TESTIMONY TODAY AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR OF THE CO
AUTHORS. YOURSELF AND OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO.
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
BELL AND AND GET SOMETHING DONE
ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU.
WELL MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ALL HUNDRED TOWARDS AS A
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL AND.
AND ALLY OF THE AND DOCUMENTS
AUGHTON DOCUMENT A COMMUNITY I
URGE YOU TO CONSIDER THIS BILL
GOING FORWARD US STRONGLY URGING
IVA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SORRY ABOUT THAT NOT A TALK.
HELLO CHERVEN.
AND THURMOND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SOME FORTUNATE SOME OF
THEM LEFT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO BE HEARD. FORTUNATELY.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE FOR SOME
FOR ME.
MY PARENTS WERE ABLE TO. A GAME
LEGAL STATUS THROUGH THE ORACLE
OF EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR THINGS
TO PEOPLE LIKE ARNOLD TORRES.
FOUND AYE HERE TO TALK ABOUT
MYSELF FOR MY PARENTS I'M HERE
TO TALK ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES AT
WORK AND AYE EGGMAN WATCHMAN A
IN THE FIELDS I MANAGE VARIATION
FOR. THE FARM DOWN IN THE MORE.
AND THIS ISSUE AFFECTS A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS. MY COLLEAGUES AT WORK
THEY'RE NOT ASKING FOR YOU
CITIZENSHIP THEY'RE NOT ASKING
FOR EVERYTHING THEY'RE ASKING
JUST SEE HAVE ITS SENSE OF.
COMFORT THAT THEY'RE GOING FROM
DRIVING FROM HOME TO WORK AND I
DON'T GET PULLED OVER AND GET
DEPORTED AND NO LONGER SEE THEIR
KIDS. ARCHIE GUYS TO VOTE YES IN
FAVOR OF EAT BE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE I KNOW YOU GUYS ARE NOT
VOTING TODAY.
BUT HERSHEY GUYS MOVING FORWARD
A YOU GUYS TAKE THIS ISSUE
SERIOUSLY AND.
PLEASE DO THE RIGHT THING THING
I THOUGHT YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAY BE A FUTURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
AND WHEN AND WHEN YOU GET HERE
YOU'LL YOU'LL LEARN THAT
SOMETIMES UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF
ARCHIMEDES OVERLAP IN MEMBERS
HAVE TO COME IN AND OUT BUT WE
WILL MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE GIST OF WHAT YOU
SHARE. AND.
I'VE SPOKEN WITH MOST OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THEY
ARE DEEPLY COMMITTED TO THE
ISSUES THAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT.
AND AND IS NOT LOST ON ANYONE SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
LOOK FORWARD TO ONE DAY WORKING
WITH YOU. AND AND THE GLORY OF
THE FOR DEVOTING THE GOVERNOR'S.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JUST LET ME KNOW
IF YOU'RE RUNNING AGAINST ME
SIEU COULD HURT HER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF BRIAN LITTLE THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING SUPPORT
FOR AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE THANK
YOU.
THEY HAVE A MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATTHEW WHILE WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE TOO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
IF YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE.
MEMBERS.
MY NAME OF THEIR GROUP I WORK
PER UNIT OF THE FEDERAL.
BUT TO THEM HERE TO REPORT THAT
MY MY NEPHEW.
THE THEIR THEIR PARA THROUGH.
NOT SEE THEIR MOM.
OR FATHER COME BACK SO A ON
BEHALF OF MY MY NEPHEWS I WOULD
LIKE. YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HE WAS HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF. AB EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE ANYONE ELSE.
SAYING NONE IN THE SPIRIT OF
BALANCE WE WANT TO ALSO WELCOME
THOSE.
TO PRESENT WHO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
I BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE SOME
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WISH TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION.
AT ABOUT THE BILL AND.
AND THEN WE WILL HEAR FROM
ANYONE IN THE PUBLIC WHO ALSO
WISHES TO ADD ON ANY CONCERNS
WERE OPPOSITION ABOUT THE BILL
IT.
THERE.
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY OUR NECKLACE
CHAVEZ ON BEHALF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE COMMITS
YOU IN CALIFORNIA TO WORK WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON BEHALF OF
FARMWORKERS AND IMMIGRANTS.
THE SAME PRESIDENT COMMITTED TO
BUILD A WALL TO KEEP IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS OUT.
THE PRESIDENT CREASING WORKPLACE
RAIDS QUOTE I WANT TO SEE FOUR
HUNDRED PERCENT INCREASE IN WORK
SITE OPERATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT WHO ARRESTED
TWENTY SIX FARMWORKERS ON THE
WAY TO WORK IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
AND A SEPARATE INCIDENT A FARM
WORKER COUPLE ON THEIR WAY TO
WORK KILLED IN A CAR CRASH
FULFILLING ICE AGENTS LEAVING
SIX ORPHANED CHILDREN.
THE SW RECENTLY ATTENDED HIS
FUNERAL SERVICE AND IS
ORGANIZING FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
THE CHILDREN.
LAST MONTH THE CONGRESSIONAL
HISPANIC CAUCUS CRITICIZED HOUSE
REPUBLICAN IMMIGRATION PROPOSAL.
WHICH INCLUDES AN AGRICULTURAL
GUEST WORKER PROPOSAL. BY
REPUBLICAN BOB GOODLATTE.
CALLING IT THE MASS DEPORTATION
ACT.
THIS IS THE CONTEXT FOR
CONSIDERING AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE.
GOVERNOR BROWN RECENTLY STATED
IMMIGRATION DEBATE. HAS BECOME
INFLAMMATORY FOOTBALL THAT VERY
LOW LIFE POLITICIANS LIKE TO
EXPLOIT.
THE OF W. AGREES.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOCUS ON
INCREASING WAGES AND IMPROVING
WORKING CONDITIONS.
FOR FARMWORKERS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD FOCUS ON
PROTECTING FARMWORKERS WHO ON
THEIR WAY TO WORK.
THESE ARE POLICIES YOU CAN DO
SOMETHING ABOUT HERE AND NOW.
THE NUMBER OF FARMWORKERS HAS
NOT CHANGED IN CALIFORNIA IN
FACT THE EMPLOYMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT HAS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS ON FILE AND
CULTURE.
WE DON'T HAVE A SHORTAGE OF
WORKERS WE HAVE A SHORTAGE A
CALIFORNIA BASED POLICIES.
THAT HELP IN FOR FARMWORKERS ARE
NOT FALLING BEHIND ALL OF THEIR
WORKERS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE.
WE RECENTLY HAD SOME INITIAL
DIALOGUE.
WITH THE CHAIR AND THE AUTHOR ON
THIS ISSUE.
AND WE ARE OPEN TO CONTINUING
THIS DIALOGUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE AGAIN LIKE THE
AUTHORS AND THOSE WHO OPPOSE SO
WILLING TO COME TOGETHER TO TALK
ABOUT STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES.
THAT ARE IN THIS BILL ANYONE
ELSE WHO WAS HERE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SIR.
ANYONE ELSE IS GOING FORWARD.
BECAUSE RESPONSES A TRAIL OF THE
CALL THIS REMAINING RIGHTS AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
Q. ANYONE ELSE WHO'D COME TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
I WANT TO GIVE THE AUTHOR IF HE
WANTS A CHANCE TO ADDRESS
ANYTHING IN THE COURSE OF
MEMBERS UP QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WILL TAKE THOSE AS WELL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I I WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST SAY
THIS.
AS A SAID EARLIER A LOT OF
THESE ISSUES.
ARE ARE FEDERALLY RELATED AND
THEIR ECONOMIC THEIR
HUMANITARIAN IMMIGRATION SOME OF
THEM MANY OF THEM ARE BIGGER
THAN WHAT THE STATE CAN DO BUT.
THEY ALL IMPACT OUR STATE I
THINK WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO WORK ON THEM.
I SEE TODAY IS A START.
WE DON'T AGREE ON ALL THE
THINGS THAT ARE IN THIS BILL BUT
I THINK EVERYONE AGREES THAT WE
OUGHT TO DO MORE. TO SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND WE'VE GOT TO MAKE
SURE THAT NO ONE HAS TO LIVE IN
FEAR WORK IN FEAR AS A WORKER AS
A STUDENT AS A FAMILY MEMBER. AS
A LOVE ONE AND WE TAKE THOSE
ISSUES TO HEART WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE TO HAVE TO LIVE IN FEAR
WE DON'T WANT ANYONE. TO BE
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN FIND A
SOLUTION AND.
I HAVE OFFERED.
THE SUPPORT OF OF OUR OFFICE
AND I KNOW THAT MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE ARE
WILLING TO WORK TOGETHER WITH
THE AUTHOR. WITH UFW WITH OTHERS
WHO HAVE FEELINGS ABOUT THESE
ISSUES.
I FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN SUPPORT
IMMIGRANT FAMILIES AND WORKERS
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T PUT THEM
AT RISK FOR DEPORTATION FROM HIS
TREATMENT OR FOR ANY KIND OF
ABUSE OR EXPLOITATION.
WE CARE ABOUT THE WORK SHORTAGE
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A WORKFORCE THAT IS ABLE TO
DO THE WORK THAT HELPS TO KEEP
OUR LOCAL BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE STRONG. AND WE CARE ABOUT
OUR FAMILIES WE WANT THEM TO BE
SUPPORTED AND SECURE AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS WE'VE COMMITTED TO
KEEP HAVING THIS CONVERSATION
UNTIL WE IRONED OUT THE BEST
WAYS. TO MOVE FORWARD AND SO I
THINK THOSE WHO ARE HERE TODAY I
ASK WITH THEIR PATIENTS AND KNOW
THAT WE ARE NOT DEALT WITH THIS
ISSUE WERE JUST BEGINNING. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK AT UNTIL
WE GET IT DONE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A
GONZALEZ FLETCHER SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU I KNOW THAT. THAT.
.
TO SAY THE SLAPPING CORNY I KNOW
YOUR HEARTS PEER IN LESS AYE I
KNOW AND THAT YOU CARE DEEPLY
AS.
WE ALL DO WE DO FOR IT FOR THESE
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR.
IT WAS NICE NO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING.
A FARMER WHO.
YOU KNOW I DESPERATELY WISHED A
A YEAR AND A HALF AGO OR TWO
YEARS AGO WOULD HAVE SAID SOME
OF THINGS WE HEARD TODAY IN NOW
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH WORKERS IT'S
NOT GONNA BE DONE BY ROBOTS
WHERE. YOU KNOW WE NEED TO
RESPECT ON THE WORK WE WORK
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK WE WORK AS
MANY HOURS AS IT TAKES ALL THE
THINGS THAT I HEARD.
REMINDED ME OF WHY IN FACT WE WE
OUT WORK SO HARD TO CHANGE THE
RULES.
FOR FORMER GOVERNOR TIME.
AND OUT.
THERE IS A BENEFIT TO THAT.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE WHO SPOKE UNDERSTAND
THAT.
ALL OF US WANT TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN.
TO.
IN PARTICULAR.
I.
TO TO.
TO.
FIGURE OUT A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP
AND FIGURE OUT A PATHWAY TO
RESIDENCY WHATEVER THAT LOOKS
LIKE. AND WE WORKED HARD AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK HARD TO
PRESS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO
GIVE US WHAT WE DESERVE I'M HERE
TODAY BECAUSE MY FATHER CAME
HERE AS A FARM WORKER. I'M HERE
TODAY BECAUSE HE.
HE CAME HERE UNDER SOME.
BIZARRE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WITH A GROWER.
IN AN AGREEMENT AND THANK GOD HE
MARRIED MY MOTHER WHO WAS A
CITIZEN AND.
YOU KNOW NOW IN IT IS THAT IS A.
LEGAL RESIDENT NOW.
.
I ALWAYS WORRY.
ABOUT.
WHERE WE GO WITH THIS
DISCUSSION?
BECAUSE MY DAD DID.
PUT UP WITH VERY HARD WORKING
VERY HARD CONDITIONS IT'S WAS
BEFORE A LOT OF THE PROTECTIONS
WE HAVE TODAY. IN HE DID IT
BECAUSE OF. THE HOPE OF WHAT
WOULD BE EXISTING FOR HIM IN THE
FUTURE AND I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE AS WE CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE ONE OF MY
BIGGEST CONCERN. IS IS BECAUSE
WE HAVE A LABOR SHORTAGE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE AWAY THAT
HOPE FOR IN REPLACE IT SIMPLY
WITH A GUEST WORKER PROGRAM.
THAT REQUIRES A PEOPLE WHO ARE
GIVING US THEIR HARD WORK AND
LABOR IN FEEDING OUR ENTIRE
COUNTRY AS WE HEARD IN GIVING US
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE. THAT
THAT WE ARE USING THEM AS LABOR
ONLY IN NOT PROVIDING THE HOPE
FOR THE AMERICAN DREAM THAT THEY
CAME HERE FOR IN THAT THEY
SACRIFICE THEIR BODIES FOR SO
THAT THEIR CHILDREN CAN REMAIN
HERE. AND AND SO AM I I AM
HOPEFUL AND THANKFUL FOR THE UFW
FOR LEADING THAT FIGHT. IN DC
THAT WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
PUSH FOR THE SPINE DC BECAUSE
WE.
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT A.
A SOLUTION.
DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE RIGHTS OF
THE WORKERS IT DOESN'T TAKE A
WIFE WAY THE RIGHTS OF THEIR
FAMILIES IT PROVIDES A PATHWAY
FOR THEM TO CONTINUE TO STAY
HERE. AND THAT WERE NOT LOOKING
AT FARMWORKERS OR ANY OTHER
NECESSARY.
WORKER AS SIMPLY.
THE LABOR THAT THEY PRODUCE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW AND I KNOW. AT
ALL OF YOU THAT HAS BY NO.
YOU'RE ALL FAMILIES YOUR PEOPLE
YOUR NEIGHBORS YOU KNOW YOU WERE
MIGHT FIT MY FAMILY WAS IN THIS
WORK SO I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT%
OUT THERE BECAUSE THIS THIS BILL
MADE ME NERVOUS AND I THINK WE
HAD DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THAT.
BUT I DO APPLAUD YOUR EFFORTS I
HOPE WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION I HOPE WE. WITHOUT
THE BILL CAN CONTINUE TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING MAYBE SO WE COULD
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
WORKS MAYBE WE CAN WORK WITH OUR
OUR FOLKS.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I ENCOURAGE
ALL OF US TO LOOK AT THOSE
EMPLOYERS AND SAY YOU HAVE TO GO
TO THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS
YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE PRESENT
UNITED STATES. YOU HAVE TO THOSE
PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE SUPPORTED
TIME AND TIME AGAIN AND TELL
THEM WHAT THEY'RE BECAUSE SEEN.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR LIVES THE POWER
TO CHANGE THIS IS IN THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO THAT
THE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE TESTIFYING
SUPPORTED PUT IN OFFICE. AGREED
HAVE THEIR VOICE HEARD BY THEM
AND IT IS TIME THAT THEY HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND NOT COME TO
DEMOCRATIC STATE OF CALIFORNIANS
SAY WE HAVE TO FIX THIS ONE WE
DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY.
WHAT DO WE DONE EVERYTHING WE
CAN WE'VE TRIED AYE EVEN AFTER
PASSING SB FIFTY FOUR WEEK WE
HAVE?
SOME THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WOULD
SUPPORT THIS BILL GOING AROUND
AND TRYING TO UNDO THAT SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
CLEAR. ABOUT WHO IS DOING WHAT
IN THE STATE WHO IS WORKING SO
HARD TO PROTECT OUR IMMIGRANT
POPULATION IN THE ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY. AYE I WILL GO
WITH ANY EMPLOYER TO TO
WASHINGTON DC I DON'T THINK
THOSE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS OR
THE PRESIDENT WANT TO SEE ME.
BUT I WOULD GO IN SUPPORT THAT
BUT THAT'S WHERE THE CHANGE HAS
TO HAPPEN I DON'T HAVE THE POWER
TO CHANGE THAT WE CAN DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN WILL CONTINUE
TO THAT I KNOW WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THIS AUTHOR. AND THE
CHAIR TO DO THAT BUT I REALLY
WANT ENCOURAGE.
THE PRESSURE TO PUSH AS FAR
BACK TO THOSE EMPLOYERS AS
POSSIBLE WHO DO HAVE THAT YOU'RE
OF THOSE FOLKS.
THANK YOU AMERICA CELLS FLETCHER
SOME MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I
ALSO WANT TO ECHO MY THINKS OF
OF THE AUTHOR AND I'M ACTUALLY
GRATEFUL THAT WE'RE NOT VOTING
ON THIS TODAY BECAUSE BECAUSE WE
OPPORTUNITY TO FURTHER. HAVE
CONVERSATIONS NOT JUST WITH THE
AUTHOR BUT THE OTHER.
OF A JOINT AUTHORS AS WELL AS
OF THE CHAIR AND A THIRD. OUR TO
PEOPLE THAT I HAVE GREAT GRAY
MAN RESPECT AND TRUST IN IS THE
CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR TO BE ABLE
LEAST TO HAVE AN HONEST
FORTHRIGHT CONVERSATION AND
DIALOGUE THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
BEGUN. AND CONTINUE TO DO IT
WILL CONTINUE TO DO I KNOW.
EVEN BEYOND TODAY'S
CONVERSATION.
I'M AND YOU KNOW I I I BECAUSE
SOME OF THE SENTIMENTS OF FROM
HIS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND YOU KNOW FROM ONE OF THE
THAT.
OTHER AUTHORS I WON THE JOINT
AUTHORS SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THIS WORKFORCE
DRIVES OUR ECONOMY.
AND THAT'S THE CASE THEN WE SHED
EIGHTY VOTES ON THE ASSEMBLY.
THAT SUPPORT A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP AND PRACTITIONER HAD
EIGHTY VOTES ON FARM WORK
OVERTIME THAT'S REALLY HOW
PEOPLE FEEL ABOUT THIS
WORKFORCE.
AND.
BUT I ALSO FEAR SETTING FALSE
EXPECTATIONS AND FRANKLY EVEN
WITH S. B. FIFTY FOUR RIGHT. AND
LABELING ESSENTIALLY WHAT HAVE
YOU. THEY'RE STILL RAISE A
HAPPEN THE CAPITAL SILICON
VALLEY AND SAN JOSE AS WELL AS
AND. AND FOREIGN COUNTRY.
SO THAT SHOWS HOW MUCH POWER WE
HAVE AND DON'T HAVE.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT WE
DON'T WE CAN DO TO PROTECT OUR
OUR OUR.
I RESIDENTS THERE'S CERTAIN
THINGS WE CAN'T DO.
AND SO. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT.
.
IT AND AND ONE I KNOW ONE OF THE
BETWEEN AUTHORS ALSO ROOMS OR
FOR DEBT. KIND OF FEAR BEING
INSTALLED ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE AND I JUST THINK THAT
THAT.
IT IS NOT A REALITY WE TALK
ABOUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT FEAR
BECAUSE YOU ACTION HAVE MEMBERS
YOUR COMMUNITY THAT HAVE BEEN
DETAINED AND DEPORTED. BY ISIS
VERSES.
YOU KNOW AND THE REALITY OF
THAT HAPPENING. AND THEN THE
FEAR THAT'S IS STILL BECAUSE OF
NOT JUST RHETORIC BUT ACTIONS
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND FROM
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THAT ARE DIVIDING OF SO WHO
CREATING ALLEGE OUR COMMUNITY
THAT'S THAT'S.
CREATING INTENTIONAL FEAR IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
IT'S A MUCH DIFFERENT THING AND
WE HAVE TO BE REALISTIC
ESPECIALLY HAVE MAJOR EMPLOYERS
THE HEART OF OUR ECONOMY. WHICH
IS THE FARMERS IN THE WORKERS
THAT WORK ON THOSE FARMS.
AND YET.
THAT ECONOMY IS NOT HOLDING THE
WHITE HOUSE ACCOUNTABLE.
GOT HOLDING THAT THE CONGRESS
ACCOUNTABLE
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT REALLY.
SHOULD BE PROTECTING THIS
ECONOMY.
SO SHOULD WE AS CALIFORNIANS DO
WILL BE CAN TO PROTECT US
ECONOMY AND PROTECT AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ABSOLUTELY IN FACT I
THINK THIS LEGISLATURE HAS ON
TIME AGAIN INCLUDING THE AUTHOR.
THAT THEY'RE WILLING TO STAND
UP FOR THESE WORKERS I WILL
CONTINUE TO STAND UP FOR THESE
WORKERS.
BUT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
NO WHAT ASSURANCES DO WE HAVE.
IF WE DO HAVE HAVE LIVED F
WE'RE COMFORTABLE AND WE PROVIDE
TO D. H. IF WE COME THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S CUP ALTHOUGH WE DO WE
HAVE A TASK FORCE WORKING GROUP.
AND WE PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION
DHS.
UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION NOT
UNDER.
OBAMA OR THE BUSH OR EVEN REAGAN
WHO PROVIDED AMNESTY. UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHAT ASSURANCES
DO WE HAVE THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OR I USE UNDER
DIRECTION THE PRESENT ATTORNEY
GENERAL WILL NOT USE THAT INFO.
FOR NEFARIOUS PURPOSES WE DON'T.
AND THAT'S THE PROBLEM I THINK
THAT'S THE PART THAT'S WHY
STRUGGLE SO MUCH WITH THIS IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ASSURANCE.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THIS WHITE
HOUSE THAT CONTINUES TO PULL THE
BALL WAY LIKE IT'S LUCY AND
CHARLIE BROWN LOW BALL I'M BORED
CHILDREN FOR DHAKA AND OF COURSE
ISN'T. IT IS NOT OR HAVING TEAMS
HAS COME IN THE OFFICE A. S. FOR
ALL BUT INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM
AND THERE'S NO INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM AND SO DOES THE
CONVERSATION BUT I WANT TO
CONTINUE.
MODEL BUT THE AUTHOR I IN THE
DAYS AHEAD OF THE BORG COMES
BACK ROW BOAT BECAUSE THOSE ARE
REPEAL THOSE ARE VERY REAL
CONCERNS AS TO WHAT WE ARE DOING
IN SOME WAYS.
OF OF GETTING QUITE A
CREDIBILITY TO ADMINISTRATION
HAS NOT DESERVE ANNOUNCEMENT
BASED ON THEIR ACTUAL ACTIONS
NOT JUST THEIR RHETORIC.
SO.
DOT DOES MY COMMENTS RIGHT NOW
I'M HAPPY TO MEET WITH THE
AUTHOR.
AFTER TODAY I TO GET JOB. HERE
OF RESPONSE AS WELL AS
CONVERSATION ON IT.
I DO WANT TO.
IN A SHORT ORDERED GOETZ AB
TWENTY SIXTY NINE THE OFFICE
BEEN PATIENT.
BUT.
QUICKLY SEE IF ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'VE COME AT COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE I'D LIKE TO TURN TO
THE ON IN THEIR CONSIDERATION OF
TIME I WILL BE BRIEF.
WITH MY CLOSING REMARKS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
.
IT'S AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ONE
ACT CLEARLY.
FROM ALL SIDES IN WHATEVER
PERSPECTIVE YOU MAY HAVE.
I WANT TO JUST MAKE SOMETHING
VERY CLEAR IS THAT. TODAY.
WE ARE DEPENDENT ON THE CONGRESS
AND THIS ADMINISTRATION.
TO PUT FORWARD A COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION.
PLAN THAT WE ALL HOPE IS
REFLECTIVE OF NOT ONLY TAKING
CARE OF FAMILIES.
.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME KEEPING IN
MIND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ECONOMIC.
ASPECTS OF WHAT THESE LARGE
POPULATIONS IN. CALIFORNIA IN
THIS COUNTRY.
PROVIDE TO PRODUCE.
DAY IN AND DAY OUT.
.
THE LIKELIHOOD.
THE EXPECTATION
THE ASSURANCE.
IS ZERO.
THAT WE WILL GET.
SOME KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM FROM DC THAT
WILL NEED ALL OF THE
EXPECTATIONS.
THAT WERE REFERRING TO.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE.
TO EMPOWER.
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE. IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE SIXTH LARGEST ECONOMY OF THE
WORLD.
AND THE STATE THAT STRIVING.
ECONOMICGROWTH OF THE UNITED
STATES.
TO LAND OUR VOICE.
TO THE IMMIGRATION CONVERSATION
IN WASHINGTON DC.
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE FIFTY THREE
MEMBERS THAT WE SEND TO
WASHINGTON DC TO WORK ON OUR
BEHALF.
WHEN IN CALIFORNIA.
WE SEE OURSELVES AS A DRIVING
FORCE.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES.
WHEN ASKING THE ADMINISTRATION.
RIGHT TO GIVE US THE GREEN
LIGHT.
ON WHETHER OR NOT WE CAN GO THIS
WAY OR GOAL THAT WE WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICIES.
JUST YESTERDAY WE WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
WE OUR STATE MIGHT HAVE SOME OF
THE TOUGHEST.
CLEAR. DIRECTED POLICIES WHEN IT
COMES TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
IN THE WORKPLACE THIS BUILDING
OUTSIDE OF THIS BUILING.
AND WE'RE GONNA DRIVE IT.
TO BE THE LEADERS ON THAT ISSUE.
IT WOULD REALLY BE DONNING TO ME
THAT AN ISSUE. AS IMPORTANT AS.
IMMIGRATION.
AND THE ECONOMY.
WOULD NOT BE AN ISSUE THAT WE
WOULD.
NOT CHAMPION.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO WASHINGTON
DC.
AND LET IT BE KNOWN THAT THEIR
NEEDS TO BE A FIX EITHER THEIR.
OR TO ALLOW US.
TO PROVIDE A FIX HERE.
AND THE FIX HERE THAT'S
PRESENTED IN THIS BILL ALTHOUGH
IT'S BEEN SAID. THERE ARE
CONCERNS.
IT CLEARLY STATES THAT WERE
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS THAT ARE WORKING HERE
ON PERMITTED.
GIVE GET RECEIVE A CERTAINTY.
HAD COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
AND CONTINUE CONTRIBUTING.
TO OUR ECONOMY AND TO THE THESE
VERY IMPORTANT INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE BEFORE US.
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS OF THE
PARENTS THAT ARE HERE OR OF THE
CHILDREN THAT WE WORK THAT WE
HEARD.
.
FROM MORE ABOUT IN THE
TESTIMONY.
I DON'T THINKTHAT THAT'S
SOMETHING OUTSIDE OF OUR REACH.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU KNOW FOR
SOMEONE TO SAY. WE SHOULD STAY
IN OUR LANE. RIGHT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AND YOU TAKE CARE OF YOUR
STATE ISSUES I DON'T THINK
THAT'S. ENOUGH SUBSTANCE
FOR US TO DO NOTHING AND I KNOW
THAT WE'RE SAYING WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP WORKING ON THIS ISSUE.
I I BELIEVE THAT.
WE HAVE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
CHAMPION.
ANOTHER ISSUE ANOTHER BECAUSE.
THAT IT INTERSECTS WITH.
PEOPLE ARE FAMILIES AND
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
AND I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
A HUNDRED PERCENT COMMITTED TO.
WORKING WITH ALL OF YOU. AND.
AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU SERIOUSLY CONSIDER.
WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY AND.
THE DIFFERENCE THAT WE CAN MAKE
IN. THOUSANDS THOUSANDS OF
IMMIGRANT LIVES THAT ARE HERE IN
OUR STATE.
WORKING IN DRIVING THE THE
ECONOMY FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISTER.
I THANK YOU I THINK YOU'RE CLOSE
SAYS IT ALL.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP HERE. AND FOR
RIGHTFULLY SAYING THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE IN THIS
CONVERSATION WHILE WE CAN'T.
SET THE TABLE ARE CONTROL ALL
THE ISSUES ARE TAMI. OUR
DIVERSITY OUR COMPLEXITY
OBVIOUSLY HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN THE
NATION. AND WE ARE LEADER SO
THANK YOU FOR LEADING CALIFORNIA
FOR BEING A LEADER ON THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
WE'RE GONNA CLOSE THIS
DISCUSSION AND WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE.
SO HE MEMBER BONTA IS HERE TO
PRESENT. WELCOME SIMILAR BONTA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU.
A COMMITTEE CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND IT'S BEEN A LONG
DAY.
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE.
UNDER LONGSTANDING CURRENT LAW.
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA CANNOT BE
DISMISSED OR DENIED EMPLOYMENT
DUE TO THEIR USE OF PRESCRIBED
MEDICINES
SUCH AS OPIOIDS OR TO TREAT A
MENTAL OR PHYSICAL DISABILITY OR
MEDICAL CONDITION.
UNLESS THAT USE A MEDICINE POSES
A SAFETY RISK
OR CREATE AN UNDUE HARDSHIP FOR
EMPLOYERS TO ACCOMMODATE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINE WOULD REQUIRE
THAT THE MEDICAL USE OF CANNABIS
AS RECOMMENDED BY DR. BE GIVEN
THE EXACT SAME REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION AS OTHER
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT OR FEET HIGH.
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL RELATES TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS ONLY. WHEN A
PATIENT HAS A RECOMMENDATION FOR
A MEDICAL DOCTOR TO USE CANNABIS
TO IT DOES NOT. APPLY IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM TO ADULT USE OF
CANNABIS.
UNDER THIS BILL EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO FEDERAL MANDATES
SUCH AS TRUCK DRIVERS SCHOOL BUS
DRIVERS.
AND AVIATION WORKERS AS WELL AS
FEDERAL GRANTEES LIKE HOSPITALS
WOULD BE EXEMPT THIS BILL WOULD
NOT APPLY TO THEM.
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE DOES NOT IN
ANYWAY APPLY TO OR PROTECT
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE IMPAIRED. AND
UNABLE TO PERFORM THE ESSENTIAL
FUNCTIONS FUNCTIONS OF THE JOB
BECAUSE OF THE USE OF CANNABIS.
THAT CONTINUES TO BE. ARM
SOMETHING THAT'S PROHIBITED.
AND WHILE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
IMPAIRMENT I'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT THERE IS NO
LEGAL STANDARD FOR CANNABIS
IMPAIRMENT LIKE THERE IS FOR
ALCOHOL IMPAIRMENT.
AT WHICH WE HONOR HAS THE POINT
ZERO EIGHT PERCENT BLOOD
ALCOHOL.
CONTENT TEST.
THAT'S TRUE BUT IT'S ALSO
COMPARING APPLES AND ORANGES CAO
ALCOHOL IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
AT ISSUE HERE IT'S NOT A A
PRESCRIBED MEDICINE. AND TO MY
KNOWLEDGE THERE ARE NO I'M PER
SE IMPAIRMENT TESTS FOR ANY OF
THEM THE MEDICAL.
.
PRESCRIBE MEDICINES THAT WERE
THAT WE WOULD BE AT ISSUE IN
THAT IN THE WORKPLACE.
I KNOW THIS THAT THERE ARE SOME
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
THAT THAT HAVE SOME AGREED UPON
LEVELS BUT BUT THOSE ARE NOT THE
SAME AS PER SE IMPAIRMENT TESTS.
SO.
THERE'S NOTHING UNIQUE ABOUT
CANNABIS THAT CAN'T BE
ACCOMMODATED UNDER THE SAME FEE
HAS STRUCTURE AS ALL OF THE
OTHER. MEDICAL LABS AND MEDICAL
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THAT ARE
BEING USED NOW.
ALSO.
CALIFORNIA IS OFTEN ON THE
VANGUARD ON THE FRONT LINES ON
THE CUTTING EDGE DOING THINGS
FIRST WERE NOT HERE THERE ARE
TWELVE STATES THAT ALREADY HAVE
THIS LAW.
I IN THOSE STATES.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD A CLAMORING
FROM EMPLOYERS WE HAVEN'T HEARD
FROM ANY PARTICULAR. A TRAITOR
INDUSTRY THAT THAT THE SKY HAS
FALLEN IN AND THINGS CAN NO
LONGER WORK.
I'M OF COURSE THERE ARE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN STATE LAW AYE BUT
WE THINK THAT IF IT CAN WORKING
TWELVE OTHER STATES GIVEN ALL
THE THINGS THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
ACCOMPLISHED AND WILL CONTINUE
TO ACCOMPLISH WE CAN ALSO. MAKE
IT WORK
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
MANY WORKERS FIND THAT THAT
CANNABIS CAN BE. A.
ARE EXCELLENT ALTERNATIVE TO
OTHER DRUGS THAT HAVE A VERY
DEBILITATING SIDE EFFECTS SUCH
AS.
ADDICTIVE OPIOIDS ROLLO EVER
OPEN LIKE CRISIS.
AND A LOT OF STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
EQUIPMENT CLEAN ONE FROM DR
SANJAY GUPTA THAT I WAS JUST
READING THE OTHER DAY. THAT.
CANNABIS CAN BE A REAL
ALTERNATIVE AT TWO TWO ADDICTIVE
OPIOIDS.
BUT RIGHT NOW.
CANNABIS PATIENTS ARE NOT GIVEN
THIS ALTERNATIVE
THE CAN'T USE CANNABIS MEDICAL
CANNABIS AND THAT INSTEAD OF
ADDICTIVE OPIOIDS AND KEEP THEIR
JOB. UP RIGHT NOW THEY WILL BE
THIS AT THEIR ALLOWED TO BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AND AND
LOSE THEIR JOB SIMPLY FOR USING
MEDICAL CANNABIS. AND THE SEEKS
TO AND THAT.
NO THERE THERE ARE QUITE A FEW.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ALREADY IN
THE IN THE MARKETPLACE ALREADY
BEING USED BY WORKERS IN WHO ARE
EMPLOYED. AT MORE WILL WILL COME
AS NEW DRUGS ARE ARE INVENTED
AND ENTER THE MARKETPLACE.
AND OUR ASKING IS THAT THE SAME
PROCESS PROCESS THAT IS.
PRESCRIBED UNDER FEE HA BE USED
HERE THAT A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION BE GIVEN.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
INTERACTIVE PROCESS BEING GAUGED
IN WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN EMPLOYER
AND EMPLOYEE.
ABOUT A JOB THAT EMPLOYEE CAN DO
ARE UNDER CERTAIN CONDITIONS
THAT WHILE THEY ARE.
TAKING MEDICINE FOR THEIR
MENTAL OR OR PHYSICAL CONDITION.
AND THAT THAT STRUCTURE HAS
WORKED
I FOR SOME MONEY AND MEDICINES
UP TO NOW WE THINK IT CAN WORK
FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS.
AS WELL.
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE IS NEEDED
TO PROTECT OUR WORKERS PATIENTS
WHO ARE SICK.
AGAINST NEEDLESS DISCRIMINATION
IN THE WORKPLACE AB TYPE TWENTY
SIXTY NINE IS AN EQUITABLE
REASONABLE MEASURE THAT PROTECTS
PATIENTS EMPLOYERS AND THE
PUBLIC.
AND TREATS MEDICAL CANNABIS
ACCOMPANIED BY MEDICAL DOCTORS
RECOMMENDATION THE SAME AS ALL
OTHER MEDICINES.
IN THE WORKPLACE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
LOOK FOR TAR DIALOG I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. WITH ME HERE TODAY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY NINE IS RYAN MILLER. CO
FOUNDER OF OPERATION EVEN BACK
EDUCATING VETERANS ABOUT
CANNABIS
AS WELL AS ALLEN CROWLEY AND
EMPLOYMENT LAW EXPERT AT
WEINBERG ROGER AND ROSENFIELD
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF YOUR CW. A
CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WE WILL HAVE LOVE FOR
EACH OTHER SIDE.
TWO MINUTES INTO WITNESSES. THE
FIRST WITNESS FIRST WITNESS.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS RYAN MILLER
OF OPERATION EVAC EDUCATING
VETERANS ABOUT CANNABIS. AND WE
PREVENT SUICIDE AN OPIATE
OVERDOSE IN MILITARY VETERANS.
THROUGH CURATING COMMUNITY AND
PRACTICING MINDFULNESS
FORTIFIED WITH COMPASSIONATE
FREE A CANNABIS ACCESS IN
EDUCATION.
MY OWN EXPERIENCE WHEN I WAS
DISCHARGED HONORABLY FROM THE
MARINE CORPS.
I HAD A MICROSOFT AND CISCO
CERTIFICATION.
AND I CAME HOME ESSENTIALLY TO
SILICON VALLEY.
ARGUABLY THE OPTIMAL MILITARY
EXPERIENCE AND TRAINING FOR
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION TO
CIVILIAN EQUIVALENT.
HOWEVER BEING FROM A WORKING
CLASS.
COMMUNITY MY NETWORK WAS BLUE
COLLAR FOLKS.
GARBAGE MAN PLUMBERS TRADES
FOLKS.
AND SO I DID HAVE THE NETWORK TO
GET INTO TECH AND I HAVE A LOT
OF SOCIAL ANXIETY. THAT
PREVENTED ME FROM.
NETWORKING I IN PENETRATING THE
TECH
A NETWORK.
SO WHAT I'M ASKING YOU TODAY IS
IF YOU WANT TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONING. A
MILITARY FOLKS INTO THE CIVILIAN
SOCIETY IF YOU WANT TO BE
SERIOUS ABOUT PREVENTING SUICIDE
AN OPIATE OVERDOSE ON ECONOMIC
EMPOWERMENT SPECIFICALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT. IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO DO THAT.
I SPENT SEVEN YEARS AT FEDEX
OFFICE MAKING COPIES FOR KINKO'S
AFTER I LEFT THE MILITARY.
I DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE ANOTHER
URINALYSIS TESTS AT ANOTHER.
POTENTIAL EMPLOYER I WOULD
DEGREE FROM GOLDEN GATE
UNIVERSITY IN MANAGEMENT AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY.
HOWEVER.
BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT
SPECIFICALLY URINALYSIS TESTING
HAS PREVENTED ME FROM.
SUCCESSFULLY MANAGING THAT
TRANSITIONS SO THANK YOU FOR A.
ASSEMBLYMAN BONTA IN.
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE WE CAN
HELP.
MOTIVATED IS BETTER TRANSITION
SUCCESSFULLY SO THANK YOU. MAKE
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
I OR MY NAME'S ALAN CROWLEY AND
I AM A LABOR EMPLOYMENT ATTORNEY
HAVE BEENPRACTICING WITH THE
WIND RUSH ROSENTHAL FIRM FOR
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS.
AND I'VE NEGOTIATED ALL KINDS OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
WITH.
DRUG ALCOHOL POLICIES.
INCLUDING ONES THAT ARE IN THE
SO CALLED ZERO TOLERANCE.
WENT LIVE SETTINGS.
EVEN PRESENTED A CONFERENCES
INVOLVING A DRUG TESTING IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SON I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE DRUG
TESTING IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY. ALL INDUSTRIES IN
FACT.
AND I'VE A REPRESENTED HUNDREDS
OF NOT THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN
CASES INVOLVING DRUG TESTING.
SO I JUST WANT TO TRY TO
DISENTANGLE A LITTLE BIT. V. A
DRUG FREE WORKPLACE POLICIES
FROM REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
I THINK THAT.
THEM.
SO.
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN HAD DRUG
FREE WORKPLACE POLICY SINCE AT
LEAST NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
THEY'VE BEEN DEALING WITH.
.
ACCOMMODATIONS SINCE THE EIGHTY
EIGHT WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
NINETY.
AND SO THEY WOULD BE BASICALLY
FOLLOWING THE EXACT SAME
POLICIES AND UPDATE THAT THEY
USE TO ACCOMMODATE.
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS THAT THEY DO FOR
MEDICAL CANNABIS EXACT SAME
PROCESS.
AND SO CURRENTLY IF AN EMPLOYER
HAS A DRUG FREE POLICY IT
TYPICALLY STATES THAT THE
EMPLOYEE HAS TO INFORM THE
EMPLOYER.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE DANGERS
OPERATION THAT THEY MAY BE
TAKING MEDICATION THAT MAY
IMPAIR THEIR ABILITY TO WORK.
AND.
AND THEN.
.
BUT IF THE EMPLOYEE IS SUBJECT
TO DRUG TESTING. AND DOESN'T
INFORM THE EMPLOYER THEN CASE
LAW HOLDS VERY CLEARLY THAT THE
EMPLOYER CAN TERMINATE THE
EMPLOYEE BECAUSE THE EMPLOYEE
NEVER MENTIONED IT TO THE AMP TO
THE EMPLOYER.
SO CURRENTLY EMPLOYERS EASILY I
HAVE WE HAVE THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS TO MILLIONS OF
EMPLOYEES WHO. HAVE PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS THAT.
CAN MAKE HIM DROWSY THAT CAN
MAKE THEM DISEASE THAT CAN MAKE
IT CAN AFFECT IMPAIRMENT. AND.
THOSE PRESCRIPTION THOSE
EMPLOYEES OF PRESCRIPTION
MEDICATIONS.
IF THEY'RE IN A DRUG FREE
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENTS.
THEIR FOR THEIR OBLIGATION IS IS
TO INFORM THE EMPLOYER THAT THEY
TAKE THE MEDICATION.
IF THEY DON'T AND THEY ARE DRUG
TESTED. V. EMPLOYER IS LEGALLY
ALLOWED TO TERMINATE THE
EMPLOYEE FOR FOR NOT REPORTING
AND FOR FEELING THE DRUG TEST.
IF THE EMPLOYEE THEN SAYS I WANT
A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
BECAUSE OF THIS.
HOPE YOU A PRESCRIPTION FOR
LIKE AND WHAT.
THAT'S YOU CAN GET RETROACTIVE
ES DE ACCOMMODATION.
SO SO BASICALLY VIS VIS HER
EMPLOYERS OF AN OPERATING.
AND AND AND AND IN DEALING WITH
EMPLOYEES YOU COULD REQUEST
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY ARE IN THE
SAME ENVIRONMENT WITH A DRUG
FREE WORKPLACE AREAS SO IT'S
IT'S A VERY SIMPLE PROCESS.
SO.
AND AND THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTEND
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE MEDICAL
CANCER TRIPS PRESCRIPTIONS WOULD
EXTEND THE REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION PROCESS TO THE
VERY MINIMAL PROCESS.
SO AN EMPLOYEE. JUST SIMPLY
WOULD HAVE THE RIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA TO ASK FOR A
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
THE EMPLOYER GETS TO CHOOSE THE
THE EMPLOYEE CAN SUGGESTS.
ACCOMMODATIONS BUT IT IS UP TO
THE EMPLOYER TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE.
IF THE EMPLOYER BELIEVES THAT
THE EMPLOYEE CANNOT SAFELY.
PERFORM THE ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS
OF THE JOB.
THE EMPLOYER CAN ASK EMPLOYEE
FOR CERTAIN OF MEDICAL.
.
DOCUMENTS SAYING CAN YOU TO
PERFORM IS THIS.
FUNCTIONS THAT'S UP TO THE
EMPLOYER TO DECIDE IF THE
EMPLOYEE CAN PERFORM THAT WORK
WHETHER THERE HAVE A
PRESCRIPTION FOR LIKE IT IN OR
NARCO OR BENZODIAZEPINES OR
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
AND SO.
IF THE EMPLOYER APPROVES OF THE
ACCOMMODATION OF THEN THE
EMPLOYEE CAN WORK IF THEY CAN'T
THEN THE IT AND IT GOT TO THE
PROCESS.
SO THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS
A PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN WORKING
FOR AT LEAST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS.
TO MILLIONS OF WORKERS THAT YOU
USE PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS TO.
EMPLOYEES WHO NOW USE MEDICAL
CANNABIS IT'S THE SAME PROCESS.
.
I CAN GET YOU TO WRAP SIR YEAH
SURE SITE IF YOU HAVE ANYMORE
QUESTIONS I'D I KNOW THE DETAILS
OF THESE LAWS EXTREMELY WELL AND
BE GLAD TO ANSWER ANY MORE
QUESTIONS.
AND SO.
I'M CERTAIN THERE WILL BE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU TODAY OKAY.
.
DODD AYE AYE LET'S GO LITTLE
LONGER BECAUSE THIS IS OBSCENE
TRY TO NEW TERRITORY AND I THINK
IT NEEDS TO GET STATED WILL GIVE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME TO THE
OPPOSITION. AND SHOULD BE NEED.
THANK YOU OTHERS WHICH AN ADD ON
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOING BACK IS FOR
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFA BASED IN SAN JOSE
WEREN'T AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
I THINK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROBERT
HARRIS ON BEHALF AYE ASCII YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
DALE DURING A WITH CALIFORNIA
NORMAL ONE OF THE A CO SPONSORS
OF THE BILL ARE WE HEAR A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THIS PROBLEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RICH MILLER AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS MUSCLE HERE FOR AMERICAN
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS
HEALTH EDUCATION ILLEGAL
PATIENTS RIGHTS I AM A PETITION
THE STATE I'M IN MR MCLARTY'S.
AREA I HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY THIS I HAD A SIX
FIGURE JOB I CAN NO LONGER WORK
THAT JOB. I COULD NOT TAKE
PHARMACEUTICALS THAT ALMOST
KILLED ME.
YOU SORT OF THEIR FARMS SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HOW MANY MISSILES WITH ALMOND
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE ON BEHALF
OF MYSELF HERE TODAY TO? BE HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JENNIFER COULD WISH
I'M A REGISTERED NURSE IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT IN SAN JOSE.
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
AS WELL OMINOUS I KNOW MY SON'S
FIVE IN HE BENEFITTED FROM
MEDICAL CANNABIS IT STOPPED HIS
TEACHERS WHEN NOTHING ELSE DID
SO. THEY I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS THAT CAN BENEFIT FROM.
THANK YOU.
JOSH OGLE CHO THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
REMOVE ON BEHALF OF THE.
HISPANIC CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE
AND THE BLACK CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE OR IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE OPPOSITION
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
CAN WE MAKE SOME ROOM FOR THEM
AT THE TABLE PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTY FISHER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND SURPRISE.
OF.
WE THOUGHT WELL WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS TIME WE ARE
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENT STILL.
ARE TRYING TO FIND A PATH
FORWARD OF WITH THIS WILL
HOPEFULLY BE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR BUT AT THIS TIME WE ARE
STILL IN OPPOSITION AND OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN. STILL REMAIN
SAFETY IN THE WORKPLACE AND OF
THE LACK OF A TEST FOR
IMPAIRMENT.
HI AND GOOD AFTERNOON MICROBES
INHERENTLY HAVE QUEST
DIAGNOSTICS ON.
AT QWEST HAS I AM. QUITE A
COUPLE FEW COMMENTS HERE I'M
OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
BASICALLY POSTED BASICALLY EVEN
THE UNDERLYING PREMISE THE
PREMISES LAID OUT BY THE AUTHOR
IN IN THE IN THE FACT SHEET.
I'M THAT THERE SOME FINDINGS IN
THE BILL THAT DISCUSS THE FACT
THAT I THE FDA HASN'T FOUND.
DRUG TESTING IN THE WORKPLACE
BE SAFER EFFECTIVE IN AND WE
JUST CHALLENGE THAT.
THE THAT SINCE SINCE DRUG
TESTING IN THE WORKPLACE IS HAS
BEEN INSTITUTED BACK IN THE
NINETIES. ON DRUG USE IN THE
WORKPLACE HAS CONSISTENTLY GONE
DOWN EXCEPT IN YEARS WHERE YOU
KNOW MARIJUANA HAS BEEN
LEGALIZED IN DIFFERENT PLACES
AND AT SPIKE'S A LITTLE BUT THEN
IT GOES DOWN.
AND AND AND THE FACT IS IS A
DRUG FREE WORKPLACE IS A SAFER
PLACE THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE ON
DRUG ABUSE HAS HAS.
STATISTICS I MEAN THAT THAT THE
THE WORKPLACE IS MORE PRODUCTIVE
THERE'S LESS INJURIES ARE LESS
WORKERS COMP COMPENSATION
CLAIMS.
IT IS IT IS IT IT LEADS TO
SAFETY IN THE WORKPLACE AND WE
JUST WOULD YOU KNOW.
CHALLENGE THAT THAT IN THE
FINDINGS. AND WE DON'T THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO AND
NECESSARILY COMPARE CALIFORNIA'S
EMPLOYMENT PICTURE THAT THE WITH
THE WAY IT.
MARIJUANA IT'S MET MEDICAL
MARIJUANA STREET IN THE
WORKPLACE ON THE BACK AND IN
THEM AND EMPLOYMENT SIDE WITH
OTHER STATES YOU KNOW THE
DISTANCE THING WITH TWELVE
STATES ARE TEN STATES. THAT THE
FRONT END OF THIS IS DIFFERENT
THE STATE'S WE SHOULD YOU KNOW
AS AS AS A SOMEONE BONTA NOTED
THINGS ARE YOU KNOW THERE IS A
BIT OF APPLES AND ORANGES HERE
SOME SOME STATES HAVE. YOU KNOW
THAT THAT THEY HAVE DUBBED THE.
WHAT LEADS TO A PRESCRIPTION? IS
DIFFERENT AND HOW IT'S
PRESCRIBED ON ON HOW OFTEN IT'S
PRESCRIBED AND THE.
THAT THE SOME STATES REQUIRE
RENEWAL OF THAT SOME STATES HAVE
A HARD AND FAST RULE ON A CARD
SO WE JUST DON'T THINK THAT THAT
SHOULD NOT NECESSARILY BE THE
PRINT THE BASIS FOR WHICH YOU
ARE. YOU PATTY YOUSEF CALIFORNIA
ON THEM FINALLY.
.
WE DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD BE
EACH AND WE SHOULD BE EQUATING.
.
MEDICAL MARIJUANA USE AND AND
AND OPIATES IN THE IN THE
WORKPLACE THAT DAY CLEARLY THERE
IS A PROBLEM WITH OPIOIDS AND
THERE'S A DOZEN BILLS AND
LEGISLATURE TRYING TO UNRING
THAT BELL. WHAT AT WHATEVER
WE'VE DONE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
LED TO THIS PROLIFERATION OF
OPIATES IN THE WORKPLACE?
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE FIXED BUT WE
SHOULDN'T SAY ALL THE WAY TO FIX
IT IS ASSIST ALLOWED MORE
MEDICAL MARIJUANA I MEAN
MEDICAMENT MARIJUANA IS STILL
ADDICTIVE I MEAN THEY'RE IN THE
IN THE IT'S IT'S THERE'S THERE
IS A. THERE IN THE NATIONAL TO
SOME DRUG ABUSE YOU KNOW THIRTY
PERCENT OF A PEOPLE ON WHICH YOU
CAN USE IT VERY REGULAR USE OF
MARIJUANA CHAU. ADDICTIVE
TENDENCIES AND SOME PERCENT OF
THOSE HAVE AN ADDICTION AND SO
WE WE SHOULDN'T JUST KIND OF
TRADE ONE ADDICTION THING FOR
ANOTHER ADDICTION THING SO WE
ASK YOU TO. HOLD THIS BONE
COMMITTEE MAYBE MAYBE SAID ON
THIS FOR AWHILE AND LET'S SEE
HOW HOW THE WHOLE MARIJUANA
THING CALIFORNIA SHAKES OUT
BEFORE WE START CHANGING
EMPLOYMENT LAW. THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU OTHERS WHO WISH TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
I. MISTER CHAIR MEMBER SCOTT
GOVERNMENT HAVE THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION WE ENTER
INTO THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS WITH THE WEINBERG
FUHRMAN HAVE A DIFFERENCE OF
OPINION ON. YOUR.
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS GENERALLY ABOUT THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION MAINLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INCREASED
LIABILITY FOR EMPLOYERS.
OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
SEAN THOSE OF THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION OF INDEPENDENT
BUSINESS REPRESENTING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS REALLY THINK THE
AUTHOR AND STAFF FOR THE OPEN
DIALOGUE ONE TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE. BUT FROM RESOLVED
WORKPLACE SAFETY LITIGATION
CONCERNS REMAIN OPPOSED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURSTING HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
AND THE URBAN COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
CATH LOSSES COVERED IN THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ASSOCIATE OR COMMENTS WITH
THE CHAMBER I'M AND REMAIN
OPPOSED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN LITTLE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION LIKE TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE POSITION AND THE
CONCERNS OFFERED BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE CHAMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THE CALL RICE CALVARY
MANUFACTURES A TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION WERE ALSO POST
THANK YOU.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION AND
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES AND ONE
I THINK THE AUTHOR FURTHER
RECENT AMENDMENTS AND. BUT HOPE
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW
ON WESTERN ROAD ASSOCIATION ALSO
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
AYE BY MARTY FISHER THE CHAMBER.
THANK YOU.
THERE STILL GIVENS WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ALSO OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
JAMIE CON ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
BUT WE STILL HAVE CONCERNS WITH
BILL AND HAVE TO BE UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ADDING ON IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOU
KNOW I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRING THIS FOR THIS IS NOT A
SIMPLE. ISSUE THERE'S OTHERS I
IT'S IT'S COMPLEX ISSUE. LA AND
UNDER A LOT OF THEM REGARDING
CANNABIS RIGHT NOW I MEAN I
THINK THAT'S WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW IS WE'RE TRYING TO SORT ALL
THIS OUT.
IT DEFTLY BALANCES LOT OF
ISSUES WITH WORKER RIGHTS OF
PATIENT RIGHTS WITH EMPLOYER
RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITIES TO ALL
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND OF COURSE
WORKPLACE SAFETY WHICH WE ALL.
YOU KNOW TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY IN
THIS BUILDING FOR CERTAIN.
AND I DO THINK AGAIN ON EARLIER
BILL.
THAT WHERE THERE WAS SOME MIX.
THE CHAMBERS SAMPLERS EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERN EARLIER BILL AND I
CIVIL.
YOU KNOW I DIDN'T TAKE THOSE
CONCERNS. IN THE SAME WAY I
THINK THESE ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS AND I THINK THAT WE ALL
SHOULD REALLY BE STOP ABOUT IT
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT. LOOK LIKE
THE DRUG.
THE DRUG FREE WORKPLACE.
HE A IT'S ON ACCIDENT BUT NOT
ALL THINGS ARE IN EIGHTY EIGHT.
IT WAS THE HEIGHT OF THE WAR A
WAR ON DRUGS WAS JUST SAY NO.
AND IT WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
ILLEGAL DRUGS.
AB AND A STREET DRUGS AND KIND
OF THAT WERE RUNNING RAMPANT.
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY AT THAT
TIME
THERE'S A LOT REASONS WHY THEY
WERE OF I'M NOT GONNA GET INTO.
BUT.
.
THAT THAT IN NINETEEN NINETY AT
EIGHTY EIGHT. WAS MADE A VERY
CLEAR AWAY JUST LIKE WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT.
THOSE PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
THOSE DRUGS ACTUALLY I
MEDICINALLY PRESCRIBED WE'RE NOT
REFERRING TO THOSE BECAUSE THOSE
ACTUALLY HAVE A BENEFIT AND IT
DONE PROPERLY AND EMPLOYERS
INFORMED. AND APPROPRIATE MANNER
A YOU CAN ALLOW FOR REASON
ACCOMMODATION BOUGHT THE SAME
TIME ENSURING THAT THERE'S
WORKPLACE SAFETY BECAUSE OF ONE
IS IMPAIRED I'D END OF THE DAY.
DOTS THAT TAKES PRECEDENCE THAT
YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD NEVER ALLOW
SOMEONE TO PUT ANYONE ELSE CLEAN
THEMSELVES IN DANGER.
I AND SO YOU KNOW THAT THE
REALITY IS THAT.
BICU GIVEN THE FACT THERE'S
AN ACCEPTABLE LEGAL PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THERE'S PLENTY OF FOLKS.
THAT USE CANNABIS OFFER
MEDICINAL PURPOSES FROM THE YOU
KNOW THE HAVE LOW LEVELS OF
TEENAGE SCENE THEY BENEFIT FROM
A HIGHER LEVEL OF CBD.
THERE ARE. WELL KNOWN.
AND SCIENTIFICALLY SHOWN
MEDICINAL BENEFITS SO AT THE END
OF THE DAY IF WE HAVE AN
EXCEPTION FOR LEGAL PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS THAT THE EMPLOYERS HAVE
BEEN ABLE. TO ACCOMMODATE TWO
EIGHTY A THERE'S NO REASON WHY
WE CAN'T DO THE SAME FOR
CANNABIS THE QUESTION.
THAT THIS COMES DOWN TO IS DOUG
DO YOU BELIEVE OR DOES VALUE
BELIEVE DOES CANNABIS PROVIDE
LEGITIMATE MODESTO MEDICINAL
BENEFITS.
SCIENTIFICALLY IT SHOWS THAT IS
SHOWN THAT IT DOES NOT A MATTER
OF BELIEF. EVEN IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE IT DOES IF YOU'RE STILL
THINKING BACK ON THE REEFER
MADNESS DAYS.
THAT'S YOUR RIGHT TO HAVE THAT
OPINION. BUT THE REALITY IS THAT
CANNABIS DOES PROVIDE MEDICINAL
BENEFITS AND THAT THAT'S THE
CASE THERE SHOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR ONE THAT HAS.
CANNABIS THROUGH BEFORE
MEDICINAL PURPOSES TO HAVE THE
SAME RIGHTS THAT SOMEONE THAT
HAS PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
PAINKILLERS AND ABOUT A THOUSAND
OTHER TYPES OF PRESCRIPTION.
DRUG REMEDIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE.
AND THAT THE BALL THE SAME STEPS
ON THE SAME PROCESS HE'S THAT
DOES WORKERS DO AS WELL.
I AND SO OUT OF FOR THOSE
REASONS ON MY SUPPORT THE BILL I
DO THINK THAT THERE'S STILL AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT I KNOW. KNOWING
THE AUTHOR I KNOW THAT THERE
STILL WILL BE WORK DONE ON SOME
OF THE DETAILS OF HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT THOSE WORKPLACE
SAFETY ISSUES ARE RECONCILED TO
A TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE. BECAUSE AGAIN.
THE REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS
ACCOUNT FOR THAT THAT WOULD THAT
THAT SAFETY IS NEVER COMPROMISED
AND SO I CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD.
BUT I'M CERTAINLY GOING TO VOTE
AYE.
TODAY IN AND HELPED MOVE THE
BILL RIGHT NOW.
IF THERE'S A SECOND.
AND AND WHEN I LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS THOSE IN
OPPOSITION THAT WAS IT WAS. GOOD
TO HEAR THAT THERE WERE SOME
POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM
OPPOSITION ON THE WORK THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN DONE.
A SIMILAR GONZALEZ FLETCHER
FOLLOWED BY SOME MOMENTUM
MCCARTY.
SO IS HELPFUL TO OUR LOOK. ASK
SOME QUESTIONS OF THE BUILDING
TRADES AT.
I DON'T SEE THEM HERE.
.
SO.
I WAS ON THE FENCE I ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT WAS
SAID TODAY BOTH ON BOTH SIDES
WHICH MAKES IT REALLY HARD I
MEAN THIS IS. IT'S LIKE I GET IT
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS BUT THE SAFETY ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR SAFETY ISSUES IN THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES THE
HOSPITAL'S SOME OF OUR.
.
WHO ARE SENSITIVE WORK PLACES
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS?
MAKE THIS COMPLICATED SO I HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW.
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ARE NOW USED
AND WHETHER THAT NOTICE IS GIVEN
AT THE HIRING HALLS OR IS IT IT
NOT IN A. IN A WORKERS NOT
DISPATCHED TO A JOB SITE OR
GIVEN TO THE EMPLOYEE I DON'T
KNOW IF.
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT OF IF
SOMEBODY COULD ANSWER THAT.
SOME OF OUR GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
WE ARE ON THE LETTER NOW
POSITION WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OUR MY MEMBERS ARE
SIGNATORY THE CARPENTERS AND
LABOR'S AGREEMENTS.
THE WAY. I READ THIS COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS AS THE
ATTORNEY SAID. WORKERS AND
PROSPECTIVE WORKERS TO THOSE
FROM A HIRING HALL ARE OBLIGATED
TO TELL THE EMPLOYER IF THEY
WANT PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS TODAY.
I AS HE SAID FAILURE TO TELL
EMPLOYER WOULD RESULT IN
TERMINATION.
IF A WORKER FROM THE HALL IS
TELLS US WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
RETURN THEM TO THE HIRING HALL.
WE ALSO HAVE THE RIGHT AT THE
EMPLOYERS SOLE DISCRETION NOT TO
DISPATCH THE WORKER AND AS A
PRACTICAL MATTER IF A WORKER
TELLS US THEY AREN'T OPIOIDS
THEY WILL NOT BE DISPATCHED TO
THE JOB SITE TODAY. IF THAT
WORKER LATER DOESN'T TELL US
OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE TERMINATED IF
THEY TASK HIGHER THAN THE
PERMISSIBLE LEVELS THEY ARE
TERMINATED.
SO THAT'S HOW THAT PROCESS WORKS
TODAY OUR COLLECTIVE ARGUMENTS
ALSO SPEAK TO MARIJUANA.
AND SAY ARE YOU KNOW EXIT
TERMINATING OFFENSE THERE ARE
ALSO A NUMBER OF STATE LAWS
CALTRANS FOR EXAMPLE. IN THE
STATE HAS ITS OWN DRUG WE FREE
WORKPLACE RULE AS IT APPLIES TO
CONTRACTS WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
CESSATION OF THE PROJECT.
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS BILL
THERE ARE OTHER ELEMENTS THAT
HAVE TO BE FACTORED IN WE WILL
BE OUT OF COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE CONTRACTS.
IF A WORKERS TEST POSITIVE
ALSO WE HAVE THE HIGHEST WORK
COMP RATES OF ANY INDUSTRY ONE
IN FIVE. FATALITIES A CURRENT
CONSTRUCTION ON SO IT IS A
UNIQUE
SETTING. AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE
ASKED FOR AN EXEMPTION IN THIS
ARENA.
BECAUSE WE DO WE DO HAVE A ZERO
TOLERANCE POLICY TODAY FOR
OPIOIDS.
YET I THINK WHAT MY DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR EARLIER I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THAT ZERO TOLERANCE
POLICY OF HAVING WORKED WITH A
LOT OF WORKERS I'M ALSO GRATEFUL
THAT YOU NOW AT. THE SAME HIRING
HALLS IN THE SAME UNIONS HIGHER.
.
THEY HAVE A BROAD AND.
ARRAY OF FOLKS THEY'RE WILLING
TO HIGHER IN A LOT OF THE
POLICIES WE PUT FORWARD IN THIS.
IN IN THIS HOUSE TO SAY YOU
SHOULD BE IN NOW LOOK PAST
PEOPLE'S PAST ADAM.
INDISCRETIONS.
ARE ARE ARE. DONE WITH JOY IN
THE BUILDING TRADES AND A LOT OF
THINGS EXCUSE BUT I'M THERE'S A
NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE WORKERS.
.
WHO'VE GONE THROUGH THINGS IN
THEIR PASTOR ARE ACTUALLY
STAYING CLEAN AND SO AM I I
THINK I'M SENSITIVE TO IT
BECAUSE I'VE SEEN AND I'VE SEEN
HOW THE BUILDING TRADES OF
CHANGE PEOPLE'S LIVES IN.
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAD AYE AT
SO I THINK WE'RE GONNA WORK ON
THAT RATE WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
THAT IS A SPACE FOR WE'RE GONNA.
WORK ON ON.
.
THE DRUG FREE.
WORKPLACE ISSUES AND THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD AND WE HAD BRIEF
CONVERSATION I WANNA MAKE SURE I
UNDERSTAND THIS. I WAS CONCERNED
BECAUSE I DIDN'T REALIZE THERE I
DON'T. UNDERSTAND.
CANNABIS ENOUGH AND I HAVE A LOT
OF EXPERTS RAMMING THAT I
THOUGHT THAT THE PRESCRIPTION
WHAT NOT LIKE THAT.
WHO HAVE WORKED ON THIS ISSUE?
CALL LOWERED. THE POLICY
EXPERTS.
WHEN ORDER I WAS MAKING AND I
MEAN THAT THE SUIT MIGHT YOU
KNOW THERE MIGHT BE SOME
EXCELLENT. NOW JUST CHECKING.
MR FLORENCE YOU TWO AND NOW I'M
I'M TEASING AND.
YOU TOLD ME SO MY IN VISIONING.
PRESCRIPTIONS FOR MATT MEDICAL
MARIJUANA MAY BE OUTDATED.
INSIDE I THINK I WAS GIVING
REALLY BAD EXAMPLES OF LAKE SO
THAT YOU KNOW I I SAW THE
LITTLE.
OFFICES THAT WERE SET UP AND YOU
GO IN THERE AND YOU SAY I HAVE A
HEADACHE YOU GET A PRESCRIPTION.
YOU YOU A SERVICEMAN I WANT TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
THAT WITH THE CHANGE IN THE LAW
THAT'S CHANGED.
IS THAT CORRECT.
YES WE WE ADDRESSED.
THE ISSUE OF.
GETTING A ADOPTED RECOMMENDATION
TO BE LICENSED PHYSICIAN AND YOU
HAVE TO BE AN ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN
WHICH MEANS THAT YOU'VE DONE AND
EXAMINATION OF THE PATIENT
BEFORE YOU'VE GIVEN THEM THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR FOR MEDI.
CANADA SO WE THINK WITH THE
REQUIREMENT FOR THE LICENSING
WITH THE REQUIREMENT TO BE AN
ATTENDING PHYSICIAN.
FRANKLY WITH WITH.
WITH ADULT USE THERE'S LESS.
SEEKING OUT OF MEDICAL.
.
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT EVIL ANY OF
THAT WORK.
WHAT'S THAT UNTIL PEOPLE MONEY
IS AT WORK POSSIBLY AM IF IF
THEY'RE IN A BUT THAT RELIGION
OF PATIENTS WITH A DETERMINED
MEDICAL CONDITION AND EMPLOYER
CAN ASK FOR PROOF OF THAT
MEDICAL CONDITION.
HOW OFTEN DOES A PATIENT HAVE TO
RENEW?
THAT PRESCRIPTION.
BUT IS IT UNLIMITED I I I'M JUST
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THIS OR I'M
SORRY I KNOW THIS IS.
IT ARE CORRECT ANSWER THE
QUESTION SHORT SWORD EMPLOYEE
SEEKING PROTECTIONS UNDER THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE TO PRESENT TO
THE EMPLOYER THAT THEY'RE
SEEKING ACCOMMODATION AND THEN
THERE'S A JOINT THEIR
DISCUSSION.
AND.
ABOUT WHETHER THAT.
PRESCRIPTION IS GOOD ENOUGH IS
INSTRUCTIVE ENOUGH TO THE
EMPLOYER. AND WHETHER THE
EMPLOYER'S WILLING TO
ACCOMMODATE EMPLOYEE TO SAFELY
PERFORM FUNCTIONS BASED JUST
UPON IN IF IT'S IF IT'S NOT A
VERY SOLID RISK PRESCRIPTION. OR
SOMETHING MORE.
SO THE EMPLOYER CONTROLS THE
PROCESS OF INTERACTIVE PROCESS
AND IN IT IT AND IF IT'S AN
UNSATISFIED WITH A. POORLY
DRAFTED PRESCRIPTION.
THE EMPLOYER CAN DENY THE
ACCOMMODATION.
SO NOW AN EMPLOYER WHO HAS NO
MEDICAL.
KNOWLEDGE AT ALL IS GOING TO
EVALUATE WHETHER THIS IS A REAL
PRESCRIPTION OR.
KIND OF LIKE WE GET BY BECAUSE.
WE DON'T WANT HEADACHES
PRESCRIPTION.
I I DON'T MEAN TO MINIMIZE AND I
IN NO WAY GUYS I I. TOTALLY
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS REAL I'M
JUST.
WE ALL NOW RIGHT AND A PLAIN
PEOPLE THAT WE GOT A CARD HILL.
RIGHT HOW LATE IT NEEDED WELL
I'M JUST IT JUST TO JUMP IN A
QUICK AT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE MEDICAL RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM LICENSE PHYSICIANS NEED TO
BE RENEWED EVERY YEAR SO TO ADD
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
IT HAD UNLIMITED I'M SORRY I
JUST I I NEVER SEEN WHETHER YOU
COULD CONTINUE TO GET ONE EACH
YEAR IF YOU CONTINUE TO QUALIFY
FOR IT IF I GOT A PRESCRIPTION
SO IT'S NOT LIKE. I'M PAIN
KILLERS RIGHT IT PAINKILLERS TO
GET A PRESCRIPTION FILLS A
CERTAIN DO I GET A PRESCRIPTION
IT'S LIKE AN UNLIMITED AMOUNT.
FOR YET ANOTHER PRESCRIPTION
IT'S THAT IT'S A IT'S A
RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU CAN USE
MEDICAL CARD OUT OF IT I AM I
DON'T THINK IT IDENTIFIES
QUANTITIES MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE
CAN SHARE.
OKAY IS THERE ANY OTHER.
.
DRUG THAT IS PRESCRIBED IN THAT
MANNER.
WORDS YOU CAN UTILIZE THIS.
IN YOUR SELF REGULATING THAT
DOSAGES THAT AMOUNTS LIKE ALL
ALL OVER THE COUNTER.
CAN YOU NOT THAT'S MY
PRESCRIPTION NOT NUMBERS COULD
NOT SURE. OKAY SO THESE ARE AYE
AYE.
NO YOU DON'T NEED MY VOTE TODAY
BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME REALLY GOOD
PEOPLE WHO I'M SURE PASSING THIS
THROUGH BUT I'M I'M.
GOING TO GIVE.
MY VOTE TODAY BECAUSE I THINK
WORK ON TO SOMETHING I JUST
REALLY THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
THINGS MISSING. AND THIS IS ONE
OF MY BASIC QUESTIONS BECAUSE IT
IN THIS SITUATION SO WHAT I
ENVISION A MAYBE I HAVE THIS
WRONG AND I'M WILLING U. S. COME
IN AND TEACH ME BECAUSE.
NOW.
.
MY FAULT FOR STAYING AWAY FROM
OTHERS CAMPUS POLICY. SO MUCH OF
WHAT I'M UNDERSTANDING IS.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE A MEDICAL
CONDITION MIGHT DRAGREES WITH
ME FOR EXAMPLE I GET MIGRAINES
RIGHT. SO MY DOCTOR AGREES WITH
ME.
SHE PROVIDES ME WITH THE ABILITY
TO USE MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
IT'S UP TO ME TO DECIDE THE
DOSAGE THAT AMOUNT I USE WHEN I
USE THAT HOW I USE IT.
IN SO ONCE I GET THAT
PRESCRIPTION UNLIKE ANY OTHER
PRESCRIPTION SO IT'S NOT LIKE AN
OB OR YOU'RE LIKE ALRIGHT I'M
TAKING TWO OF THESE A DAY FOR
TWO WEEKS.
RIGHT OR WHATEVER. NOT VERY GOOD
AT.
MATT
SO I'M GIVING THAT TO MY
EMPLOYER AND NOW MY EMPLOYERS IN
A POSITION WHERE HE OR SHE HAS
TO.
FIGURE OUT.
HOW MUCH THAT IS IN HOW THAT'LL
AFFECT YOUR WORK PLACE SO IT'S
EITHER A ZERO DRUG POLICY
COMPLETELY?
OR PUTTING EMPLOYERS IN A WEIRD
POSITION TO FIGURE OUT HOW
IMPAIRED THIS MIGHT MAKE YOU I'M
JUST FEELING A LITTLE.
I THINK THAT'S MY CONCERN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER IT NOW WE
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A MAGIC
ANSWER.
AGAIN I'M A SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT THAT'S THAT'S MY CONCERN
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE.
THANK YOU.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
FOLLOWED BY SIMILAR MELINDA'S.
A SIMILAR THANK YOU I WANT TO
MAYBE
FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT THAT LINE
OF QUESTIONING BUT I CONCUR THIS
IS NOT A BLACK AND WHITE.
IT'S A LOT OF GRAY AND THERE'D
BEEN A LOT OF. CHANGES IN THE
WORKPLACE AND IN THE PAST AND.
DECADE OR TWO SINCE WE START
THINKING ABOUT A NIGHT FIRST
WIDE I AGREE THAT THERE IS A
DISCREPANCY.
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
PRESCRIPTIONS OTHER OPIOID SIR
ANTIDEPRESSANTS MANY THINGS THAT
YOU COULD TAKE FROM A DOCTOR.
IN GO TO THE WORKPLACE AND I MET
PEOPLE HERE LOCALLY WHO HAVE
OTHER THAT.
HAD ISA PHYSICAL AILMENTS.
OR ANXIETY RATHER ISSUES AND IT
HAD TAKEN BEFORE LEGALIZATION
MEDICAL ARE ONE AND WE TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN. LEAD NORMAL
LIVES AND GO TO WORK SO.
I DO RECOGNIZE THAT. I AM
SYMPATHETIC TO THAT SAFETY
ISSUES THERE.
CERTAIN PROFESSIONS YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY UP BUT A CRANE YOU KNOW
AND YOU WANT THAT PERSON
ENTERED.
TOLL BRIDGE YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT
HAVE YOU THERE YOU CAN MAKE IT
QUITE A FEW EXAMPLES OF CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS ONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE CERTAINTY THAT
SOMEBODY. IS ON THEIR THEIR
THEIR GAME.
SO.
MAY BE A YOU MISTER MISTER
BONTA AREA WITNESSES SKATE CAN
ENLIGHTEN US ON CALIFORNIA YOU
MENTION A CALIFORNIA WERE NOT
THE LEADER IN THIS THIRD TWELVE
OTHER STATES AND.
ANY BEST PRACTICES OR EXAMPLES
OF HOW THEY'VE ADDRESSED.
SOME OF THESE.
POSITIONS IN THE WORKPLACE.
IN.
SENSITIVE JOBS.
I'M SURE IT'S IT'S ONE THAT'S
BEEN ONE OF THE THE GREAT
QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING
AND AND ONE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE WITH SOME OF THOSE WHO
ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION.
FOR EXAMPLE SOME OF THAT THE
CONTRACTORS. ARE WHO WORK WITH
WITH SOME OF THE LABOR UNIONS IN
CALIFORNIA ALSO WORK IN SOME OF
THE STATES WHERE.
IT'S POLICY IS ALREADY IN PLACE
AND SO.
WE'RE GONNA HOPEFULLY HAVE A A
LONGER DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED THERE HOW THEY'VE
ADDRESSED THESE ISSUES. HOW
SAFETY IS IS APPROPRIATELY
ACCOMMODATED IN AND ACCOUNTED
FOR? THE WITH THE WITH THE ONE
THING I'LL SAY SINCE SAFETY HAS
COME UP A NUMBER OF TIMES.
IS THAT.
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
IT NEEDS TO BE ASKED FOR BY THE
EMPLOYEE.
AND IT NEED NOT BE GIVEN IF IT
WOULD POSE A DANGER TO THE
EMPLOYEE OR OTHERS.
SO THERE IS A STRONG SAFETY
PROTOCOL ALREADY BUILT IN.
TO EXISTING THE EXISTING FEE
HOUSE STATUTE THIS PART OF THE
CHANGE THAT IT CONTINUES TO
FOLLOW THAT SO IF IF AN
EMPLOYER.
RIGHTFULLY SAYS.
MISTER OR MRS EMPLOYEE YOU
CAN'T BE IN THAT CRANE.
TODAY IT'S A SAFETY HAZARD TO
YOURSELF AND THE REST OF OUR
TEAM HERE.
THEY'RE FULLY WITHIN THEIR
RIGHTS TO DO THAT FEE HOW SPELLS
IT OUT THAT YOU CAN DO THAT.
WE. ARE ALSO OFFERED AN
ADDITIONAL.
AMENDMENT.
TO SORT OF PRIDE ADDITIONAL BELT
AND SUSPENDERS ADDITIONAL
STRENGTH AND REINFORCEMENT
AROUND THE ISSUE OF SAFETY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO TO OFFER THAT
A AMENDMENT IT IT WASN'T ENOUGH
TO SATISFY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION THERE SOME INTEREST.
AROUND
I IN AND ENTIRE INDUSTRIES BEING
EXEMPT WE THOUGHT WE SHOULD TIE
IT TO A PRINCIPLE TO A NEXUS OF
SAFETY WITHOUT THAT WAS A BETTER
POLICY APPROACH. BORDER OPEN TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE A DISCUSSION.
I I DON'T HAVE THE DETAILS
TODAY ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE
FOR BEST PRACTICES IN OTHER
STATES THAT SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
INQUIRED ABOUT AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO INQUIRE ABOUT HOPE
WE HAVE MY ANSWERS FOR THE
DEADLINE IN THE LITIGATION
PROCESS IF.
AND THE COMMITTEE IS.
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL TAKES
ALLOWED TO MOVE ON AND THEN CAN
YOU AYE REITERATES WHAT BUT YOU
HAVE SAID. I KNOW THAT.
.
NO THEY NOW ASSISTANT MOST
CORRESPONDENTS ABOUT HERE
TESTIFY FROM THE BUILDING TRADES
TO.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE BEEN
MENTORED ENDS FAR AS THEIR.
THEIR CONCERNS AND WHAT YOU'RE
WORKING WORKING WITH WELL THEIR
BALL GENERALLY HAVE A DRUG FREE
WORKPLACE POLICY AND.
AND IF AN EMPLOYEE HAS A
PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
AND DOZEN REPORTED IN A TEST
POSITIVE LIKE FROM OPIOID. THAN
THE EMPLOYER CAN FIRE THE
EMPLOYEE SO THE DETERRENTS TO
APPEARING AT WORK IS THE DRUG
FREE WORKPLACE POLICY. AND THIS
BILL WOULD STILL BE IN HARMONY
WITH ALL THOSE.
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE THE EXACT
SAME PROCESS SO YOU KNOW THERE'S
A CASE FROM LAST YEAR WERE.
A TRUCK DRIVER TO MINING COMPANY
TOOK BIKE IT INFERS BACK AND
THEN REPORTED TO THE EMPLOYER.
TESTED POSITIVE AND THEN AFTER
THE TEST IT WILL HAVE THIS
PRESCRIPTION OF LIKE IN AN
EMPLOYER TERMINATED EMPLOYEE
BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO. TELL
ABOUT THE EMPLOYER ABOUT THE
PRESCRIPTION. AND THEY TESTED
POSITIVE AND BECAUSE THEY HAD
ASKED AN ACCOMMODATION AND AND
IT WAS A COMBINATION IS NOT
RETROACTIVE IT'S ONLY
PROSPECTIVE. IS TOTALLY LEGAL SO
WOULD BE THE EXACT SAME PROCESS
SO ANY EMPLOYER ALL THE DRUG
FREE WORKPLACE POLICIES.
WHICH STILL EXISTS INTACT IT'S
JUST THAT IF SOMEBODY HAD A
PRESCRIPTION THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO ASK COULD BE ACCOMMODATED AND
THEN THE EMPLOYER EITHER.
EITHER AGREED TO THE
ACCOMMODATION OR NOT NUCLEAR MAY
SAY THAT IT'S TOO DANGEROUS
FOR THIS PERSON AT THEIR DOWN
DAY THEY DON'T BELIEVE THE
PRESCRIPTION.
OR.
ON OR IT MAY BE TO GO IN THIS
CASE IT CAN BE A TRANSPORTATION
WORKER THAT'S EXEMPTED OR COULD
BE.
THE UNEMPLOYED THAT'S COVERED
BY THE WAY THE THE NINETEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT DRUG FREE WORKPLACE
ACT UNDER THAT ACT.
IN A WHICH WHICH COVERS A LOT OF
EMPLOYERS A LOT OF CONSTRUCTION
POURS A LOT OF PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
TO GET GRANTS. AND OF THAT ACT.
IF THEY KNOWINGLY HAVE EMPLOYEES
THAT USE THEY'RE GONNA PROBLEMS
SO. SO THAT WOULD COVER A LOT
THAT OF OF THE OF EMPLOYERS AS
WELL BUT THEIR VIEWS ACTION
PROCESS AND IN COURTS DEAL WITH
THIS ALL THE TIME. THEY JUST
DEAL EMPLOYEE HAS TO TELL
ANNOUNCEMENT COMPETITION
AFFRONT.
IF THEY DON'T TO GIVE ME A
VIOLATION.
SOME REMEMBER MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
NEITHER THE OPPOSITION NOR THEIR
SUPPORT.
THAT IT'S COME TO TESTIFY TODAY
HAS CONVINCED ME.
TO VOTE FOR AGAINST THEIR CAUSE.
I DON'T THINK THIS BILL IS
COOKED YET.
I THINK SOME VERY PERTINENT
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED THAT
YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO ANSWER
BECAUSE YOU JUST. HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THAT FAR ALONG WITH THE BILL
THINK THEY ARE VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS OR IF YOU TO GET THE
SUPPORT YOU NEED. THERE'S
QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
BE ANSWERED SO MY CONCERN IS
THAT HERE WE ARE VOTING ON THIS
BILL TODAY. A LOT OF VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS HAVE NOT
BEEN ANSWERED.
.
TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S POINT.
YOU KNOW I AM WELL AWARE THAT IF
YOU WANT A MEDICAL MARIJUANA
CARD IN CALIFORNIA. IT'S IS EASY
IS HANDING OVER THE CASH TO GET
ONE WE KNOW THAT THAT IS
UNFORTUNATE FOR THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY NEED IT.
WHOSE LIVES ARE HELPED BY THAT
THOSE WHO. END UP NOT BECOMING
ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE AN ALTERNATIVE IT'S
UNFORTUNATE FOR THEM THAT THEY
HAVE YOU KNOW. BAD ACTORS OUT
THERE WHO ARE DOING THIS AND WE
KNOW IT'S THERE AND WE'VE SEEN
THE INVESTIGATIVE REPORTS IN
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING NEW SO.
.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE EMPLOYERS IN A
POSITION WHERE.
.
WHAT IS A REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION AT AND WHAT IS?
IMPAIRED I GUESS THAT'S WHY I'M
WONDERING. WHO DEFINES THAT?
GIVE A.
YEAH.
.
SO AGAIN I MEAN EMPLOYERS DEAL
WITH US ALL THE TIME THOUGH GET
AN EMPLOYEE WHO SAYS.
THEY NEED TO TAKE LIKE IN AT
NIGHT BECAUSE I CAN'T SLEEP. AND
ALL OF THE DISCUSSION AND SEE IF
THEY WANT TO ACCOMMODATE THAT
PERSON AND IF THE PERSON IS IN A
SAFETY SENSITIVE POSITION THAT
MAY BE DRUG TESTED ARE THEY WHAT
ARE THEY GONNA DO.
AN EMPLOYER CAN DECIDE THAT A
COMBINATION OF NOT THEY HAVE A
MAJOR PROFESSIONALS OR THEY
DECIDE THEY ENGAGE IN THAT
PROCESS AND IF THEY'RE NOT
CONTENT.
BECAUSE IT'S AN INTERACTIVE
PROCESS WITH WHAT THE EMPLOYER
PROVIDES. THEN THEY'LL SAY THAT
THERE'S THERE'S AND WE'RE NOT
GOING THE OTHER COMMENT YOU
BECAUSE.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT CLEAR
ENOUGH THAT YOU HAVE AN
IMPAIRMENT YOU MAY NOT BE
QUALIFIED.
AND SO IF THEY DO THIS ALL THE
TIME WHETHER THEY HAVE A TRAINED
PROFESSIONAL THAT DOES IT.
AND REVIEWS THE MEDICAL RECORD
OR THE NOTE FROM THE EMPLOYEE
THAT SAYS THE CANTOR CAMPS TO
SOMETHING OR NOT. SO THEY REALLY
HAVE A LEGAL OBLIGATION IF THEIR
EMPLOYER THAT'S UNDER THE FEE
HOW OR IF HE A TO ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS. AND SIMPLY THIS WE JUST
OUTLET THE EMPLOYEE ASK
IF AN EMPLOYEE HAS A BOGUS.
MEDICAL AUTHORIZATION FOR
CANNABIS OF THE EMPLOYER CAN ASK
FOR MORE.
BUT YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING MY
QUESTION ABOUT WHO DEFINES WHAT
IMPAIRED MEANS.
WELL.
THAT'S A SEPARATE ASPECT I MEAN
IMPAIR MEANS THAT IF AN EMPLOYEE
BELIEVES THAT IF AN EMPLOYER
BELIEVES IN EMPLOYEES IMPAIR
WORK WITH THE USUALLY DO IS
THEY.
DAVID MAKE OBSERVATIONS AND
DECIDE THAT THERE'S A REASONABLE
SUSPICION AND THEN THEY ORDER A
DRUG TEST.
AND IF THEY ORDER DRUG TEST.
AND THE EMPLOYEE IS NOT INFORM
THE EMPLOYER THAT THERE HAVE
SOME MEDICATION THAT HELPS THEY
CAN BE FIRED.
BECAUSE IF I THAT THE DRUG TESTS
OF THE EMPLOYER DECIDES
IMPAIRMENT BY OBSERVATION.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DO ALL THE
TIME I MEAN THIS STANDARD IS
YOUR OBSERVATION POST AN
ACCIDENT PRE EMPLOYMENT.
THEY'LL DO A TEST BUT IF
THEY'RE NOT SURE IF THEY BELIEVE
IN EMPLOYEE APPEARS IMPAIRED AT
WORK. THEN THEY'LL DO IT
OBSERVATION BILL THAT MAYBE HAVE
TO AND THEY DECIDE WHETHER THE
PERSON IS ACTING BIZARRE.
LOOKING DIFFERENT AND THEY CAN
ORDER PERSON TAKE A DRUG TEST.
WHEN THE EMPLOYEE SHOWS UP WITH
THAT WITH THE CERTIFICATION AND
SAYS.
I'D LIKE AN ACCOMMODATION.
YOU KNOW THE EMPLOYER OUGHT TO
DECIDE WHETHER THE
ACCOMMODATION.
WHAT HAVE THE PERSON PARA WORKER
NOT THERE'S PLENTY OF JOBS WERE
YOU KNOW?
IN A VACANT TAKEN THAT IT WON'T
MAKE A DIFFERENCE OTHER PLANES
ALSO WILL AND IF THEY DON'T WANT
TO HAVE A TRUCK DRIVER WHO'S.
WHOSE.
ON BIKE IN OR BENZODIAZEPINES
THAN THEY WANT OTHER TRUCK
DRIVER THE CAN A COMIC THAT
TRUCK DRIVER SAFETY PERFORMANCE
FUNCTIONS.
CAN I ASK MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
PROBLEM SOMEONE FROM THE
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD TO
ADDRESS MY CONCERNS IS A LOT
LIKE TO HEAR BOTH SIDES OF THIS.
I DON'T CARE WHO IT IS JUST.
WE YOU WE NO ONE WANTS TO COME
UP SOMEONE.
MAYBE.
MONEY TO COME SIT AT THE TABLE.
THEY DON'T BITE. NAY NO.
.
SO.
MY QUESTIONS
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT NOW IS THE
INA WHO DECIDES WHAT IMPAIRED
IT'S EIGHT HE'S SUGGESTING THAT
YOU KNOW IT WHEN YOU'RE TELLING.
YOUR EMPLOYER THAT YOU'RE TAKING
THIS TYPE OF MEDICATION WHETHER
IT'S MARIJUANA OR SOME TYPE OF
OPIOID.
.
IF YOU TELL THEM AHEAD OF TIME
THAT'S ONE THING IF YOU DON'T
TELL THEM AND THEN THERE'S SOME
SORT OF ACCIDENT HEARD HEARD
SOMETHING THAT GOES ON IT
WORKING HAVEN'T TOLD THEM THEN
YOU HAVE A PROBLEM. BUT I JUST
I'M STILL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT DOES IMPAIRED MEAN WHO
DECIDES THAT AND IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE THAT
YOU'RE DRIVING A TRUCK OR
OPERATING A CRANE.
I MEAN THERE ARE LOTS OF OTHER
AREAS OF EMPLOYMENT WHERE THE
EMPLOYER.
WOULDN'T WANT YOU TO BE IMPAIRED
WHATEVER THAT MEANS SO CAN YOU
ANSWER OUT OF THE SECOND SO.
MARTY FISHER COACHING.
.
SO FIRST OF ALL I AM NOT AWARE
OF ANY.
PACIFIC JOBS WHERE AN EMPLOYER
WOULD.
WANT OR WOULD ALLOW AN EMPLOYEE
BE IMPAIRED ON THE JOB I MEAN I
DON'T I DON'T I WOULD HEARD FROM
ANY OF MY MEMBERS ARE MY
COLLEAGUES WHERE THEY SAY WELL
THIS PARTICULAR JOB IT WOULD BE
OKAY.
AND AS FAR AS DETERMINING
IMPAIRMENT.
THERE IS NO DEFINITIVE METHOD TO
DO SO OTHER THAN THE ONLY ONE
THAT THAT I'VE THAT I'VE FOUND.
IS THE.
CH P. THEY HAVE A DRUG
RECOGNITION EXPERT AND IT IS A
MAJOR TRAINING AND THEN THEY SIT
AND OBSERVE THE INDIVIDUAL FOR
TWO HOURS.
TAKE THE BLOOD PRESSURE BUT AS
FAR AS A.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE OF
BREATHALYZER FOR ALCOHOL.
IMPAIRMENT YOU HAVE YOU KNOW
URINALYSIS AND.
OTHER TESTS FOR TO.
DETERMINE OTHER OTHER TYPES OF.
DRUGS IN THE IN THE SYSTEM OR OR
IMPAIRMENT WHICH IS ALSO
DIFFICULT AND A LOT OF
SITUATIONS BUT FOR FOR MARIJUANA
IMPAIRMENT THERE THERE'S THERE
ISN'T ANYTHING THERE SOME. TESTS
THAT ARE IN DEVELOPMENT.
SO IT'S JUST.
IT'S IT CAN BE A JUDGMENT CALL
AND IF WERE.
.
WE HELLA EXPOSURE TOLITIGATION
BECAUSE WE.
SUSPECT THAT AN EMPLOYEE IS
IMPAIRED BUT WE CAN'T PROVE IT
SO. IF WE HAVE A DRUG FREE
WORKPLACE POLICY NOW WE WILL
USES ZERO TOLERANCE.
LEVEL SO BUT UNDER.
A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION IF WE
HAVE KNOWINGLY HIRED THE PERSON.
WITH A POSITIVE DRUG TEST FOR
TTC AND WE'VE ALLOWED WE'VE
HIRED THEM KNOWING THAT WE GIVE
THEM ACCOMMODATION IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT THE ACCOMMODATION IS BUT
THEN. WE DO A DRUG TEST TO TEST
THEM FOR IMPAIRMENT WE WE DON'T
HAVE ONE BECAUSE IF THEY'VE
ALREADY TOLD US THAT THEY'RE.
USING MARIJUANA THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO USE IN THEIR SYSTEM AND
WE BASICALLY SAID THAT'S OKAY
WHEN WE HIRED THEM.
AS IN THE ISLAM THING AND
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION.
OPEN THOSE THERE'S A QUESTION AS
TO HOW HOW THE TEST IS DONE AND
I HAVEN'T GOTTEN A STRAIGHT
ANSWER AS TO HOW HOW IF
IMPAIRMENT CAN MAKE. YOU CAN
FIND IMPAIRMENT YOU CAN FIND
OPIOIDS IN THE SYSTEM AND I
BELIEVE THERE'S A RANGE OF
LEVELS.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS
ONE THAT'S AGREED UPON THAT IS
IMPAIRMENT OR NOT
SO THERE'S NO STANDARD IN PLACE
FOR. OPIOIDS EITHER THAT.
I MEAN I'M I'M JUST TRYING THERE
THERE ARE.
I HAVE NOT I CAN TELL YOU I'M
I'M NOT CERTAIN I JUST READ IT
DEPENDS ON. YOUR YOUR.
YOUR BODY WEIGHT YOUR AGE YOUR
METABOLISM ALL MEDICINES AFFECT
YOU DIFFERENTLY THAT'S WHY
THERE'S RECOMMENDED DOSAGE DON'T
YOU EVEN JUMP IN THERE I SEE
LEANING FORWARD.
AND I WAS. THERE IS THAT THAT
RIGHT THERE IS A DIFFERENT
DOSAGE SO I WOULD IMAGINE THE
SAME IS TRUE FOR OPIOIDS.
OR FOR MARIJUANA OR ANYTHING
ELSE AND.
YOU KNOW YOU OKAY SO YOU GET A
PERSCRIPTION THAT IN YOUR DOCTOR
SAYS TAKE ONE BIKE AND IN THE
MORNING AND YOU DECIDE WELL I'M
REALLY A LOT OF PAIN SO MANY
TAKE TO.
WHILE.
HOW HOW IS SOMEONE SUPPOSED IN?
KNOW THAT IT I MEAN IT'S JUST
THIS IS REALLY COMPLICATED AND.
THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING I CAN'T.
I'M JUST NOT THERE TODAY BECAUSE
IT FEELS LIKE WE HAVEN'T FIGURED
OUT ALL THE KINKS.
AND I THINK MY QUESTION IS TO
BOTH OF YOU HAVE MADE THAT
PRETTY CLEAR THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF ANSWERS.
SAU I WE TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THERE ARE NO ANSWERS AND IT
IS VERY COMPLICATED.
I MEAN FOR THE PEOPLE LIKE I
SAID AND I WILL WRAP BUT MISTER
CHAIRMAN I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG
HEARING.
BUT FOR.
WE YOU KNOW LIKE YOUR YOUR
GENTLEMAN WHO CAME WHO IS THE
VETERAN WHO TALKED ABOUT.
.
HIS HIS USE OF MEDICAL MARIJUANA
AND FOR THE MANY OTHER VETERANS
OUT THERE WHO ALSO NEEDED OR
ANYONE FRANKLY WHO'S NOT EVEN A
VETERAN PEOPLE OF LEGITIMATE.
USES FOR THIS TYPE OF.
TREATMENT.
AND DON'T WANT TO GO ON
PRESCRIPTION OPIOIDS.
.
I THINK.
WHEN WE END UP PUTTING POLICIES
IN THE PLACE WHERE WE ALMOST.
DRIVE THEM RIGHT TO IT.
AND NOW WE HAVE THIS OPIOID
CRISIS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL NOT JUST A STATE
LEVEL. SO THERE'S THIS TENDENCY
TO THINK THAT IF A DOCTOR GIVES
IT TO YOU IT'S OKAY IT'S GOOD.
IF YOU DON'T GET IT FROM A
DOCTOR THAT IT'S THAT IT'S BAD
OR ITS I JUST.
GOOD LUCK.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY.
WELL THERE YOU HAVE IT GOOD
LUCK.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER.
NOT THAT I WANTED.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA FOR
BRINGING THIS FOR.
UNITE BOTH KNOW AS THE.
SOUNDING FIVE OF THE LAWS FOR
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
REASON WE EVEN GOT INVOLVED IN
IT IS BECAUSE.
THIS IS A OF CALIFORNIA VOTED
FOR MEDICAL MARIJUANA WE CAN
COME OVER REGULATIONS FOR NINE
OR TEN YEARS.
AND IT TOOK THE EFFORTS OF FIVE
OF US
TO CONDUCT COALESCING BRINGING
TOGETHER A LOT OF IT BECAUSE OF
FEAR.
FEAR OF NEW THINGS FAIRLY
UNKNOWN. AND THERE WERE SEVERAL
SEVERAL ATTEMPTS.
TO PROMOTE REGULATIONS FOR THAT
AND WITH THE EFFORTS OF
BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING
TOGETHER TO PUT THE ORIGINAL
MEDICAL MARIJUANA LAWS ENTER
INTO A FACT. AND I KNOW WE DID
IT.
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE GOT ACCESS.
TO REMEDIES THAT WE KNEW WOULD
HELP.
I WAS VETERANS WHAT IS GOOD
YOUNG PEOPLE WITHOUT CHRONIC
ILLNESSES SENIOR IF. WE KNEW
THAT THE MEDICINAL ELEMENTS OF
OF CANNABIS ARM. WERE VERY
IMPORTANT AND WE ALSO KNEW THAT
PEOPLE WEREN'T DOING IT.
OR THE PEOPLE THAT REALLY NEEDED
IT.
IT WENT ABOUT GETTING HOT.
AND AND SO I ALSO WANT TO SAY I
AM CONCERNED ABOUT BOTH SAFETY.
BUT THE OTHER THING THAT THE
GOVERNOR MESSAGES ABOUT
PRODUCTIVITY IN THE WORKPLACE.
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T
MISS THAT EITHER.
SAFETY IS REALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
EMPLOYEES.
AND I AND I GUESS IN.
PLOY YEARS BUT WILL PROBABLY
EMPLOYEES DIPPING A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE BETWEEN TRYING TO
TELL YOU. HONESTLY WHAT I'M ON.
BUT BECAUSE WE KIND OF HAD THIS
REEFER MADNESS KIND
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT CANNABIS
IS.
WE AUTOMATICALLY BELIEVE THAT
EVERYBODY THAT IT'S ON MEDICAL
MARIJUANA AUTOMATICALLY GETS
HIGH.
AND IS TEACH SEA LEVELS BETTER
CAN BE REALLY IN. NONE. TO VERY
VERY LOW.
AM WE NOT WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT EVERYBODY THAT'S ON MEDICAL
MARIJUANA.
CAN'T WALK AND CHEW GUM AT THE
SAME TIME.
.
YOU NO AND AND I GOT TO HEAR
THIS STUFF ABOUT IT DRIVE.
NOTEBOOK UP.
DRIVE TO DRUG OR PATHWAY DRIVE
YOU MIGHT IT MAYBE ALL OF THAT
BUT IT MAY NOT BE ALL THAT I
KNOW ONE THING YOU MAY NOT. BE.
A DRUG TO ANOTHER DRUG BUT IT.
IT DEFINITELY HAS HAD SOME GREAT
EFFECT ON AND HELPING PEOPLE AND
I WISH A LOT OF PEOPLE HERE
WOULD. USE A MODEM MEDICINAL
STUFF THAT'S OUT THERE THE MIGHT
EVEN CHANGE YOUR MIND ABOUT SOME
THE ELEMENT YOU HAVE AND WHETHER
NOT YOU CAN ACTUALLY OPERATE.
AND DO THINGS I MEAN THAT'S PART
OF THE PROBLEM RIGHT HERE THAT
THAT INDIVIDUALS.
BANKS ARE.
WELL.
I HAVEN'T SMOKED SINCE SEVENTY
NINE.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S SOME
STUFF OUT THERE. THAT.
BUT SO.
STRONG COMPARED TO WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN SEVENTIES. THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
ANYBODY GOING TO WORK.
IT IS SO STRONG BILL PASSED OUT.
AND SO JUSTICE IT WILL NEVER
HONEST DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN RECTORY
TIONAL USE OR ADULT USE. AND
MEDICAL BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE
TUMBLE MEDICAL HERE AND
HOPEFULLY STAY ON MEDICAL.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THIS
DISCUSSION.
SEEM TO BE. DEVOLVED INTO
RECREATIONAL AND THAT'S THE ONE
THAT WE DO WE REALLY NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT PRODUCTIVITY.
AND SAFETY
SAFETY IS MOST IMPORTANT AND
THE.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS A
VALID.
A VALID REASON.
TO BRING THIS UP I'M WORKING
WITH CHP ALONG WITH MISTER
BONTA.
DAY HAVE FIELD SOBRIETY TESTS
A CANNABIS.
THAT THEY WORKING ON INTO
PERFECTING FOOT WITH FUNDING
THAT CAME FROM US. EARLY ON WE
NEED TO GO AHEAD AND. BRING THAT
OUT TO THE FOREFRONT SO THAT
EMPLOYERS CAN ACTUALLY USE SOME
OF THOSE.
THOSE TESTS FOR THE CONTEST
BEFORE IF SOMEONE TELLS YOU TO
USE IN IT YOU CAN DO THOSE TYPE
OF TEST DETERMINE WHETHER THAT
THEY CAN OPERATE. ON DANGERS
MACHINERY BECAUSE WE DO NOT I
REPEAT WE DO NOT WANT THEM
OPERATING ANY TYPE OF LOVE.
MACHINERY.
AGAIN THIS IS
NOT NINETEEN EIGHTEEN.
IS NOT DIG NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
LET'S COME INTO THE FUTURE AND
MOVE FORWARD AND I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I KNOW.
THAT THE AMENDMENT YOU'RE TAKING
A THAT THINGS THAT YOU'RE
WORKING THROUGH. IS IS NOT THAT
IT'S HALF COOKED IT'S JUST THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE I GET
FULLY BAKED BEFORE WE GET IT OUT
OF HERE. AND THEN.
YOU WILL HAVE IT DONE O'DONNELL
DEBATE YOU KNOW.
PINE INTENDED EFFECT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT WAS AN
ARGUMENT IN SUPPORT ORGANIC.
BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR CALL I
WILL BE SUPPORTING TODAY THANK
YOU.
WE ARE MOST
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
PERSON I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US SUCH AN INTERESTING
BILL. AYE AYE.
.
I THINK YOU I THINK YOU WITNESS
THAT FOR MANY OF US THAT CREATES
A KIND A HEALTHY DISCOMFORT.
YOU KNOW I'LL SAY FOR MYSELF
THE IDEA OF SAFETY WAS PARAMOUNT
MY MIND IN SO MY FIRST REACTION
GUT REACTION WAS HOW CAN THIS
BE.
AND VERY SIMILAR TO THE
CONCERNS WE HEARD FROM OUR
EMPLOYERS TODAY.
I.
I HAD THE BALANCE AND TEMPER
THAT AGAINST THE NOTION THAT
SOMEONE MIGHT NEED. AN
ACCOMMODATION AND THAT ARE OUR
SYSTEMS HAVE ALLOWED FOR THOSE
WHO HAVE THE NEED FOR AN
ACCOMMODATION TO HAVE IT. AND IT
IT IS THAT THAT ALLOWS ME TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY.
I THINK THERE ARE QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAVE TO ANSWER I THINK WE
HAVE TO ANSWER HOW. WE BALANCE
THE NEEDS OF ACCOMMODATION WITH
SAFETY OF FOR THOSE IN OUR
WORKPLACES IN THIS IS CLEARLY
NEW TERRITORY. AND AND SO I HOPE
THAT AS YOU GO FOR WITH THE BILL
YOU WORK CLOSELY WITH OUR
EMPLOYERS. AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS RAISE CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW TO KEEP OUR WORKPLACE
A SAFE REGARDLESS OF THE TYPES
OF POSITIONS
IT JUST SEEMS THAT THERE COULD
BE THERE COULD BE CHALLENGES BUT
BUT THAT. WE DON'T DOT
CHALLENGES WE LOOK FOR WAYS TO
ANSWER THEM AND FIND WAYS TO
MOVE FORWARD IN WAYS THAT ARE
THOUGHTFUL AND SO.
THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL ALSO
ADDRESSED THE CONCERNS WE HEARD
FROM PLAYERS TODAY ABOUT
LIABILITY.
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THE LAW
SAYS ONE THING AROUND
ACCOMMODATIONS.
WE KNOW THAT OUR EMPLOYERS
COULD ALSO BE SUSCEPTIBLE AROUND
LIABILITY.
AND SO WE WOULD ASK THAT.
YOU MAKE THAT A KEY FOCUS OF
YOUR WORK WON'T FOR WITH
EMPLOYERS IN OUR STAKEHOLDERS
I HAVE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WOULD LIKE CLOSER TO THE COUPLE
GOOD QUICK COMMENTS FIRST.
I LOOK FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION THERE'S THERE'S
THINGS THAT I'M OPEN MINDED TOOK
TO LEARN ABOUT TO ADDRESS TO
IMPROVE ON.
AT TO THINK ABOUT I THINKS AND
SOME OF THE THINGS WHAT WHAT
WE'RE LEARNING ABOUT TOGETHER
DID IT'S IT'S SOME SOMEWHAT OF
OF NEW TERRITORY.
SO THE FOR TO.
.
A CLEVER PROCESS TO IS TO
EXPLORE AND STRENGTH IN THIS
BILL I THINK A LOT OF THAT
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD TODAY. ARE
NOT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT MEDICAL
CANNABIS THERE ABOUT THE
EXISTING FEE HOUSE SYSTEM AND
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION THAT'S
BEEN THE LAW FOR MULTIPLE
DECADES AND HOW IT APPLIES TO TO
ALL.
PRESCRIBE MEDICINES ALL WORK
AND AND AND. YOU KNOW I THINK
BECAUSE WE WATCH THINGS LIKE CSI
AND OTHER THINGS WE EXPECT THE
LEVEL OF EXACTITUDE WHERE YOU
KNOW.
WITH THE LEVEL OF PRECISION AND
AND AND CERTAINTY THAT SOMETHING
IT ACROSS THE THRESHOLD OR NOT
BUT. EMPLOYERS ACROSS THIS
STATE HAVE FOR FOR MANY MANY
YEARS NOW.
DEALT WITH JUDGMENT CALLS AND A
MULTIPLE INDICIA AND FACTORS
THAT LEAD TOWARD THE DECISION
ABOUT IMPAIRMENT.
AND DECISION ABOUT WHAT
ACCOMPLISHES. WHAT WHAT
CONSTITUTES REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION AND THAT WHAT THAT
WILL CONTINUE?
WITH WITH WITH ANOTHER MEDIC
MEDICINE A MEDICINE FRANKLY THAT
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DECIDED.
OVER TWENTY YEARS AGO WAS
SOMETHING THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA PATIENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO AND THESE ARE PATIENTS
WHO ARE BATTLING EPILEPSY WHO
ARE BATTLING CANCER FOR SOME FOR
WHOM THIS IS THE ONLY WAY TO
TAKE. HAVEN'T TO TO GET RID OF
THAT PAIN.
THAT THAT MAKES OUR LIFE
IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE
SO.
I THINK THOSE PATIENTS DESERVE
NOT TO BE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST
IN THE WORKPLACE
I THINK THAT. THAT.
BILLS SHOULD NOT BE HELD TO THE
STANDARD IN THE FIRST HOUSE IN
THE FIRST COMMITTEE THAT THE
READY FOR SIGNATURE THAT DAY THE
WHOLE REASON WE GO THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IS TO GET
THE INPUT OF VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS WITH DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES. AND DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES TO MAKE THE BILL
STRONGER TODAY HAS BEEN EXACTLY
THAT IT'S WHAT IT'S WHAT MADE
THIS BILL STRONGER BY RAISING
ISSUES THAT I WILL WORK ON
PURPOSE PROVIDES. SOLUTIONS AND
SO I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN MORE AND
AND GET INPUT AS WE GO FORWARD
I'M.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE SOME SUPPORT FOR MEDICAL
CANNABIS PATIENTS THAT
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST IN THE
WORKS IN THE WORKPLACE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE OF THE MOTION A SECOND.
PUSHING HIS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA.
OR NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES NOT
VOTING.
AND YOUR BILL IS OUT
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEGE THANK YOU STAFF.
THANK YOUNG TECH EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW.
YEAH. BUT I.
.
SO CAN WE GET A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT IS OUR MOTION FOR.
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I CONSENT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THAT CONSENT CALENDAR AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTY TO MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS WITH
RECOMMENDATION CONSENT THURMAN
AYE THURMAN AYE FLORA. FLORA AYE
CONSULTS FLETCHER JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
CONSENT CONSENT COUNTER IS THAT
WE HAVE SOME BILLS ON CALL.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BILLS ONCOL AB TWENTY FOUR
EIGHTY TO VOEPEL BAKER. ABSENT
MEMBERS THURMAN NO THURMOND NO
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER NO
MCCARTY NOW MCCARTY KNOW THAT
BILL FAILS THE BILL FAILS.
.
NEXT BILL ON CUT I ON CALL A. B.
THIRTY EIGHTEEN LOW.
ABSENT MEMBERS THURMAN AYE AYE
THURMOND AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE. UNTIL.
AB THIRTY EIGHTEEN IS OUT
.
DO ADD ONS FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY NINE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER OF FLORA.
FLORA NO. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE.
STILL.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTEEN EGGMAN
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE. ABILITIES.
YES I WOULD LIKE IT'S AN.
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY EIGHT
CARILLO ABSENT MEMBERS THURMOND
AYE THURMOND AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I AM MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE
.
YOU
HEARING IS ADJOURNED